is that loc.gov yes it is www.loc.gov
from the new orleans literary festival a
panel on the future of feature writing
panelists include chris hedges a nation
institute senior fellow and former new
york times foreign correspondent
catherine balton deputy editor of the
new york times and kevin allman of the
gambit weekly in new orleans the program
is an hour 15 minutes
delighted to have you all here
on this wonderful day in new orleans
this is an unusual panel
we are going to talk about feature
writing
but
as a genre that perhaps offers more than
just you know what you read in section b
of of the daily paper let me take a
second if you would
and introduce my fellow panelists here
some of whom may be more familiar to you
than others
proceeding simply in alphabetical order
kevin allman is our local boy
kevin is the editor of gambit weekly
which is our extraordinary alternative
weekly newspaper here in new orleans
[Music]
[Applause]
um
uh kevin uh his work has appeared in the
washington post in the los angeles times
the globe and mail in canada
and our own times picayune
as well as details vogue and other
publications around the country uh
interestingly particularly for the
purpose of this panel he's also a member
of the national book critics circle
a novelist
the title of his recent novel was tight
shot which was nominated for an edgar
award by the mystery writers of america
and he was also the winner of the 2008
walker percy southern playwrights
festival so he's a man who lives in many
genres
also with us today uh coming uh in from
new york uh is catherine bowden who was
actually on the program of the festival
i believe yesterday for a panel for the
master class she is the deputy editor of
the new york times magazine or was the
deputy editor from 1998 until just this
past october and she's now the books and
theater editor on the daily new york
times itself
her previous jobs at the times
included being deputy editor of the book
review deputy science editor of the
times and senior editor of the magazine
which again makes her especially
appropriate for talking with us today on
this topic
chris hedges
was
apparently elusive at the new york times
with it for many years but mostly
serving in overseas capacities he was a
foreign correspondent for nearly two
decades for the times also for the
dallas morning news the christian
science monitor and national public
radio he was a member of the team that
won the 2002 pulitzer prize for
explanatory reporting
as opposed to the other kind of
reporting i suppose which is simply
observating and confusing okay um any
and
in in addition uh he's the author of the
bestseller uh american fascists and the
national book critics circle award
finalists for the wars of force that
gives us meaning and most recently um
for a book published by simon schuster
when atheism becomes religion so thank
you all for joining us here in new
orleans at the tennessee williams
literary festival
[Applause]
we've been tasked today uh with talking
a bit about feature writing uh as a
genre um in the previous panel you might
have heard uh in the characterization
that
northerners will give you information
but southerners will give you a story
and feature writing perhaps uh is uh the
very genre that falls in between those
two areas a genre that uh is in
published in newspapers and magazines
ostensibly to convey
information
but on the other hand offers a great
deal more potential
let me let me cast it this way
is feature writing particularly with the
contraction and the decline of daily
newspapers around the country um what is
the role today what is the nature of
feature writing as a genre and what what
promise does it offer us uh that that
more conventional journalism might not
any of you want to start that off
as the editor here
surrounded by writers uh
i would say that the role of feature
writing um is going to remain strong i
think um
the the reason sorry the reason um
newspapers exist is to disseminate news
but i think a lot of the reason that
people read newspapers and especially
magazines even news magazines is
for an understanding of
not only the news but um
the news in a broader sense cultural
news sociological news
and what you said before about a story i
think is is always relevant in future
writing and so i'm i think that
people also just enjoy the narrative
element of feature writing and as long
as newspapers exist in some form um
maybe not in on paper as we
now read them but in some form that
feature writing has a
i would hope has a good future um
i think it's a an appreciated
form appreciated for
kevin you're also an editor as well as a
writer what's your sense of it
my sense of it is that nobody knows
where it's going right now it'll always
be around but in what form
yeah
there's no telling probably the
the mid part of the 20th century was
probably the golden age for that when
people would uh
sit down and read a 5 000 6 000 word
story that had a strong narrative and
all of that
there were hundreds of magazines that
would publish those things there were
advertisers that would support them and
now we're looking at i mean the
christian science monitor folded friday
went online only
um time and newsweek i doubt that
they'll both be in existence by the end
of next year um
and what really scared me was that the
new yorker and one of its
january issues was down to 10 pages of
advertising
and you know uh they're dumping
subscriptions you can get a subscription
to the new yorker for 24 dollars for 52
issues so i'm not sure
what form it's going to take people are
always going to want to do it but right
now
the crystal ball is really cloudy
i think part of the
decline of newspapers
and and you can see it in sort of how
thin local papers have become has taken
a tremendous toll on two aspects
of
reporting one investigative reporting
and the second is feature writing
and i think the cause
is the same these are both
very labor-intensive and time-consuming
activities
i began as a reporter now almost three
decades ago uh and have watched the arc
of that decline throughout my career
and i think uh that
without doubt
it is harder and harder to find good
writing in american newspapers
good writers have been shunted aside
the quality of the writing has
deteriorated markedly
and i fear as you do
where that's going to go i mean those of
us who can publish books i think
have
tried to keep alive our love of literary
journalism
but there are as you point out
very very few outlets now i mean we're
all sort of
competing for a handful of
publications places like harper's for
instance
whereas two decades ago there were
dozens
i i
want to revert
to my
optimistic future which is that i think
you're both right that um traditional
media as as we know them and read them
and hold them in our hands
are declining and certainly um the two
areas you talked about are
labor-intensive and expensive for um to
to foot the bill for
oh sorry okay um that basically what i
said is the traditional media i agree is
in decline but i think that um online
media is really really a thriving
area and i think even
that some of the traditional media have
very strong
online components and
but there are also a lot of
independent online magazines that are
publishing really good things slight and
salon i think are the best known of them
but
um
and
it kind of depends on how we define
feature writing if you include um
[Music]
personal essays and
political essays um
i think certainly they're thriving uh
but i also think that um just
online media is opened up a lot of um
area for good writing that
the decline of newspapers may be
shutting off let me respond to that i
i
i think the problem with online media is
that they've not attracted the
advertising base uh that supports that
kind of work that allows a great writer
like gay tales
to go out to hollywood and spend six
weeks
uh day in and day out writing that
classic story uh frank sinatra had a
cold
it is
extremely time consuming and costly to
do it and we see with newspaper websites
the new york times website is of course
a wonderful website
but
it only attracts i believe nine or
eleven percent of advertising revenue uh
and that's true uh for all newspapers
large and small uh the advertisers have
not migrated from newsprint to the site
and i think we also have to be clear
in understanding that new media
configurations
impose
their own demands on content
the average reader of the new york times
spends with a paper edition about 45
minutes with a paper the average viewer
of the new york times website spends
about seven minutes they use the website
the same way they use cnn or google news
or anything else to get headlines
they're not actually reading um and i
think that for those of us who are
readers anything that runs over 1500
words i'm and i'm sure i'm not alone i
have to print it out there
your eyes become exhausted uh uh trying
to read through
a complex and textured narrative
online um so i'm not as
optimistic i think that that the
internet imposes its own demands in the
same way that we saw television impose
its demands on
how content is shaped
i'm not as optimistic either and i'll
give an example right now as an editor
i've been wanting to send a rider down
to united home a nation which is down at
the gulf of mexico and it's american
indian community that was impacted very
hard by hurricanes gustav and ike and
tremendously undercovered by the media
in better times i might be able to send
down a writer for two three weeks to get
to know the people and to spin a
narrative that becomes a feature story
that tells the larger story through the
eyes of
of the people that went through it i
don't have that money or that time or
that space now so if i send someone down
it's going to be for two or three days
they're going to be doing a lot of
research on the internet beforehand
going down with a lot of preconceptions
and bringing back what's going to be
more of a
less of a feature and more of a hard
news story when it might be better told
as the story of human beings and not as
the story of wetlands being washed away
and all that
so
what you were saying about investigative
reporting i think is is very true we
don't have the time or the money or the
space for that anymore in many
newspapers and magazines and that's sad
well this conversation is taking a very
interesting direction uh in pointing to
among other things the technological
changes especially the internet
and their financial ramifications
chris mentions the the contraction of
advertising dollars
in the web page of the new york times
for example let me roll us back a couple
of decades just to frame this a little
bit because chris mentioned uh gay talis
in the 60s
and in the 70s
the so-called new journalism
was probably the greatest flourishing of
the genre of feature writing that
journalism has seen
in this country
if you think back for example to jack
newfield and the village voice of tom
wolf
an electric kool-aid acid test and as
well as a series of of other
works of new journalism before he turned
interestingly to fiction
um
esquire magazine along with the village
voice and gay tales often wrote for them
this was an extraordinary moment um it
then started to bend and metamorphose
itself you had the sort of red-headed
stepchild of the new journalism gonzo
journalism which became even more
participatory
particularly as practiced by hunter s
thompson
in fear and loathing in las vegas for
instance in which the journalist
not only embedded himself in the story
such as kevin was just talking about
assigning a writer to do but uh in in
the hands of hunter s thompson the the
reporter became the story uh became the
actor on his own stage so let's just
frame back for just a little bit of a
few decades because it's not that long
ago what was it that led the new
journalism or enabled the new journalism
to become
really the premier genre in this country
i would i would argue that it virtually
superseded even fiction uh in the
national consciousness and in the
literary community for about a decade or
a decade and a half
oh rolling stone was it was another
venue for tremendous journalism joe
esterhaas before he started writing
screenplays was a really terrific new
journalist
so what was it that made that kind of
feature writing
as as dominant as compelling and
powerful and and what has changed let me
there's also a cultural dimension to all
of this
we live in an image-based society
and
the decline that you mentioned
is
uh
part of our transformation
illiterate culture
to
an illiterate culture
42 million americans are
[Music]
functionally illiterate
another roughly 50 million are
semi-literate meaning they read at a
fourth or fifth grade level that's
almost a third of the country
and those people who are technically
literate
uh even people who have college degrees
opt into an illiterate culture they stop
reading
and
you see it in terms of the decline of
print based
material
across the cultural spectrum
you see it in the publishing industry
you see it with magazines you see it
with newspapers 80 of american
households last year did not buy a book
um and so
uh
much of what we're going is a very
frightening
cultural transformation
where
we believe i think of course this is a
an illusion that we can receive
information
through images
the two political campaigns that we just
went through for president
were based on personal narrative
and how we were made to feel they were
not fundamentally based on ideas
uh and that confusion of propaganda with
ideology
that
uh belief that
how we
you know how we are made to feel is a
form of knowledge i think is has been
has been as destructive as perhaps
anything else that has uh uh
gripped our culture uh since i as you
correctly point out this heyday of
of uh
of uh
literary non-fiction in the 60s and
70s
catherine or kevin
well to attempt to answer your question
about what gave rise to new journalism i
i was too young to actually really be
aware of um
the shift when it came
except that i was a reader um and i
don't know where it came from but i i
would um argue that we're going through
a concurrent kind of shift right now
with um
moving out from these traditional
magazines that we're talking about i
mean i i agree esquire
rolling stone the new york times
magazine where i worked for 10 years um
you know they're all publishing pretty
good stuff still but if you really
really want to read interesting material
it's on other kinds of
subjects i am in my master class
yesterday urged the
people in that to read the um best
american magazine writing the thing that
the national magazine awards as me puts
out every year it's full of amazingly
really great writing but it's being
published in places that you probably
haven't heard of in magazines like seed
and
that's the only one i can think of off
the top of my head but
there's a great piece in that magazine
that was published in seed uh i mean in
the book form of it um so
i do think that
now that by necessity
um
we a feature writing is kind of seeing
also a change maybe not as dramatic and
maybe not as lasting as
the rise of new journalism and maybe
that was just because there happened to
be
a number of really really spectacular
writers coming to
maturity at that point and some really
brilliant editors um
certainly um you know the editors at
esquire rolling stone made an enormous
difference in
in the rise of
that kind of journalism
um
now i think it's more um
[Music]
the shift is more
a response to the necessity for a shift
but to me it's producing some pretty
good stuff so
kevin what's your take on this we're all
so cheerful here today aren't we
it's the most depressing challenge i've
ever heard is george bush still
president that you know did i miss
something okay um i i think there's a
couple things um one
one is that we don't we don't have
kind of the national media bonds that we
used to i mean a cover story in time
magazine
50 years ago
would be the talk of various social
classes various races i mean this this
would bind the country same thing with
the nightly news and walter cronkite and
huntley brinkley and all that what was
said there was shared among a vast vast
uh
variety of americans we don't have that
anymore it's not it's everything's on
cafeteria plan um
so you pick the news that you want to
watch and it's usually the news that
reinforces your own preconceptions about
the world whether it's keith olbermann
or sean hannity
you pick the radio that you want you
pick all these things none of that is
conducive to feature writing to feature
journalism which by necessity
tells a story
somewhat akin to fiction um
i i mean i i can't even really think of
uh
i'm trying to think of something in the
last 10 years some lap feature story
that had everybody in the country
talking can anybody think of that
well
i think you're touching on the very
thing let me jump back one step even
further prior to the new journalism in
the 60s and 70s
the period that i would uh argue in
which american journalism flourished was
much earlier and was
they were called the muckrakers uh
people like lincoln stefans and ida
tarbell
um and uh you may recall and it took a
literary form also in upton sinclair's
the jungle
and what they were doing was writing
about industrial conditions they were
writing about social conditions and what
these two periods of flourishing of
feature writing had in common i'm going
to toss this out as a hypothesis
is these were moments of great political
tumult
when the status quo was being challenged
um by
progressive labor unions in the early
part of the century and the rise of
socialism before it was frightened
underground by the red scare
and then its resurgence during the
vietnam war and the civil rights
movement and ultimately the feminist
movement as well
and feature writing seems to take its
heart and gets its pulse rate uh racing
when it has something
to engage with that means something that
changes lives
when it's not just entertainment
um
and uh it's more than just a coincidence
that that is when future writing seemed
to have so much heart and so what i'm
going to ask here is um
is is that part of what happened um
in the in the 90s um
have uh
under the era of george bush and not not
to be overwhelmingly partisan and lay it
all at his door a lot of these problems
the economics undermining uh the major
newspapers and magazines certainly
pre-existed george bush
but can i say and this is no defense of
george bush but the media was really
shitty
when it came to covering what george
bush did
really really bad i mean we look back
and and
i mean no offense to the new york times
but you know um
i'm sure you had nothing to do with that
but um
and and i guess i don't entirely agree
with you michael because one of the best
pieces of feature writing that i
remember in the last 10 years was dana
priest in the washington post
um who and the post gave her the time
and the resources and the support to do
the walter reed medical center expose
and i think it took nine months
and tens of thousands of dollars
and that made a difference that was
something that i think everybody in this
room remembers and talks about and all
that that was the last piece of really
good feature writing and she used the
stories of the soldiers and she's the
stories of the nurses and she's the
stories of the bureaucracy
and uh it just pulled out a hell of a
piece of journalism
okay part of what our oh go ahead i i
think that that the landscape has
changed i mean you're certainly right
about the muckrakers uh and about the
new journalists in the 60s that there
was a kind of
passion which i think is extremely
uh
healthy
um and something that established news
organizations like the new york times uh
deal with very uncomfortably
um
but the fact is
the the the broad mass of the literate
culture turned to print
organizations print
mediums in order to get their
information
and that has changed
uh profoundly
uh
you know we rely now on primarily
electronic
uh conveyors
of
you know information
and
most all of these are corporatized i
mean the there are about six or eight
companies viacom
rubert murdoch's news corp
disney general electric that control
just about everything
except for some of these very marginal
uh publications
uh and a few community radio stations
that we see
hear or read and uh the bottom line of
of the corporate
of corporate entities is profit
and it is about the lowest common
denominator and it is about appealing to
everybody and it is about not angering
their advertising base
i think we're all talking about
different things here i i don't
i think um first of all i don't think
dana priests uh what she wrote was
feature writing i think it was it was
investigative journalism um
written large
um and i don't think newspaper writing
for the most part is feature writing um
to me i mean maybe we should all define
what we think feature writing is to me
feature writing is um
is a way to address a subject that may
have something to do with the news but
in which essentially what you're doing
is telling some kind of story that is
behind the story um
and
telling it in a narrative way
it it can appear in a newspaper there's
certainly you know kinds of feature
writing that do appear in newspapers but
um to me primarily feature writing is um
is magazine writing it it it can become
book writing a lot of magazine pieces
become book writing but i don't know do
you i mean
why did you mention dan and priest as
feature writing
because this was the closest thing i
could think to it to to
um some
to an organization that would actually
devote the time and money that would go
into something akin to feature writing
because i think that is the main problem
now um you know unless you're john
wenner who's going to pay matt tybee to
travel around the country to do these
you know kind of
nouveau hunter s thompson pieces
unless you have that kind of backing
financially and and in your gut you're
not going to get good feature writing
i i do think a lot of magazines are
still you know backing um reporters to
go out and spend some time i know the
new york times magazine um
you know we're not going to send
somebody to travel around the country
for two or three months but we'll send
somebody to uh or at least we would up
till this year i don't think we're
sending anybody anywhere anymore
um
you know to um central america to report
a story or uh to give them the time to
report a story over a period of time um
not a whole lot more money to do it but
certainly the time to do it and the and
the expense money to to travel to two or
three different places and i think other
um
of these dying major magazines still
also do that i think that right but
they're very they're very few i mean you
know the you know we can sit here and
just start ticking off
uh you know they're they're the
landscape is so diminished i mean you
can't argue that's just factually true
yes you're right the new york times
magazine will still do stuff and the new
yorker
but these smaller magazines like seed
i i can i don't know the magazine but
i'm pretty certain they don't have a
budget that they can hand somebody uh
thousands of dollars to go off for weeks
and do this kind of work um and it and
it it it takes that kind of time and it
takes those kind of resources in order
to produce something of that quality
i don't know seeds budget either so
but again if you think uh and
if we are suggesting that the economics
um and this battle
between the the business office and the
editorial office uh in american
journalism
goes back to the inception of journalism
itself i mean these debates were going
on in the early 19th century
in newspapers and yet at some point
and and i would suggest it was often
through alternative presses you know
kevin you're uh the editor of the
alternative weekly here um and one of
the reasons that newspapers like the
village voice chicago reader the phoenix
uh who are all host financially right
now who are we all you know the creative
loafing which has a chain is you know
applying for bankruptcy the village
voice is a husk of what it was
you know we're
it's great to see alternative but
they're they're just not making the
bills
but cheerful again
well it's it's it
you know some sometimes uh
it's from it's from the the slough of
despair that ultimately uh you know we
we emerge
and rearrange i really didn't plan on
taking this direction in this
conversation
i was philly feeling pretty cheerful
myself before this whole conversation
began
different levels of publications and
personally i find the locals are
flourishing they are doing a magnificent
job because they are taking me
and taking my work which i do very good
work and they know the big guys
don't want me anymore because they can't
afford it so they are welcoming me in
with open arms and i'm sorry but i'm
tired of hearing all the
negativity well it's not a matter of
it's
it's not a matter of being negative or
you know being a pessimist or an
optimist i mean i was a war
correspondent for most of my life and
people who didn't uh very quickly grasp
the reality of the landscape around them
often didn't live very long
it's a matter of looking
at
the factual
data
that as kevin has pointed out
is deeply disturbing about uh
media alternative media that we all care
deeply about and that have been such an
important element in american democracy
in providing alternative voices um
that it's just true i mean they they are
you know and kevin just talked about the
phoenix and the voice and um go to new
york and pick up the voice and and pick
up with the voice as to what it was
which is a local paper by the way i mean
it's an alternative local paper so
right well the
the
for those of us who write for magazines
um it's just indisputable
that
the
outlets that we have are diminished and
those that remain are are are really
hanging on by their fingertips i mean
that's just a fact and and for those of
us who care about writing and see
and and not just as a kind of art form
or a passion but believe i think i'm as
i'm sure all of us do at this table that
it is uh an absolutely essential element
it's one of the pillars of our
democratic society
that this isn't just about the decline
of newsprint or the decline of magazines
or
the decline of feature writing
uh
you know
remaining in a print-based society in a
print-based culture allows a populace to
deal with ambiguity with nuance with
complexity with other points of view
instead of being fed these thought
terminating cliches that are pumped out
over the airwaves on this this has an
existential
element to it
that is
deeply
uh important for the maintenance of our
open society
[Applause]
here's one of the ironies particularly
we'll get to the q a in a little bit
okay give us just a few more minutes
okay they got to earn their honoraria
okay
the um
ironically we were talking
southern culture was the topic of the
previous panel
and rick bragg for example one of the
great practitioners of the southern
story talks about that oral tradition
because his people from northern alabama
they in fact
don't read
and thus the oral tradition become
became dominant
and was a very important device for
cultural continuity for shared values uh
and for commentary but here's the irony
it seems to me in our contemporary
culture and this may this may illuminate
what why feature writing is threatened
we have a new form of oral culture
what is supplanting print journalism um
is television talk shows uh the pundits
uh the sean hannity's um you know and
and people of that ilk um but it's it's
instantaneous it's off the top it's not
reflective it's not investigative and
i'm not even gonna you know
i don't think we even want to go in the
direction of the extreme of this uh new
form uh uh rush limbaugh uh which is is
is the very worst example of it but what
has happened culturally if we think of
the implications of this is we are
bombarded with information daily there's
a dozen of these men and women on tv
every single day uh chattering away at
us blathering away at us
but
how what does it say about a culture
that is now moved from being a literate
culture in which long deliberative
investigative pieces have been
supplanted
uh by just instantaneous uh and daily
chatter and i think chris it's a little
bit of the of what you're talking about
in terms of the political implications
there was a great book written in the
early 50s by the british social critic
richard hogarth called the uses of
literacy in which
he saw
a lot of this coming
and
he
he understood
that the creation of mass culture
meant the destruction of another culture
which was oral culture
it replaced oral culture
and
he wrote it at the perfect time in which
he was able to document that destruction
among the working class
in england
and so
the you're very right that we have a new
national narrative common vernacular
built primarily around trash talk
and celebrity gossip
and trivia which has corroded and
infected news is passed off
as news so that
we are not only uh entering an
image-based world an image-based culture
one that is essentially
post-literate
uh but we are destroying
those uh
the the the
the the viewpoints the expressions
the
distinct individuality
and i think
one could argue even the complexity
of human life
by
eradicating the power of both our
literate and our oral culture this would
certainly be hogar's argument i think he
was onto something
i can't argue with any of that
i mean i'm
the rise of trash tv is
devastating for um
public discourse but i don't think it
really has much to do with feature
writing i i think
uh uh to go back to where i started i do
think there's a very very strong new
forum for virtual writing and that is
basically online journalism you may
print it out but um
it's still there and it still is
journalism that is uh
is produced there's and disseminated
without all the traditional hindrances
of
that are now you know affecting
newspapers which is the cost of paper
the cost of ink the cost of trucking
uh the cost of distribution
um and
i think that actually um there's a very
very thriving uh community of writers
and readers uh online um you you need to
know where to look for them i don't
think there's um
a mass readership for anything but i
actually don't think there's ever been a
mass readership for anything i'd love to
know how many people actually uh read
the jungle you know i mean maybe it
seemed like everybody was talking about
it but my guess is oh no i'm sure we've
all read the jungle but i mean
i i think it it
there we think back to things that
everybody was talking about but really
those everybody were probably as you
know sort of
small a group as everybody is today um
and
i i think that we are
evolving into
we're not there
and certainly the advertising uh model
isn't there and if it can't be paid for
in the end it's not gonna thrive but i i
think they're gonna figure it out and i
i do think that um you know
my kids generation i have a 25 year old
son
is is um he's very literate and he does
almost all his reading online uh and
i don't think that's so unusual these
days
and i think he's really really
interested in reading and i think a lot
of kids are well katherine let me ask
this the it's possibly the relationship
between feature writing as you yourself
uh intuited a few minutes ago in
response to kevin um much of the feature
writing we've been discussing has
actually tended
not all of it the rolling stone not
necessarily but much of it it's also
been close to investigative journalism
one of the great strengths of the
alternative weeklies
the ones that we mentioned which are now
very much in jeopardy
was the investigative journalism that
they were doing or the cultural
commentary that they were doing which
the mainstream press uh would not well
they are the mainstream press these days
whether they want to admit it or not
they've been around 50 plus years they
are mainstream
okay now
they've obtained a degree it's like
james agee writing about the worst thing
that can ha and let us now praise famous
men the worst thing that can happen to
an artist
is social acceptance um that that art uh
art thrives on its marginality
this may be why the southern tradition
is so rich
we certainly thrive on our marginality
in that regard uh but i don't think this
is an incidental coincidence in all
seriousness um
the new journalism and and the
muckrakers both vote what those two
periods had in common is they uh they
were investigative uh they were also
very politically conscious and they were
alternatives they tended to be driven by
ideologies that were counter to the
prevailing here's one of the interesting
things about the new york times if you
ever study the structure of journalism
this goes back to where feature writing
diverges from traditional journalism
new york times is a very interesting
institution um ever notice that how many
articles
on the front page of new york times say
special to the new york times right
as if it has
an elevated status it has a privileged
status and obtaining information that
nobody else can one of the other
interesting devices if you study
patterns of journalism the new york
times more than any publication
relies on unnamed highly placed sources
if you were to go through the new york
times and look at the number of articles
that don't quote a source
and that rely on that privileged access
now this leads to certain abuses you may
recall during the vietnam war this led
to a highly placed
source in the administration referring
to the absolute brilliance of the
policies of henry kissinger
in navigating the vietnam war
the highly placed source commenting on
dr kissinger was dr kissinger
but it had to do with the structure of
the journalism
itself now feature writing one of the
things that made it different is it had
a very clear individual voice
and the reporter the writer of it uh
whether it was uh in the old period a
lincoln stefans or jack london before he
turned to fiction
or during the new journalism period tom
wolf or hunter s thompson
they had a voice
and the journalist himself was an active
agent jack newfield in writing for the
village voice
always in his articles revealed the news
gathering process itself he demystified
it he talked about picking up the phone
and talking to the deputy mayor right he
didn't it wasn't a highly placed source
privileged only to the village voice it
was jack newfield picking up the phone
and talking to the deputy mayor and
embedded in the very structure of the
journalism and the genre was the news
gathering process and it didn't mystify
very much revealed itself so let's see
if we can
come come back around
the
charge we had in coming on this panel
was to talk about how feature writing
was distinct from other forms of
journalism and maybe maybe this will
help clarify because uh catherine you
you i heard that plaintiff cry before
what are we all talking about okay well
who are some of the best examples of
feature right new york times um
you're going to pick up that gauntlet
okay
go for it uh there's a dueling oak in
central park it's true okay that um
sources are allowed to remain anonymous
perhaps more often than they should be
um the times reporters
are our rules of conduct are that um
with an anonymous source the editor has
to know who they are
uh and the editor
asks and is always told who they are um
the kinds of stories that anonymous
sources appear in where they don't need
to appear actually happen to be feature
stories
for the most part where you know
somebody just doesn't want to be named
for some reason because just want to be
a public figure
i think with news stories where
anonymous sources appear and by the way
when that happens in future stories we
have our eagle-eyed public editor who um
will haul anybody up on that and does
repeatedly
chris can talk to this more than i can
because he was a news reporter for a
long time but um there are a lot of news
stories that uh you just simply won't
get unless you guarantee somebody
anonymity and that's why those things
continue to exist there's a kind of
tension
um because as catherine points out
correctly
there are moments when you must turn to
an anonymous source i can tell you
having covered conflicts
that
literally
by naming certain people in a story they
could be killed
and i've even interviewed during i
covered the war in el salvador for five
years i would many times interview
illiterate campesinos who would give me
their name
but the kinds of things that they were
telling me
i understood would put their life in
jeopardy either by the military or by
the fmln which was not a rebel movement
which would occasionally carry out
executions of people that they
considered to be pro-government and
territory they controlled so i wouldn't
print their name
the tragedy is that
you have reporters judy miller would be
a perfect example who abused that
i think important aspect of news
gathering and she of course
anonymously quoted
lewis scooter libby
to publish falsehoods
in the new york times and then
staged a little soap opera where she
went to jail
to
in essence defend somebody who
had leaked the name of valerie
uh plane
and uh in a kind of retribution against
her husband who had been a whistleblower
so
uh it really boils down to the ethical
composition
of the reporter
and i think that's why
uh you know
ethics are are so important within
journalism but there has to be a place
for
the
anonymous source uh because many people
within institutions i mean it's no that
when i covered el salvador again during
the reagan administration the death
squads were killing between
800 and 1 000 people a month
and there were
members of the
state department in the embassy in
san salvador who
leaked to the press
informations about government complicity
with the death squads uh and
that information was important for the
american public to understand this was
at a time when
congress had to certify every six months
continuing aid and it created a kind of
pressure
until finally there was an active part
in the u.s government
to shut the death squads down
and so
this
the tragedy is that
this
is an extremely important
uh ethical responsibility on the part of
the reporter and
it has the capacity to be misused and it
has been misused it was misused
by
michael gordon and judy miller in the
build-up to the war in iraq
and
it's a terrible stain on the new york
times
which is flawed as all institutions are
flawed uh but then there are also many
examples where i think it has been used
correctly to
the the betterment of our common good
and to the society at large
i would say there is also um
i i i would defend it in a lot of kinds
of feature writing as well i think if
you're writing about um
uh children um
in a lot of cases um
you simply i mean if it's a child who
has um some kind of a disability mental
disability or
um
[Music]
we once did a story in the magazine
about a high school junior high school
kid who was a cross-dresser and nobody
in his school knew he was a crossdresser
it was a really interesting feature
story that said a lot about
what was then kind of an evolving
phenomenon if we had named that kid um
that he would have been lynched in his
in his middle school i mean it was
it was that or or no story um
what the times does uh however is um
even though they'll disguise a name in
feature writing n and news reporting
you're never allowed to use anything
that is not um in some way accurate if
we use initials they have to be the
initials that are the person's actual
initials if we don't use a name at all
if we use a descriptive term it has to
be something like um you know
that is an accurate description
we don't allow conflation of um
two different characters into one judy
miller i'm basically i think is
responsible for
the enormous distrust that people have
of um newspapers period now and
and that's a tragedy i mean
it is something that we can't recover
from in the interest of full disclosure
i am a lifetime subscriber to the new
york times and it was but it's hard to
come back from something like that um
just as it was from you know our
previous
scandal yeah i was really trying to in
in raising that issue of of different
styles and structures of types of
journalism um i was trying to get us
back to the question of what
characterizes feature writing
and the reason i brought up anonymity
in a story was to contrast it with the
very personal voice of some of the
stronger pieces of new journalism
we've got a few minutes left for the
panel to talk before we can toss it open
to questions from the audience um who
are let me uh kevin you wanted to say
i'm just going to say
let's talk about feature writing this is
the there you go
um probably the best feature writing
i've read in maybe the last two years
was a piece by a woman named nancy
rommelman who's written for some new
york publication she's in portland
oregon
and she doesn't work much because she
needs to feel that pull to get into
these things but um
in portland there was a case of a
terminally ill child that had
tremendous support from the community
mother completely devoted to her um
every year one peter or paul from peter
paul and mary would come to town and
they'd do a concert and raise money and
this child had everything wrong with her
and
after peter or paul left that night
child was about 14
the mother
put a lot of sleeping pills in the
daughter's nightly medication took
sleeping pills herself and they went to
bed together and died
and this was on all front page of the
oregonian and this was on the front page
this was on top of the news of what a
tragedy this was
and nancy thought there was something
fishy about the story
and she went and she dug and what she
came up with is an amazing i think it's
about 3 500 word story
about a child that wasn't sick
and it was a case of munchausen's by
proxy
and she went and she said and the child
had supposedly had all these injuries
and surgeries and all that stuff and she
saw the corpse and there wasn't a cut on
it
and it was just an amazing
piece of feature journalism that not
only blew away would have been done
before but also brought her nancy into
the story as a mother and who could do
something like this and why
and i still remember it ending with her
i mean she obviously
i wouldn't say fictionalized it but
imagined what that last few minutes
would be like
of a child that was used to taking
medicine every night
giving her the last minutes that she'd
ever take
and then setting the scene with the
police found in bed which was the two
curled up together
and um
that was an extraordinary piece but i
think it took about six months to do
and she didn't make a damn dime off of
it by the time it was done i mean um it
was hundreds of hours of work and she
probably got a couple thousands of
dollars for it but um
that's the kind of thing that i would
like to see more of but
i just don't
even when you write as i do for a
magazine like harper's
which will pay roughly a dollar a word
uh
and expenses
by the time you're done
you're working for minimum wage
um especially if you go overseas
uh the logistics the writing the editing
the reporting
um so
when we talk about the glory days of
feature writing
when you put that kind of work into it
nobody's getting rich
you know these are are labors of love
uh and and i think that what i hear
especially kevin saying in which i
concur with
is that now even that
minimal financial backing
to carry out
this kind of work
is
disappearing
and
you know we all have to pay the rent
we all have to go to the grocery store
there are just hard facts i mean writers
don't make a lot of money
there are just hard facts about
existence
that while we certainly
will try and continue to do it
is making it harder and harder and
harder
tell us um speaking of trying to help a
writer make a little more money tell us
a little bit about your most recent book
um
when atheism becomes that's what i was
going to say
one way a future writer can make more
money is by having it but i live off of
my books i mean and
and i'm fortunate um you know a lot of
writers can't i'm you know
several of my books have sold extremely
well
so i can between giving college
lectures and
advances i can survive
it's a precarious existence but it does
allow me to do what i want to do the
book on the atheism is a little it's not
feature writing it i i graduated from
seminary at harvard divinity school i
wasn't ordained but i finished all the
academic work and uh
when i came back from uh
my time overseas i had watched how the
christian right had moved from the
margins of
american society under the bush
administration of the very epicenters of
power and spent two years writing a book
called american fascists the christian
right and the war on america
and then after that book came out went
out and debated the new atheists sam
harris at ucla
and then two days later i went to san
francisco and debated christopher
hitchens who wrote god is not great at
berkeley not an experience i would wish
on anyone in this room
and it was it was an appalling reaction
i mean when i read through the work and
debated them to see how they in the
language of scientific rationalism
had replicated the very
ideological structures that i had just
spent two years writing about in the
christian right and look i graduated
from
a seminary at harvard which i think has
done more than any other seminary in
america to produce atheists
i
i have a healthy respect for atheism as
a valid
philosophical thought all the great
reformers including martin luther and
spinoza uh were not only denounced as
atheists but heretics but what we see
here is
a new kind of fundamentalism and uh so
it's not a feature piece it's an idea
book uh and uh it
and i you know that's another panel but
that's what prompted me to write the
book i came back just furious
well the audience has been very patient
with us up to this point i i thought i
saw a few people twitching
except for ucam but that's all right
deborah okay
um are there any questions uh that uh
are burning within you that you would
like us to address there is a microphone
um uh that it will be brought around to
you for the purposes of book tv uh yes
ma'am there in the back
microphone's right next to you
don't think i need it well they probably
think they you do okay
[Music]
it's one of those electronic media right
exactly
uh actually that's sort of the drift of
my question i confess to being a little
bit surprised to hearing a couple of
nostalgic references to the good old
days when advertising supported
good journalism um
a little bit of a oxymoron in my mind
that's not exactly been a marriage made
in heaven over the years
is there no other way have you begun to
put any thought into how we can in fact
live off of or
or sell good writing without in fact
making it dependent to advertisers who
are so easily offended
it's a very good question um
there was an article recently um in
newsweek magazine because i think
they're starting to examine themselves
about some of the new forms of
journalism wealthy individuals are
starting to support
certain presses for example
the nation magazine
has long been subsidized
by wealthy supporters mother jones
magazine speaking of another major
alternative publication
has only been able to survive not by
advertising uh but by patronage the new
yorker
traditionally never made money uh it may
be now nobody's really sure but i'd say
from that january february whatever that
when that double issue was they're not
um harpers had always had uh
um you know
money behind it private money behind it
i think the atlantic uh did i don't i
mean i think you're right i don't think
um
that
most mainstream magazines at least um
were money makers uh the conde nast
magazines some of them make money some
of them don't they're the reason that uh
you know the new yorkers still published
is because new house bought the new
yorker some years ago but
um
even their money makers like
vogue which had a couple of spin-offs
they've now closed those spin-offs down
i don't know how portfolio's doing i i
don't think it's doing very well but
that was an excellent question because
in fact the change that's occurring is
moving more towards a non-profit model
of subsidization in order for these
voices uh to not be lost
only if you use the microphone
i will
one of the things that's happening
because of the digital
revolution if i may and uh in other
forms is the buying of an individual
song instead of an album the buying of
and i think we're gonna have to escape
the notion that it has to be published
in a magazine or in a uh the gambit
which i love but uh that it has to come
in a big package like that
maybe individual pieces is the way to go
i think publishers have looked into that
um in terms of making a micro payment
and they've even been talk about taking
the itunes music store which now sells
videos and sells a whole bunch of other
things and trying to sell
um
books
journalism on it i i don't know a part
of
especially talking about feature writing
part of it is serendipity um
and and i think that's really missing
today is the idea of getting a big thick
sunday paper and you want to read the
sports and you want to read this and
that but then you come across something
you never would have found on your own
and in the internet age you never would
have stumbled on
um
and that would be missing from that so
if you're buying something you already
know you want
that would be fine but trying to
trying to be led to something you might
not know that you'd be interested in i'm
not quite sure how that works i i think
you do stumble on things on the internet
one thing leads to another oh i do too
but i'm talking about paying for things
i mean
you know those are free things that you
like the bottom line is that writers
have to make a living
and
you know uh
you know we're watching the death of
metropolitan dailies um
and kevin's very right
that there's a democratic quality to
these publications and that you you pay
for stuff you didn't think about asking
for and find uh when a newspaper or
magazine is well edited and well run um
that's part of the uh you know opening
uh up of new experiences new ideas new
stories new information
and
as these large
publications let's say a newspaper
like the la times
goes down
it's not going to be replaced
on the internet
even with all of the downsizing at the
la times 700 people still work in the
newsroom and no internet site in la is
going to bring in the advertising
revenue for those numbers so i think
you're right that and catherine's right
that there will be these almost monastic
type
internet sites uh that will seek
hopefully to preserve something of the
tradition all of us here care deeply
about so that it won't disappear
but the idea that it can be sustained or
mainstreamed i think is is in doubt
i i do think even
places like the new york times are
i mean
god willing um will survive as a news
gathering organization long after it
survives as the sunday paper that drops
on your
doorstep
um and that you pay a lot of money for
uh
so i i mean i i i don't think the
internet can ever exist without um the
major news organizations to provide the
the material but i i don't think that we
actually need to get those
newspapers anymore even now
yes ma'am another question in the front
row i think here um yeah um
well uh i'm a traveler
i'm a travel writer probably one of the
ultimate feature writing types um you
know published in magazines both the us
and other countries and to inject one
positive note um
my publications
you know expect me to write stuff that
is
non-guidebooky meaning they don't want
some dim-witted little dim-witted little
piece about ooh here's a nice beach
resort or something you know they want
me to my stories to be experiential
to have a plot
um to write about quirky offbeat people
i've encountered write about an
interesting trend um and i do but what i
find is interesting and this is a
positive development is that um
i've known writers who did travel
writing in the 80s and the 70s and they
said back then they wrote all these
pieces about places they had never been
in other words you know their their
research was gleaned from books they
read movies they saw these were often
essay type pieces and i was actually
astonished to hear the back then that
was common in travel writing but the
writer's guidelines of all my magazines
and some of my papers it even explicitly
says i mean we do not want guide bookie
pieces those proliferate not only in
guidebooks but online where you know
stuff is just a long list of oh you know
restaurants hotels whatever but they
want me to tease out a real story you
know that would not be found in a guy
book you know an interesting person that
you know typifies a place you know a
bizarre place to go you know what i mean
so that could only be a good thing that
you know ages ago in travel writing
people were writing about places they
had never traveled to
well one one hopes that there are no
boring subjects they're only boring
writers
and that by
employing the sorts of devices that you
enumerated better than any of us did by
the way that was very well done i thank
you for that the elements of future
writing
that you can engage an audience
there's another hand way in the back if
you want to run the microphone over
there
give it just a second for the
purpose of we're all slaves to the
electronic media here
hold on
it's coming commercial free though yeah
this is electronic media be delivered on
foot so it's a little slower than usual
there you go okay
sir it wasn't worth the wait
[Laughter]
we'll let you know
rather than see the digital media as
such a drawback i i'm thinking of the
the the disappearance so much of
the major television networks and now
we've got a proliferation of cable
networks and we have digital areas where
i can listen to something as well as
read it is there any training going on
in the industry to have feature writers
take advantage of alternative media
rather than just
put the printed word
on a computer that could also
sing to me or play music along with a
piece or show pictures
in rapid succession or slow them down do
you understand where i'm getting is
there any movement in your industry
just as the
historical fiction writers lives changed
when google came around
they they had to adjust to that to be a
good fiction historical fiction writers
and if you like to take that on well we
live in a culture of moving images and
that's the problem
uh you know having spent almost two
decades of my life outside the united
states
i came back
i had a kind of rip van winkle
uh
confrontation with my own society and
one of the things i couldn't adjust to
was how everything moved
and it that kind of constant movement
and change of image in scene whether
it's on the nightly news whether it's on
tv whether it's the bombardment with
advertising uh conspires against thought
and i used i moved back to new york and
i retreated into the metropolitan museum
of art
at least two or three days a week
because i could stand before something
that didn't move
and could think about it and absorb it
and find
uh texture to it and i i i think that uh
you know the the part of the problem and
part of the demise of illiterate culture
is that we've absolutely destroyed
the past the capacity
for self-reflection
and for
thought
you know
when when proust
wrote in search of lost time 4 500 pages
it was during an age when a bourgeois
man or woman would come home and read
and
we to our detriment and we're paying a
cultural and a political price for it
we've obliterated that within the
culture and those i don't own a
television um partly because i'm you
know doing everything i can to create
walls
for of against that kind of intrusion
because i think at its core it's it's a
way
uh to
uh
uh
self-reflection and self-criticism which
is what good
narrative writing and good reporting is
about and
and why
those of us who write books write books
kevin
just i wanted to mention i think the new
york times does a great job with
multimedia
on their website
they've really figured out a lot of ways
to incorporate music and image and all
of these things along with
the traditional word um and i wanted to
get that in there because i think the
new york times takes a lot of crap for
the sins of just a few so um but i think
they've done a wonderful job
in multimedia i i don't have anything to
do with the website most of the time i i
don't really have anything to do with
the website but i actually agree with
you um i think
it's expanded your uh the possibilities
for what you're reading you can uh read
about an um
an art show and see a slideshow to go
along with it you can read mark bittman
telling you how to you know do a
complicated recipe and then you can see
mark bittman in a little three-minute
thing actually doing the recipe for you
and
you can see a lot of our foreign
correspondents now carry um little mini
um recorders and so sometimes you'll see
um an interview live some in a place
where you would never dream of being
able to actually
get such a visceral sense of what's
going on i i agree with you it's
um
it's it's the one part of the new york
times that is also expanding and
thriving financially so in spite of the
lack of advertising
uh which can't be denied but
i think we might have time for one more
question
all the way in the back over on this
side
okay gonna get your exercise in with
that microphone watch out what you wish
for okay
okay
yes ma'am
hi
uh this is about what you think the
potential is for writers to become
their own online
publishers and just as quick background
of a magazine writer the magazine not
only folded but the editors put their
names on our stories
what's the magazine
i'm confronting them with that i'd
rather not be on book tv but it's very
uncool
[Laughter]
and i also write for huffington post
which is great exposure but of course no
money so
i lined up an advertiser sales rep and
we have a green online daily which
advertisers are coming on board and
that's
exciting but do you think that's the
direction writers are going to need to
go and it's become your own publication
can you name me one writer who just
writes online that makes his or her
living from marketing him or herself
well the new model would be here also
the publisher and you bring on the
advertisers and
you're talking about being ariana
huffington
smaller
i i think she's pure evil
i think she's absolutely exploitive i
think she takes the words of people who
write for free and sells ads around them
and then positions herself as some kind
of bullshitty progressive
and that is
absolutely the wrong model for any young
writer to go into if you've got
something to write don't give it to
ariana huffington get your own website
do it for yourself and you will get
readers but don't give it to ariana i
did start my own thank you i'm going to
second i'm going to second that i mean
kevin's dead on on that and and if and
you know that's why huffington post is
largely junk it's celebrity driven crap
it's it is and if you've got a famous
name you can mix yourself up a drink and
and write your random thoughts of the
afternoon
in the worst prose possible and it'll be
posted up there with your picture and
believe me for those of us who care
about writing which is and all good
writing is rewriting who sweat over
every word who believe in reporting you
know we talk about the internet the
bloggers are parasitic in the sense that
they
uh don't report usually they don't even
pick up a phone
they uh they feed off of traditional
news organizations to then spin out
their thoughts most of which are insipid
and
uh for those who don't agree with that
but well for those of us i don't uh a
lot of them and and i think for those of
you but a lot of what you read in the
daily paper is incipit too right but but
when you go out and report a story you
are giving another
person a voice and hopefully if you're
doing it right you're giving a voice to
people who without your presence would
not have a voice that's what great
journalism is about and and that almost
never occurs on the internet reporting
on the internet is about as
common uh a phenomena as blacksmithing
i'd like you to
i hate you
i think i think chris i i think you're
painting too brought a swath um i think
reporting on the internet is um
a contradiction in terms but i think
that the internet does provide a forum
for some pretty good commentary and some
pretty good um reflection and some
pretty good thinky kind of writing and i
think you can even see some of it on
huffington post um it's true
that they don't pay anybody except the
celebrities i believe they certainly
don't pay they don't pay the celebrities
um but now jamie lee curtis does this
for free to get her thoughts on the
middle east on the other hand for an
aspiring for an aspiring writer um who
creates their own blog it's fine it's
good but if that writer can also appear
on huffington post they're getting a lot
more
uh readers and maybe it's the thing
that's going to help them be able to
move more into
the kind of um publications that all of
us would
i can't say even the good writers on the
internet of course there are some and
and i think that that they're out there
although i think the mass of what's on
the internet is is not good
but chris the massive what's in the
bookstore isn't good either
okay i agree with that i'm a total
luddite i fully absolutely i don't have
i agree with that i mean it it's it's
not it's not a flawed medium just
because it's the internet i mean that
there's right there's crap in everything
no i mean look at the published book at
the publishing list yeah i fully agree
um and again that gets back to the whole
idea that this is something that breaks
through cultural boundaries that this is
a cultural deterioration
uh but i think that the
the
uh that what i what i fear is that
through all of these changes with all
the many things we're losing not just
the physical
newsprint
the very ethic of reporting itself
the ethic that drives good journalism
itself is under threat and i i don't see
that ethic reported in the internet in
fact it's the inverse you you you write
for a serious publication or a newspaper
it you work very hard as a reporter to
make sure it's accurate it passes
through the hands of editors sometimes
at a paper like the new york times too
many editors
but
when you put it into print it is as
accurate and true and careful as you
possibly can be the internet you throw
anything out there and then often and
then
if there's a response
sometimes maybe there's a correction the
ethic is completely turned upside down
on the internet and that's a very
important point to remember that that
that we're losing many many things and
one of one of them is that that ethical
engine that i think drives good
reporting and good journalism
i am very reluctant thank you thank you
very much
[Applause]
i'm very reluctant to have to bring this
panel to a close just when it is
starting to get even more interesting
um please uh feel free to engage the
panelists in the lobby in the
oldest of genre face-to-face
conversation
and please join me one last time in
thanking them for joining us at the
festival
[Applause]
chris hedges is a nation institute
senior fellow and former new york times
foreign correspondent
this event was part of the 2009
tennessee williams new orleans literary
festival
for more information visit tennessee
williams.net
well and for a behind-the-scenes sneak
peek connect to cspan through twitter
facebook and youtube
coming up next book tv presents
afterwards an hour-long program where we
invite guest hosts to interview authors
this week former new york times reporter
chris hedges discusses his new book
empire of illusion which describes what
he considers to be the economic
political and moral collapse of american
culture
the pulitzer prize-winning journalist
travels through the world of pro
wrestling academia and others to dissect
the state of illusion he sees in the u.s
chris hedges discusses his book with
pulitzer prize-winning author ron
suskind
[Music]
hi i'm ron suskind and i'm here with
chris hedges and we're going to talk
about chris's latest book empire of
illusion a provocatively
titled piece of work
chris i've been following your stuff for
years lots of people have you've had a
very very interesting decade
uh we can talk a little about that
just to sort of
alert people as to your journey go so i
think this book seems to represent to me
a next and important step
in your journey as a as a writer
reporter you do a lot of reporting in
this book but also now as kind of a
public intellectual a guy who
is ready to step up into the into the
hot lights and into into the fire
tell me tell me how you arrive at
this book
at some point you had a leap from the
top moment and said this is the book i
must write
when was that how did it occur
well
you know as you know ron i was out of
the country for 20 years and
changes that occurred during those two
decades which were rather dramatic i
left in the early 80s and did not come
back to live in the country until
uh
after the events of 9 11.
so the changes within the country were
particularly stark which had been
gradual
the
destruction
especially of former manufacturing
centers
was a personal revelation because most
of my family comes from very
blue-collar towns in maine which are as
devastated as most manufacturing centers
so
that deterioration
was particularly market and particularly
troubling
i had watched of course the projection
of american power abroad in latin
america in the middle east
particularly and match that with the
perception
of american power and understood that
deep disparity
i think i grasped
because of my time outside the country
our deterioration economically
certainly militarily
and
the trouble we were in
and
set out to really explore
many of these illusions
which are sustained within
the heart of the american empire but as
one gets to the farthest reaches of the
empire
become
hollow if not obscene so these seeds are
planted long ago in you i think that's
sort of interesting here because you can
see the growth in your voice in this
book you know you're quite a bit more
strident you're saying look i'm going to
call it just as exactly as it is and
it's not a topic driven thing as some of
your other books the christian writer
what have you you know you're going for
the whole thing here right edge to edge
shoreline to shoreline and it's
interesting because you know what said
that gibran line it's easy to see the
mountain from the plane sometimes when
you're climbing it you're you're not on
the mountain you're overseas you're
turning to see america and and you are
maybe graced with some insights maybe
even against your will as to how the us
projects power as to the gap between
ideals and actions uh when you get back
i'm sure there was sort of almost a
dislocation you felt as you're walking
deeply right into the into the breach of
that well especially after seven years
in the middle east and i'm an arabic
speaker
the disconnect between
our cultural perception of the middle
east
islam
the muslim world
and the demonization in so many parts of
our society of the muslim world was
deeply disturbing to somebody was a
great deal of affection for many of the
countries that uh and and certainly the
cultures that i became intimate with so
yeah i i
i think that that there were on so many
levels so many disparities that that is
what led me to write the book i just
want to do one little uh digression
because you know you hear you're a
established prize-winning reporter for
the new york times right at the heart of
the of the msm the mainstream media the
kind of job people kill to get
but
late 2002 early 2003 you kind of you
kind of stepped off the grid into the
breach you were very ardent about your
opposition to the iraq war um just tell
us a very short precis on on that moment
where you stepped up i think it's kind
of dramatic at that commencement it was
it at rockford rockford college what
happened
well i had been speaking i had published
a book wars a force that gives us
meaning
which was a reflection on war the poison
that war is and what it does to
individuals as well as societies so i
had a kind of national platform on
various shows and inevitably i would be
asked about the preparations to invade
iraq now i've spent months of my life in
iraq seven years as i mentioned it
within the middle east itself and i
understood like most arabists
including the arabists in the state
department friends of mine the
intelligence community and the pentagon
that
invading and occupying iraq and
expecting to be greeted as liberators or
have democracy implanted and emanate
outwards across the middle east was a
non-reality-based belief system uh it
was it was utopian in the way thomas
moore used the word utopia no place
um
uh we don't think of dick cheney as a
utopian but in that sense he was uh and
so i spoke i i'd be delighted to hear
that you think so i uh
well utopianism wedded to violence has
caused more genocides in human history
than yeah sure um
and i had a i knew i had a choice i mean
i'd been you know almost 15 years with
the new york times i knew that for a
news reporter and i was a news reporter
not a columnist to speak out against
policy was a career killer uh yet on the
other hand i felt that there were so few
people who had that platform coupled
with the experience and expertise that
it was incumbent upon me a kind of moral
choice and i didn't go to journalism
school i went to seminary
to to uh warn about the debacle that we
have now of course stumbled into and um
and so this made the paper uncomfortable
but it came to a flash point as you
mentioned when i gave a commencement
address where i was
had my microphone cut twice and was
booed and people at one point the crowd
stood and began singing god bless
america and people were weeping and then
finally at the end of 18 minutes of my
talk two young men from the class
actually climbed up onto the podium to
try and push me off of them campus
security escorted me
uh out of
oh out of the ceremony before the
awarding of diplomas they didn't want
the students to come up
and then this got picked up by uh
you know the usual uh rush limbaugh
company and uh your former paper the
wall street journal wrote a really nasty
editorial about me
and the times uh
had to respond and they responded by
issuing me a formal written reprimand we
were killed which means that then goes
into your file
i was told to stop i had impugned the
impartiality of the paper i was to stop
speaking out about the war and uh and
then of course after that warning which
is in a formal uh
a formal warning then
i would uh the next time i did it i
would be fired so i started making
arrangements to leave the paper there
you know what's interesting because you
know you see a crossroads moment there
for you and i just i'm trying to feel
what it must have felt like for you to
be in front of that crowd i've been in
front of a lot of crowds and done
commencements and whatnot that's quite a
moment and you know especially for a
person seasoned in the in the reportage
in the reporting trades to be there
right at the center of that sort of uh
that sort of anger that that that
urgency really and but in a way a door
closes and another one clearly open for
you i mean you know uh and and that is
this incredible sort of offering of
books you've been very busy since then
and now you're sleeping what three four
hours a night this is
it's pretty i don't have much of a life
outside of that it's a pretty
astonishing output how many books have
you written since you left the time
seven seven yeah
that's uh then you leave the times in
2003. a little after that but yeah
okay all right so you are putting out
although i had written the words of
force while i was at the papers yeah but
still you're you're about at a book a
year right um and and i think this let's
get right to empire evolution this is
really a capstone uh tell me uh you know
for someone walking in the door
what is this book about and why is it so
urgent that this book needed to be
written by you at this moment
because i think we are the most deeply
illusioned society on the planet
you know one strives towards dreams
one lives within illusions
and uh you could see it you can see it
on innumerable examples but let's just
take uh you know the the last
presidential election
here we were
a country that uh not only under
international law or waging
a doctrine of preemptive war which under
post nuremberg laws is
are are defined as illegal wars of
aggression uh we were running offshore
penal colonies uh where we openly
tortured
people detained without any rights
we had had a banana republic seizure of
the electoral process in 2000
and yet we talked about our virtues and
the greatest country on earth the
greatest democracy on earth the
disparity between
what we were doing and the
perception of who we are uh this is just
writ large throughout the culture and it
it plays to a very pernicious fantasy
which is that we as americans can have
everything we want if we just dig deep
enough within ourselves if we tap our
hidden potential if we grasp that we are
truly exceptional
reality will never be an impediment to
what we desire and this message which is
magical thinking is passed off to us
across the ideological spectrum it's
oprah winfrey it's the christian right
it's corporatism
it's the entertainment industry
and uh you know i think in your book
hope unseen
it's one of the great
peeling back of those layers to expose
uh all of those institutional forces
that keep the poor poor right uh
and and and we you know when we tell
workers or blue-collar workers that they
are somehow responsible
for uh the fact that they can't find
employment or meaningful employment uh
that they can't get adequate health care
uh that they live
without uh
dignity often or hope that that that is
again
a disconnect between the reality around
us
we have literally in many uh
manufacturing centers in this country
packed up uh industry uh industries that
create and created them off to mexico or
the philippines or china they don't
exist anymore and what does exist are
often rusted out hulks this is not the
fault of workers and i think that that
uh that
disparity between the illusion of who we
are and what we can become
and the reality that is now opening up
with heightened foreclosures massive
unemployment we're shedding jobs at a
faster rate than after the 1929 crash
is creating a frightening chasm because
what illusion does is it allows you in
essence to remain in a state of
infantilism of childishness
uh without
facing responsibly i think the stark new
limitations and and maybe perhaps even
new humility which is needed for us to
cope with what's coming so that as that
divide widens between what who we think
we are and what we think we are and what
we actually are
uh
eventually it snaps it breaks
and if you're not prepared you react as
children react which is out of rage and
i think we're already seeing that these
kind of proto-fascist movements leaping
up on the fringes of american society uh
a call for uh revenge uh
a following of demagogues who promise
moral renewal uh and uh
and and that's the danger of
illusion and i think across the country
we still have not yet grasped uh either
in terms of our uh imperial expansion
the fact that this that you know we're
we're borrowing at this point to
maintain a lifestyle and an empire we
can no longer afford and either we begin
to face these responsibilities or
uh we will be confronted with uh
collapse which we are not intellectually
emotionally or psychologically prepared
to handle one of these is interesting is
as somebody writes books you know you're
always looking for some way to show a
change you know that's what we do often
as reporters and i'm fascinated by how
you uh you uh found professional
wrestling
uh because you know the metaphor which
you use on the book and you can describe
how i think it it works quite well
um you know um you in a way can track
this thing from i don't know who i
watched when i was a kid bruno san
martina wasn't that the guy you know uh
uh you know to now how how these
narratives which frankly are largely not
the coastline narratives there's a great
divide obviously between the coastal
communities and the wide middle of the
country
just at one point mark mckinnon who was
president bush's media fellow
sort of said to me
you know early on in the bush
administration you know you think bush
is an idiot i said no i don't actually i
i think a lot of things about him i
don't think he's a he's stupid no no you
do and and they do along the coastlines
and they do in a couple blocks in
southern manhattan near wall street
and let me just tell you we don't care
i said really
now now i'm interested why not he says
because you're outnumbered by the wide
beating heart of the middle of the
country you know and you know what they
like about him they like the way he
points they like the way he walks they
like the way he exudes confidence
they're not reading the wall street
journal the new york times the
washington post every day they're busy
working people that's what they like
about them but what they don't like this
is really quite telling what they don't
like is they don't like you
he says to me all right so keep
attacking our man bush for his malaprops
for his misstatements because because
that's good for us because he's being
attacked by someone those people don't
like and i think that's a it's a very
very succinct precis of the kind of
cultural struggles that your book uh so
clearly articulates across so many
realms of american life and and
especially the evolution of wrestling
tell me how you came upon that well
popular culture
always reflects back to us our own
perceptions of who we are and uh
i i didn't i i'm not my grandfather used
to watch it and very popular in a small
town in maine where my family comes from
but i hadn't watched it particularly and
so i started attending uh wrestling
bouts and uh what's fascinating about
wrestling is that the actual
choreography of the matches uh which are
highly stylized and predictable are not
what drives the crowd to a frenzy it's
the backstory which uh is elaborate i
mean has a kind of soap opera quality to
it
and it's all narrative it's all
narrative and and they're very good at
it and sometimes very funny and there
were a few stories i couldn't resist
putting in just because as a journalist
they were well i just i can see your joy
oh yeah of attending these matches and
i'm sure people are saying hedges is
just you know is well he's in his
fullness here you're watching wrestling
i mean that's sort of you can sell
tickets just to think of you watching
the wrestling match they're uh they're
very good at what they do i gotta hand
it to vince mcmahon he knows what he's
doing and uh and the crowd the screams
of that i mean
madison square garden was this one match
completely sold out and uh
uh but what was fascinating was
uh how that narrative has changed that
in when i was a child wrestling was
about it was a deep undercurrent of
xenophobia racism sure the saudi guy
there was a lot of racial iron right the
irish guy versus the italian guy versus
the jewish guy and it was always
around a particular
uh
you know clean-cut american hero
represent american values and played
fair and
uh
uh fighting uh the russian bear right uh
kind of stuff well all that's gone yeah
and now you have uh elaborate narratives
of familial and social disintegration
sibling rivalry infidelity what's
fascinating is everyone cheats
there is no good or bad as soon as the
referee's back is turned authority is
considered
to be
partisan uh against a little guy and so
it doesn't matter what you do and and uh
uh
the
uh
the kinds of stories i mean there was a
story and i write about it this wrestler
named sean michaels known as the
heartbreak kid
he is totally destroyed in the financial
meltdown he loses his 401k he's
foreclosed on his house and all this and
he has to work for a very ruthless
capitalist
a guy named jb and and what's
fascinating in celebrity culture which
we live in is that those lines
completely blur so you actually have
uh
this wrestler known as jb he he's on
cable news shows giving financial advice
as if he is
in fact a bona fide uh investment
counselor um the lines are uh they're
gone they're not even blurred they're
gone they're gone and that's something i
think that has been uh
i think both of our 10 years in the
media deeply disturbing especially on
the electronic media commercial media
where uh
we
are
captivated by uh
celebrity lives we uh you know as neil
gabler says we
all are sort of writing screenplays in
our heads uh we measure ourselves
against these celebrities and yet of
course the the actual lives of
celebrities i mean the michael jackson
would be a perfect example are train
wrecks uh you know here was a person who
thought he could bend gender and race
who had delusions of majesty painting
himself you know as a kind of royal
figure uh certainly questionable
relationships with young boys uh i think
everything about his life seemed to uh
indicate that when you know you are a
celebrity of that level you no longer
know who you are and yet
we seek
them as a kind of standard you know
i mean jackson was us really pushed in
many ways to the extreme 18 million
americans had cosmetic surgery last year
uh and it's it is about a culture that
is all about image all about
presentation and i think when you talked
about bush that's a perfect example it's
not about content it's about how you
present yourself and
in a society in a celebrity culture like
that where human beings are reduced to
commodities you fall into this quest for
eternal youth
this uh belief that uh uh you know your
achievement of either fame or at least
fleeting fame or money is the sole or
highest sort of uh
good that one can attain or you see it
on reality television shows for instance
uh you know what are the qualities that
are celebrated on these programs
programs like survivor which i also
write about but it or big brother it's
it's uh
it it is the qualities of psychopaths of
of people who are about
self-aggrandizement of um the ability to
manipulate of uh
totally untrustworthy and that they
create sort of faux friendships that
they then betray and what do they get at
the end of it they get money and they
get a moment of fame but i guess one of
the fault line issues is uh is to see if
there is a wanting to draw between our
stories that you know that are trumpeted
to us through these mediums we sit in a
stew of it
and some underlying reality are we our
stories is there some divider people say
look i watch it on television but you
know the fact is that's a that's a
confected reality that's not real even
if they find themselves in an undertow
at some cases of intima of of intim uh
you know sort of mirroring i mean it's
more than than uh uh you know an uh you
know saying i am that person saying i'll
be like that person having said that
where is the line drawn are we more than
our stories
well
um
first of all i think having spent time
with wrestling i don't the question of
whether you know wrestling is true or
untrue real or i don't think it matters
to the fans i don't think that matters i
think there's something much more
visceral i think the narratives that are
played out speak to their own personal
frustrations and narratives and through
stylized bouts uh they are able to
there's a kind of an emotional catharsis
and i think the same is true with
celebrity culture uh that uh there is
this belief uh and and in real life
stories which preoccupy the news right
now
or at least certainly television news uh
seemed to say to us that we're all just
waiting for our moment to walk on stage
uh it it it it it can happen to us uh we
will be quote unquote discovered and uh
that is exceedingly dangerous because it
imparts values uh values
about uh um
about about self-celebration about the
kind of cult of the self uh that are at
odds i think with more traditional
american values uh of humility
self-sacrifice community uh you know
values that i think of course most
parents must confront children you track
uh those values and how they were
in a way separated from action how we
were unmoored from those values across
time i think it's a fascinating run-up
where you you talk about the rise of the
advertising culture edward bernays this
notion that that all the messages will
say you're imperfect you're wanting
right you're needy and these products
will make you whole will give you what
you need to be and in a way though it
taps into one of the the strong forces
underneath america which is
self-invention place where people come
to to you know rediscover recreate
themselves you know so so you know you
see that sort of strong river of
reinvention in the american character
uh and you see
the river in a way separating that one
path where well i'll tell you how to do
it in a commercial marketplace economy
and another one which you talk about in
some parts of the book where you get as
hopeful as you get in the book to say
there is an underlying reality and we
can embrace it if we well
maybe if we are very fortunate as this
thing unfolds tell me about the building
of this culture of
of both need
and saving through product and what you
learned as you sort of trace its history
well it began of course with primarily
after world war one with the rise of uh
the consumer society and
uh the understanding it really comes out
of freud and bernay of course is twice
freud's cousin a nephew
and that's a really exciting ordinary
and they they they i mean
the creole commission the committee for
public information world war one uh
uh
which brene worked for and most of the
people who went from madison avenue
after the war worked for most of the big
ones um understood that facts were
irrelevant
that uh
it was
you you could get people uh to
do things often that were not in their
own interest
by appealing to subliminal desires
anxieties as you pointed out creating
anxieties and that's where you got the
uh eroticizing of the car uh it was
bernays brilliant idea to in order to
get women to start smoking to call them
freedom torches and have women appear on
a street in a public protest and light
up and get arrested
and then also you got the rise of the
pseudo event which uh
uh neil borstein writes about um
and the father of the reality show yeah
and it it it and that of course is just
now swept across the culture uh you i i
write in the book and and but i think
it's a good example having been a war
correspondent i write about the the
three survivors who raised the flag at
iwo jima coming back and the uh a power
of hollywood especially in the movie
that was made after the war with john
wayne
uh the sans of iwo jima to create what
appears to be real uh and because most
uh more revealed more real than life and
these people ran smack into the pseudo
event which overpowered the real event
which is why uh uh
two of them descended into alcoholism
you know dying early deaths and uh the
third who did survive refused ever spent
and we have people all across the
culture even now that slam it from real
event into pseudo events it's very
michael jackson of course is one of your
examples it's very hard to life real
life yeah
and uh that
i think is part of a disconnect from
a
illiterate or print-based culture
we are very skillfully manipulated by
images these people who whether they're
advertisers whether they're political
spin doctors whatever it is
whether it's the entertainment industry
they know how to make us feel let me ask
you a quick question uh a lot of people
are watching mad men right now you come
to it with let's just say an informed uh
position how do you feel when you watch
i don't i don't have it on a television
you do not own a television so you're an
unplugger i'm a luddite
okay
you know i mean at a friend's house i'd
be interested to know what you think of
it because people are watching really
the formation well i've read i've read
alice under stanley's you know reviews
of the times and stuff and yeah i mean
it actually sounds like a great show and
there is
yeah oh yeah no it's it's all the rage
it's all around but it's precisely that
it deconstructs the way our lives are
lived and what are the forces beneath
them that's why it's so and the the way
that we have been made to confuse how
we're made to feel with knowledge you
see it's a cousin of your book yeah you
know i mean maybe uh i'm gonna make a
lot more money than i will
yeah that that is indisputable
um the uh one of the things that's
interesting is is when you're writing
the book i i you know and i didn't know
you didn't have a television that's
fascinating um i just i say i wonder if
chris is having howard beal moments
where you just want to get up and yell
you know you got you got to get mad
first you got to turn off your
television set just turn it off first
you got to get mad as hell i mean tell
me
how
the experiences of going into the valley
here of really you know you're doing
it's a hard book to write i'm sure
because you're coming upon truths that
are that are really unsettling
um do you ever feel like just screaming
out or maybe that's what you're sort of
doing now in your in your waking life um
well the book has a degree of anger in
it i think um what did augustine said
hope has two beautiful daughters anger
and courage
anger at the way things are and or
courage anger the way things are and the
courage to make them better right uh i
think uh you know hatred is is poisonous
anger is not always bad
uh i
uh
see things happening to
a country i love deeply
that disturb me whether those are
the prosecution of the wars in iraq and
afghanistan
or whether it is the destruction of the
working class uh the blue-collar workers
who constitute members of my own family
and then a very uh
sophisticated and pernicious
capacity to make those we have shunted
aside
and turned uh in many cases into kind of
human refuse believe that they are
responsible for their own failures one
of the things i think is fascinating is
is that you would you acknowledge in the
book that there has been
progress areas of progress in the 20th
century in terms of minorities the
rights of women
people having opportunities that they
didn't have in 1900 you know you see
that that sort of train moving forward
and at the same time you see what you
call a debasement of the culture i
wonder if you see these two things
working in something of a simultaneity
whether there's an ebb flow
between these these areas of progress
and the
the companion areas of a hollowing out
as you call it well of the america i
don't want to keep going back to your
book
but well if you must
uh you know hope unseen i think uh you
captured
what i think we would call the politics
of identity yeah where
uh
i mean you did this primarily when
cedric is at brown but um
this obsession which was very much a
part of my own college experience 70s
80s
i think was
evidenced in uh a call for uh people of
color uh people who are not part of the
mainstream let me ju let's take a break
we'll look back in just a jiffy and
we'll pick right up where you left off
afterwards and several other c-span
programs are available for download as
podcasts more with chris hedges and ron
suskind in a moment
supreme court week starts sunday with
c-span's original documentary the
supreme court home to america's highest
court the real intimacy comes in the
relationship between the lawyer who was
arguing at the podium
in the court that he's arguing to
and if you stop to think of it when you
go in there you will see that if
one of us leaned over the bench as far
as we could lean
and the lawyer arguing at the podium
lean toward us
we could almost shake hands
and that is a very important thing
because it means that when the when the
arguments take place
you are physically and psychologically
close enough to each other so that there
is a possibility for real engagement get
an insider's view of the court and hear
from all the justices about its role
traditions and history
the supreme court home to america's
highest court
premieres sunday at 9 00 pm eastern on
c-span
and for a behind-the-scenes sneak peek
connect to c-span through twitter
facebook and youtube
afterwards with chris hedges and ron
suskind continues
you know it's interesting because you
know
in in
hope in the unseen you know one of the
things i do is try to walk in the shoes
of the actor cedric a kid who goes from
the worst high school in america to
brown university and and the goal
is to um is to know what drives him his
dreams of acceptance uh his sense of i
need to get there up ahead it's it's
gatsby and the green light in the dark
and someday i'll make it yeah the unseen
is a is a place he assumes it's brown
university that's where i'll be at home
that's where i'll be at home in my skin
that's where i'll be judged on my merits
of course he gets there and he's sort of
like i'm not there yet i can feel i'm
closer but i need to work on myself i
need to somehow be worthy of that moment
and i'm learning who i am and and you
know and ultimately it's interesting
because the teacher visits them and and
i'll get to a question here in about 10
seconds but a teacher and cedric tells
this teacher from high school yes mr mr
taylor i'm almost there i'm almost at
the place i thought
uh you know reaching reaching uh
uh you know um and mr so well cedric
maybe the unseen isn't so much a place
as a place in your heart
and what the teacher's talking about is
discovering an underlying human reality
which you talk about at the end of the
book right uh you know when the noise
stops when you're alone with yourself uh
when you know with great intimacy the
life that you actually are living
and i guess what i wonder about at the
end of the book you start to talk a bit
about that i know we're jumping a little
bit ahead but
how people might arrive
um you know at a place where they
somehow
are not so deeply affected by the circus
uh by all of these prompts
and lures and and uh and and
and will it take a disaster
which is something you kind of infer
here
before people in this culture
hit a kind of stop and thing
underlying reality i guess that's one of
the questions i ask because i know you
should in a way it's a struggle at the
end to say something hopeful about where
we might end up and i think you do
manage that at the end of the book but
tell me about that tension you know how
far do we have to drop in your mind
before we say
i need to hit the reset button we need
to start over we need to rediscover
these values of which which we speak
i need to know that i can only trust
what i can touch
and so now it's incumbent upon me to go
touch something when does that moment
come
well
societies that can't distinguish between
illusion and reality die
and we can go back and look at decaying
empires whether that was the roman
empire the ottoman empire the
austro-hungarian empire and read the
great
commentators on those final
years or decades whether it's cicero
whether it's joseph roth
it is that uh
inability to grasp
what's happening
uh and that clinging to
self-delusion
uh that makes
the self-annihilation inevitable
and
you know i covered the war in the former
yugoslavia
where i watched delusions of grandeur
grasp
the serbs the crots and to a lesser
extent the muslims in bosnia but all of
them uh where people they had grown up
with uh
you know gone to school with played
soccer with perhaps even married were
literally killing each other on the
length of a street and most are so i i
think that the
uh
my fear is that unless we begin to grasp
uh that
certainly that that level of consumption
that particular lifestyle that we had is
not coming back unless we begin to
confront
the radically new forms
of
structural forms that we have to embrace
in order to ward off climate change
unless we deal with the fact that
our imperial
hubris
uh is
hollowing us out and destroying us from
the inside not only morally but
financially uh you know what do we do
the day china stops buying our debt uh
we can't
we can't fund the empire anymore
uh and the dollar could within
you know 24 hours become junk what's
interesting is that you're writing this
book
i i imagine before
the september 15th disaster on wall
street before
bear stearns fails in the fall of 2008
and of course september 15th
a little over a year ago now wall street
melts down it's they practically take
the global economy with them
there's a 700 billion dollar bailout
organized hastily by the government
essentially by the treasury department
um it must have been interesting where
you started this project before that
right and then that moment occurs how
did it feel on that day and and and what
does that uh that incident that disaster
really how does that flow into the
conclusions
you know there are writers charles mayer
the historian harvard and others who
have written about this they haven't
received the kind of i think all of the
great writers sheldon wallen and others
there are great political and economic
commentators uh but because they don't
uh uh spout that orthodoxy of globalism
uh they've been shunted aside pushed out
of the
universe schiller george ackerloff we're
at animal spirits national exuberance
they were very early wendell berry i
mean they're they're there and so
mayor you know who
wrote well i mean real wages in this
country of course have yeah they're
declining since 73 yeah and um and we
have
managed to maintain a lifestyle
primarily through credit now that credit
of course is gone um for at least the
lower end of the for the the uh for the
working class and much of the middle
class um
so
there was i think an understanding
of
again that illusion
that
somehow
and you're right of course the collapse
of bear stearns and then the bailouts
only amplified this idea that we could
borrow our way back to a bubble economy
of 2006. i mean the biggest and cruelest
illusion of all was
the the the kind of speculative
excesses
of wall street that created vast uh
fictitious wealth that of course vapor
it vaporized
almost overnight but isn't there some
hope in your parlance in terms of the
sweda the uses of adversity that the
jewel in the toad's forehead here may be
a moment where clearly the music stopped
in terms of this
this whole race of of consumption fueled
by debt uh you know all of a sudden
everyone sort of woke up one morning
isn't that the kind of thing that at
least in some cases already you see
little sprouts of it have caused people
to say now hold on a second how do i
live my life what fuels it what are my
priorities are there a more stable set
of values more nourishing to me than
these consumer values that i might now
embrace clearly some of that is going on
in the society yes but that that gets to
the core of the book uh that
requires a shattering of the illusion
of who we are and
what we can become
uh that if we understand that in terms
of levels of consumption we will not go
back to what we had and and uh mayor has
written about this where he talks about
that transformation in american society
from uh a a society of production to a
society of consumption right being a
disastrous moment right and uh so
it
it's incumbent upon us to recognize
what's happening around us as long as we
close our eyes
and engage in this fantasy
that it's all gonna come back uh that we
can continue to have like you know sort
of a young two-year-old everything that
we want
then uh it becomes dangerous because
uh
what we are unprepared in every single
way
for what will inevitably happen
and i watched you know the war in
yugoslavia was not caused by ancient
ethnic hatreds it was caused by the
economic meltdown of yugoslavia
and when you debauch a currency as lenin
understood
uh
that is the when you destroy
capitalism you know when when you
descend as yugoslavia did into a state
of hyperinflation the moral order is
turned completely upside down and you
can see some of that now with people you
know like with lehman brothers fold
walks away with what is it 485 million
dollars and his investors many of whom
are people who you know month after
month year after year put a small
portion of their income aside for their
retirement or college are completely
wiped out
and and the speculators the the the
gangsters the profiteers uh they become
ascendant in a society which happened in
yugoslavia uh and those people who
actually were were sober contributing
members to the society uh you know who
had integrity who worked hard for a
living who they're they end up in the
bread lodge you know but but in this
disaster clearly there are opportunities
there are the seeds of essentially a
correction
and i guess one of the questions i have
if you've barack obama were sitting
right here at the table with us and he
says you know all right chris i read
your book liked what it said uh so what
do you think i would do or should do
right now
do you see
a correction
if you will along the lines of what you
suggest would be the right direction for
the country do you see that within the
realm of possibility for what you would
call enlightened leadership at this
moment and if so is there anything if
you had that moment you would tell the
president he could now do that would be
of value based on your on your thesis
your ideas
well the policy of the obama
administration is not markedly different
from the policies of the bush
administration
we've continued the largest transference
of wealth upwards in american history we
are expanding the war in afghanistan
military planners are talking about at
least 15 or 20 years american presence
in iraq
uh okay well obama says yeah i
understand all that and i agree with you
i want to change that what do i do
well i think we have to begin to pull
back from our you know half of all
discretionary spending since world war
ii uh has gone into defense defense and
uh and much of our deficit which are the
largest recorded deficits in human
history are caused because we are
maintaining a defense establishment that
we can no longer afford
uh and meanwhile we are crumbling
literally on the inside i mean read the
the reports about american
infrastructure
whether it's sewages or sewage disposal
or bridges or anything else or inner
city schools i mean the list goes on and
on and on
that
and this is how empires usually implode
they they expand outwards to such an
extent uh that they that the very heart
of the empire collapses
internally uh and i think that that's
the danger we face that's the tradition
so that if
we can
recognize
that this period of our history is over
and i don't think that this is a
negative i think that uh living with a
new kind of simplicity uh
not producing 25 of the world's
greenhouse gases
uh
learning to speak to the rest of the
world in a language other than the
language of force i mean i think these
actually on on a certain level may not
improve our lifestyles in terms of
consumption or in terms of power uh but
i think it certainly would improve the
quality of life in terms of moral
integrity and and meaning right and uh
and you see pockets of it no doubt
you're from vermont you know
michael pollan some of you i know
michael you know his books are best
sellers there are lots of people saying
i want to buy locally i want to have a
simpler life they're actually a lot of
unpluggers in the country that's right
get rid of the television i mean so do
you feel in any way heartened by the
fact that actually you've got a bit more
company than i think you probably had 15
years ago yes and and but my fear is
that
if
you have
a working class primarily and working
class is probably a misnomer i mean
they're they're
a working class
gives the idea that somehow they're
earning incomes where they have
sustainable lifestyles people who work
28 hours a week at walmart are still
collecting food stamps that are below
the poverty line right i think what the
forty percent of americans live and they
get sixty thousand dollars with a credit
card yeah so um
the
my fear is that if these people are
unprepared for what's coming and
unprepared for the kind of changes they
make and
refuse to receive the kind of support
that the government should be giving to
them if if we keep
shoveling
hundreds of billions of dollars into
uh speculative financial concerns you
know speculators in the 17th century
were hung it was considered criminal
what people like george soros did i mean
george has done some wonderful stuff but
nevertheless
ready to bring that back well i'm not
but but but i think it's important to
recognize that companies like aig
committed fraud and that's why their
records were seized in britain and and
so why are we using taxpayer money to
save those who committed fraud and and
turning our backs on the small uh
investors who have been destroyed by
this uh
this and and look the health care reform
bill is a perfect example it's been
hijacked by the for-profit health care
industry any legitimate debate about
healthcare should begin from the factual
understanding that the for-profit
healthcare industry is the problem must
be destroyed then we can talk about a
system but that's not going to happen
because these people have the power
to frame the debate
especially on the electronic media and i
think confuse the issue and of course we
have an electoral process
made up
where these people are largely elected
officials are largely captive to the
money of corporate interests and so what
what we're likely to be fed uh is
uh
a defective product that we will be
forced to buy and uh it won't thwart the
rise in sort of co-payments and premiums
especially for the elderly we can still
be dropped if we have a catastrophic
illness and remember you know not only
are half of all bankruptcies caused by
people who can't pay their medical bills
but seven out of 10 of those people
actually had insurance
but then of course when you lose your
job you can't pay for the premium so if
we start i i think we can't keep pushing
the underclass which is swelling now
into the middle class we can't keep
pushing them and pushing them
uh they have uh visions or uh fantasies
about a kind of lifestyle that's not
returning and yet we keep taxing them
and i think that that
is when we see groups like oath keepers
you know
when we see these you know they're
they're they're
their critique of the corporate state is
not wrong in many ways it it it is uh
very similar to mine but
it's using bedfellows for you right but
they are but what they are talking about
as a solution is terrifying of course
because it's violence and because it is
about scapegoating it's about going
after immigrants
you know liberals feminists i mean
there's a long list uh and there is a
dark undercurrent of violence in
american society there always has been
and i fear
that
just as there are signs of hope and
you're right
there are also signs that are very
disturbing
the
you know what happens this financial
mess is not over what happens when uh we
have a collapse of commercial real
estate what happens when the credit card
uh companies start going under because
how many was it 17 trillion dollar i
mean
yeah so i think it's 2.8 trillion
dollars of unsecured debt in the country
credit card debt basically it's a lot of
money yeah commercial real estate hasn't
happened really yet you know i mean of
course the banks are are you know
getting free money from the government
you have trained could make money with
that and they're not and they're not
lending and they don't know what all
good capitalists
here to make money it's not my fault man
you know this is not immoral it's a
moral go away so my fear is that the
illusion yeah that the reality is when
it finally knocks people over i mean
when they come and drag you out of your
house because you're being foreclosed
that's reality yeah and that you're and
that if
you know
essentially you have been lied to i mean
let's be clear about this we are a
society awash in lies uh that uh your
your rage is compounded uh by the fact
that you're you're just nobody's told
been straight with you you you you you
have been
uh denied
uh the right to understand the truth you
know i before we get to this point at
the very end because i think you're
hitting on something in terms of of how
certain things might unfold where we
might end up here if if we move in a
certain direction in terms of this rage
in terms of people
embracing a reality against their will
being dragged out of their house my god
i don't have enough to feed my family
that's reality i'm turning off the tv
i'm no longer part of the narrative but
what's interesting is that one of your
most
pointed critiques here
is about what i would
consider folks that you believe have a
choice in terms of these glorious
temples of learning in america you know
the the uh the world-renowned great
universities of the united states and
you've taught at them i've taught at
them you know you um you really take the
gloves off here as to the choices that
they've made uh in terms of their role
to help those frankly who are largely
privileged or at least lucky enough to
get within their corridors of those
great universities helping them uh
actually understand the meaning of a
moral education of what an educated
person knows and how that might guide
action asking the more fundamental
questions about meaning as opposed to
what you call the the sort of vocational
concept of of uh which is the the best
return on the investment of this tuition
and usually that ends up being an
investment bank or something it can tell
me about
uh the
uh the nature of that critique and also
um
how
you managed to write it with such force
i mean you've got some buddies who
probably are sending you emails on that
one from uh from princeton you taught at
princeton um tell me about how higher
education
uh has uh been co-opted into i think
what you call the military industrial
academic complex to coin eisenhower that
was eisenhower's original phrase well
military industrial but he he
dropped it that's a that's amazing yeah
that was originally his friend
yeah well the problem with
our elite they know better they know
better is what you're saying well they
they
have uh become
sophisticated vocational schools i mean
you may study liberal arts
at some of these elite institutions uh
but it's a kind of branding uh you then
go on
from there uh into the plutocracy uh
which they uh of course have been formed
uh to sustain uh and
with a kind of withering of the
humanities only a hundred thousand
students now major yeah it's astonishing
we have lost the capacity and so why the
humanities i think are important what
percentage is that of all graduates
roughly uh it's tiny it's it's in the
single digits uh i know one percent in
math four percent in english i mean it's
it's very small yeah two i think two
percent in foreign languages or
something um
the biggest major now is business used
to be education uh what is business it's
about manipulation
um
uh
and with the withering of the humanities
we have
lost that ability because that's what
humanities are about to ask those broad
questions
you know
true intellectual thought by its nature
is subversive because it is meant as
aristotle and plato and you know many
many others have pointed out to question
assumptions
to question structures and thereby
authority and thereby authority of
course
and uh with the assault that has been
waged by the right wing in this country
against the universities against quote
unquote the liberal press or
you know liberal
universities
that's confused us because it's not been
an assault against liberalism it's been
an assault against moral autonomy
against that ability to step back and
question the system and there's a very
little room for that now anywhere within
american education if american education
let's just say they all read your book
and they said dammit hedges is right
here and they moved
hard
left or hard any new direction turned on
their heels and said we are going to be
about simply creating an army of people
who ask these fundamental questions
structural questions if you will
that it would seem would be a point of
yearning for you because it might create
an army of folks who then could go out
into what they now define as the
worthwhile life that would form kinship
with those disenfranchised workers in
post-industrial america i mean in a way
that's one of the hardest parts of the
book to read to read
your view of higher education because
you know
the fact is is that
that is still a goal as it was for
cedric jennings and hoping the unseen to
get there but once you get there and
there are others like cedric who managed
somehow to get to that sunlit uplands
to then say okay
guess what next stop goldman sachs now
having said that right now again
possibly a moment of opportunity many of
the graduates saying well i'm not going
to wall street well they're not
recruiting well they're not recruiting
and it's not what it was and there's no
short thing there anymore and they're
asking themselves this next set of
questions
of how to define a life of worth which
gets closer
to some of your posits in the book the
question is how might that opportunity
be seized again at the stop and think
moment in america well the problem is
that we've created a winnowing system
where we reward a very narrow kind of
intelligence which is primarily
analytical
people who do very well on sats
people who
you know
do everything right in the classroom and
get perfect grade point averages and get
fives on all their ap exams uh now that
your new army may be somewhere at
another university rather than the the
peaks of the analytical well i think so
and that's why the you know these
universities have fed into the structure
of wall street uh you know universities
are not very upfront about telling you
what percentage of their class travels
from graduation off to the financial
sector because it's it's 60 often 60 or
70 percent that's changed of course now
but that has been and uh
the
uh you know by the time you get to these
elite schools you are so deferential to
authority i mean i saw it as a teacher
yeah um it's not so much what
they're not as concerned often with what
they're thinking but they want to know
what you think so that they can give you
uh what they think and uh
it is not uh an environment that is very
accepting or nurturing of iconoclasts of
people who
can step back and ask those broad
questions uh it can challenge and
confront authority uh and
you know i would i would look at
lawrence summers uh as a perfect example
a youngest tenured economic professor at
harvard uh and yet somebody who was one
of the architects of uh uh of
globalization and unfettered or
unregulated capitalism essentially
demolishing the 1933 glass-steagall act
uh
he's a perfect example of what these
universities are what higher education
produces which are systems manager
people who have a drone-like ability to
work at tremendous have a very narrow
and specialized kind of intelligence but
don't have the capacity to challenge
those structures and therefore that's
what we're seeing with with people like
summers they are throwing taxpayer
dollars into the hundreds of billions of
dollars to sustain a system because
that's all they know how to do so in a
way some of the the great future
potential actors maybe out there at
community colleges or
large land-grant universities kids who
didn't play that game who decided
there's more to life than hitting the
bell on this analytical yardstick
maybe live more complex lives a search
and find in some ways
that may be your natural audience right
well and you also see it in you know
university economic departments because
people who stood people who questioned
this utopian belief that the marketplace
was going to create the panacea market
right market efficiency through
rationalism that the rule of law doesn't
matter that labor law doesn't matter
let's just let the corporations decide
which is a kind of childish
utter incapacity to even recognize the
minimal conditions of human nature
you know the people who question this
and they were there some of whom you've
mentioned
were shoved aside push marginalized
quite uh
quite literally i mean
and and i think that you're right that i
think and that's what has given rise to
the whole ngo phenomena i mean many of
the people because they couldn't get an
established structures either through
academia or either through the
government uh
so the minds the creativity the it's
there but we have pushed it to the
what's interesting this echoes clearly
with me you know the character of the
price of loyalty my book in 2004 the
former treasury secretary paul o'neil
went to fresno state
he grew up uh desperately poor
his father was a janitor at the veterans
hospital at some point he lived in
places with no plumbing uh so he had
gone from one edge of america to the
other which is why he was really not of
the community uh that that supported uh
authority for its own sake uh he was
constantly questioning it and and and i
just want to end with this that you have
a lovely little passage from this
russian novelist and journalist vasily
grossman
where he talks about um you know in a
way as you talk about this sort of very
wide assessment
of what has gone wrong but he says you
know human history is not the battle of
good struggling to overcome evil it is a
battle fought by a great evil struggling
to crush a small kernel of human
kindness
but what is human in human beings has
not been destroyed even now
well
then evil will never conquer you know at
the end of the book you're searching for
that light
do you feel like you found it do you
feel like you still preserve some sense
that that this country uh has maybe
another act in it well it's not it it's
i think in what i'm saying at the end is
i put my faith in the capacity for human
redemption even as structures states and
institutions fail and die as they
inevitably will uh and that vastly
grossman it's a wonderful from life and
fate i think is the perfect example of
that well uh well thank you chris this
has been lovely empire of illusion chris
hedges latest book
thanks thanks ron
okay ladies and gentlemen let's scurry
to our seats
the next presentation
this is going to be
it may already have started
so smile turn off your phones and
beepers
you'll have to watch it when it's rerun
this evening
no time to call home and say
look at me
okay
before you leave today for the last at
the last presentation please remember to
recycle your badges we'll have a
box here or outside it's green it's big
and
we're gonna do the good thing for oh
i heard something
okay is that what they sound like some
of them during the first presentation
when ralph nader was here my phone was
sitting right here and i had not cycled
it off
and i prayed for an hour that no one
would call me
no one did
i want you to look at the back of your
programs
and notice our sponsors and throughout
the year
please patronize them
watch them on tv listen to them on the
radio
buy their products
and thank them for
being sponsors of miami book fair
international we couldn't do it without
them
yes
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
to introduce our next panel it is my
pleasure to welcome back charles chapman
a friend of miami book fair
international and a frequent and
wonderful introducer charles
[Applause]
thank you barbara today we have three
prominent journalists
they will each speak for a relatively
short time and then there will be plenty
of questions because i'm sure
many of you want to know what they think
about just about everything
first up we have chris hedges
uncompromising
is
how most journalists
except maybe those for english tabloids
regard themselves
in the case of chris hedges it's the
real thing
he covered the wars in the balkans for
the new york times during the 1990s and
then went on to be the
middle east bureau chief for that paper
currently he writes an online column for
truthdig and was recently awarded
the los angeles press prize for best
online column for the year
the titles of his books
speak for themselves
i don't believe in atheism in atheists
american fascists the christian right
and the war
on america
the ironically titled
war is a force
that gives us meaning
his current publication
is empire of illusion
the end of literacy and the triumph of
spectacle
next up we have george packer
george made his mark on international
reporting in 2005 with the publication
of the assassin's gate
it tells of the invasion and occupation
of iraq
appearing on nearly every list of best
books that year
it won numerous journalistic awards as
well
after graduating from yale in 1982 and
working for the peace corps he became a
staff writer for the new yorker
and in 2000 wrote blood of the liberals
his current book
is called interesting times
writings from a turbulent decade
our third author is sam tannenhaus
currently the editor of the new york
times book review and the sunday week in
review section
since receiving his
degree in english from grinnell and
picking up a masters from yale he has
written and edited for vanity fair and
the times
his 1997 biography of whitaker chambers
was a finalist for the national book
award and for the pulitzer prize in
biography
this year he has produced the death of
conservatism which has become a focal
point in current political debate
especially in the wake of the recent
elections
please welcome our three authors
hi we're each going to talk for five
minutes i guess the
reader's digest version of our books
um
my book empire of illusion the end of
literacy
and the triumph of spectacle makes the
argument
that we are the most illusioned nation
on the planet that we have become
utterly disconnected from who we are
what we represent and where we're going
and replaced it with fantasy
it has allowed us
to
run offshore penal colonies where we
openly torture other human beings
suspend habeas corpus
engage in warrantless wiretapping and
eavesdropping of american civilians
lived through a banana republic 2000
election where unfortunately this state
contributed to the theft
of
the democratic vote
and yet describe ourselves as the
greatest democracy on earth
a democracy that abrogates the right to
impose its virtues on others by force
we have built a system of unfettered
capitalism which has turned everything
from human beings to the natural
environment into commodities for
exploitation until exhaustion or
collapse
this
has hollowed out america from the inside
it's why we are borrowing roughly at a
rate of 2 billion a day from the chinese
and have been for the last 10 years
at some point that has to collapse
we have destroyed our manufacturing base
and described it as an opportunity for
growth
all of these things have fed into
i think a very frightening
fantasy about
where we're headed that we have in many
ways remained uh 40-year-old children
unable to confront
the as the historian harvard historian
charles mayer uh calls it that that
transition from an empire of
production to an empire of consumption
uh real wages in this country have
remained stagnant uh since 1973 and just
as we maintain empire through credit and
borrowing we maintain a lifestyle that
we can no longer afford through credit
and borrowing all of that is collapsing
one strives towards a dream one lives
within an illusion and the illusion that
we are fed is that reality is never an
impediment to what we want
that we can if we just dig deep enough
within ourselves if we find our inner
strength if we grasp as tony robbins
says that we are truly exceptional if we
believe that jesus can
perform miracles if we focus on
happiness
we can
fulfill
this pernicious
uh psychological uh idea among consumer
culture that has sort of instilled
massive consumption as a kind of inner
compulsion
and the danger of illusion is that it
allows you to remain in a state of
perpetual childishness infantilism
and as that gap opens up between
the illusion of who we are and the
reality the foreclosures the
bankruptcies that are caused by the
inability to pay medical bills the
collapse of empire
we are unprepared emotionally
psychologically and intellectually for
what it is that is about to confront us
and
when the wolf finally bathes at the door
when our house is foreclosed when the
unemployment insurance runs out
then you react if you have remained in a
state of illusion
as a child reacts you search for a
demagogue or a savior who promises moral
renewal
vengeance
and new glory and we can already see
that very frightening
psychological
uh disease leaping up around the fringes
of american society
the only
way that one can speak about hope
is to break free from a
non-reality-based belief system to begin
to speak in a new language of humility
to accept a lifestyle
which frees itself from
profligate consumption
and endorses a new simplicity
and then finally it is not
uh
incidental or accidental that the
environmental crisis we face is twinned
with the economic crisis it stems from
the same
disease which is turning everything
human beings into a commodity the
natural environment into a commodity
that we exploit uh and and and and uh
exhaust until it dies and either we wake
from this illusion or we
commit collective suicide
[Applause]
[Music]
just 15 minutes ago chris was saying he
had no idea what he was going to say
and i thought i had some idea now i have
to try to
duplicate that i will not duplicate that
um
my book is a collection of pieces of
essays that
were published during a period that i
think of now as kind of already a little
bit in the past and a distinct period
september 11th 2001 to november 4th
2008.
um
when
tara was visited on us
i think we
had and squandered certain possibilities
in the way we responded to it and
at the end of that
period of waste and squandering
we showed that in spite of
is i think in some ways accurate and
also quite savage analysis we show we're
capable of some self-criticism and some
self-renewal on november 4th 2008.
um
the the pieces in the in interesting
times are largely
foreign reporting and they're a
particular kind of
foreign story
they're long-form narrative journalism
which is probably
soon to be one of those things that
among the list of of soon to be extinct
aspects of our culture unless
journalism takes a sharp turn for the
better
i was writing mostly for the new yorker
during those years still am
and although some of the pieces are
about our wars uh our wars in iraq
afghanistan counter-insurgency a lot of
them are about parts of the world that
were sort of forgotten during that time
west africa
um east africa burma
and
i'll just tell you a quick story of
something i saw in
the west african country of ivory coast
to give you a sense of what the larger
themes of the book are
ivory coast was undergoing a terrible
civil war in the early part of the
decade and i visited at one of the
bad depths of that civil war
and i started seeing in the uh sort of
northwest part of the country these
young
14 15 even 13 12 year old fighters with
ak-47s
and t-shirts that said
they were like action t-shirts one face
was osama bin laden the other face was
george w bush
and i'd never seen such a t-shirt before
what did it mean i mean
it had the two faces of the protagonists
of the war on terror on it and
from talking to these guys these young
guys i began to think it really just
means power
that these are the two sort of cartoon
titans dominating um
the world of war right now and these
young guys want to be part of power and
where do they get these ideas well they
probably got them from the global media
which they had access to even in the
some pretty remote parts of ivory coast
they were able to watch
bbc
they were able to watch cnn they were
able to watch al jazeera and they had in
their heads a kind of a
crazy mishmash of images and slogans and
ideas some of it came from hip-hop and
gangster rap culture in this country
some of it came from jihadism even
though these guys you know were half
drunk the whole time i was with them um
one of them said to me that he wanted to
go join the jihad and osama was the only
guy who would give him a good job
another guy said he wanted to join the
u.s marines but they were all you know
kind of fighting together
in the same
rather anarchic insurgency in ivory
coast and
i spoke with an italian doctor who was
doing
humanitarian work in ivory coast and and
told him about these things i was seeing
and he said yes he said this is a
perverse effect of globalization he
called it contagion by media
in other words
it used to be that
guys like this from small villages
whose sense of the world pretty much
stopped at the edges of the village and
i got to know guys like that when i was
in the peace corps in the early 80s that
world is over
these guys now have an a notion of the
world but it's a very skewed
and
um slanted and jagged and fragmented
notion that comes from mainly from
images and these images mainly come
through
satellite tv and the web
and far from knitting the world together
global media seems to at least in this
stage to be driving the world apart to
be making it a more violent place to be
giving us not a better idea of each
other but a more
um
violent and
simplistic and cartoon-like idea of each
other it's stoking hatreds and in the
case of these young guys envy because
that was their main feeling was envy
there's all this stuff out there in the
world and they can't have it they can't
reach it they can almost reach it
a french scholar in ivory coast said to
me it's it's lesch vitrine she said in
french meaning window licking it's not
window shopping because that means you
can go in and buy it's window looking
these guys were looking in the window at
the world
through global media and wanted it and
their
frustrated aspirations were sort of
literally driving them crazy certainly
driving them to pick up a gun
and so
in that part of the world global media
seem to be producing frustration and
alienation in the muslim and arab world
where i spent quite a bit of time
especially in iraq
it was bombarding young people with
selective images of violence that was
creating
um a very intense but very narrow view
of the the world and the west and
filling their heads through the internet
with a lot of conspiracy theories that
um that may had a basis in reality but
took them very far from reality and on
our part
we were getting a very sanitized view
of the awards that we had started and
were
you know through this sort of
um
the appearance of information on
places like cnn were actually
not getting much in the way of useful
information at all we were bombarded i
mean we've never been more saturated
with information but it has not led to
more clarity
it hasn't led to more complexity in our
thinking
and i think it by the end of this period
2001 to 8 it led to a desire to just
shut it off we had been overloaded with
information about the world especially
about countries where we were at war
fatigue set in and we wanted it to stop
so where does
interesting times come in
the kind of journalism that i and some
colleagues do is an attempt at least to
get past
that level
of communication in which
you're essentially being bombarded with
images like electrons and instead to use
words and and lots of words i mean the
new yorker is you know one of the very
last places on earth where you can
publish 15 000 words on a subject
and where you can not only do that but
you can
write about ordinary people
almost every one of my stories in the
book
is essentially about people who are not
famous not powerful ordinary people um
and it tells the stories of their lives
why is that worth hearing because it
first of all it's a way to get readers
to read and it's hard to get readers to
read a lot of words about foreign
countries we're an insular nation but i
think during this period there was a
curiosity for a while about the rest of
the world um which was one of the sort
of odd um good things that came out of 9
11 and
not just to get them to read but to get
them to understand how ordinary people
think about their own lives that became
sort of the goal of my reporting was to
get at how
people who in some ways are right on the
receiving end of our policies
and who in the world we live in in the
end are going to have an effect on us as
well how do they see themselves how do
they see the world um i mean it's a
limited form because
as a journalist i'm an expert in nothing
i don't speak
arabic i don't speak burmese
i get to go in for say three weeks at a
time so this cannot replace expertise
it's a it's an amateur
not in a totally bad way it's an
amateurish form
and but it's
the best way i know of to try to explain
to readers here what's going on in the
heads and lives of people who we
see in these flickering images on in
global media and the question is does
this form have any future and i'm i'm
not sure it does and if it if it doesn't
then i think we'll all be a little bit
the worst for it
[Applause]
[Music]
i know uh we want to get to questions at
some point is that right so i'll be very
brief just as these guys have been but i
have less to say so i'll be even briefer
and then maybe um
we can get to questions right away my
book is called the death of conservatism
it's a short historical narrative about
the rise the triumph then the decline
and death i think of this very important
modern political and intellectual
movement it starts with a new deal and
takes us through obama's administration
it goes at a very fast clip
it's about not ordinary people though it
may be about my non-reality-based belief
system um
it's really about extraordinary people
some of whom have been almost forgotten
uh thinkers like james burnham and
wilmore kendall the the late william f
buckley who probably a lot of people in
this audience do know and how they
shaped an idea of conservatism that came
to dominate our politics for several
decades and then
gradually lost its its direction and
focus as it was taken over by what we
think of as movement conservatism so the
book really describes two strains of
modern conservatism
one is what i call a classical
conservatism of edmund burke benjamin
disraeli this was the idea that
conservatism
is a philosophy that should hold a
culture and society together largely
through the instruments of government
believe it or not
and some of the figures who personified
that conservatism and our own politics
included dwight eisenhower
in his best days richard nixon who was
one of the most liberal presidents of
the modern era in many ways and i think
bill clinton who was the last great
conservative president we had
um
and i'll briefly explain why i think
clinton was a conservative president
explained in the book is he was a mirror
image of dwight eisenhower these were
two presidents who followed a series of
of presidencies dominated by the
opposition party which had worked
large transformations in the society
eisenhower came into office in 1953 was
elected in 52 after five consecutive
democratic presidencies something that's
inconceivable today
the republicans did not win a
presidential election in the in the
1930s
or 40s and eisenhower who came into
office as the first republican
was expected by some
to roll back or unravel the new deal
policies of franklin roosevelt and harry
truman and he didn't do it and the
reason he didn't do it was he saw the
policies worked and that the country
expected
the government to have some role in
society then if you flash forward to
1993 40 years later when bill clinton
took office he followed three republican
presidents this sort of short but
tumultuous age of of reagan as it's
sometimes called so i think it actually
began earlier with richard nixon
and clinton came into office as a kind
of barack obama as a kind of
kennedy and johnson
democratic liberal liberal democrat
and saw that the country for better or
worse seemed in aggregate to have
accepted and this may have been a big
mistake on clinton's part the free
market policies of the previous
president so what he decided to do was
to moderate them but not to undo them
and so in that sense both eisenhower and
clinton strike me as classically
conservative figures on the other side
are the movement conservatives the most
visible right now is sarah palin whose
new book is out
and we saw eight years of movement
conservatism under george bush the
consequences of which both chris and
george have described to some extent
this is a conservatism that's based on a
kind of organized hatred of liberal
enemies
and also of government and society and
social institutions
um universities
the the media
the legal profession uh people who work
for uh local state and federal
governments are all seen essentially as
dangerous or enemy figures by movement
conservatives
and so what they gave us was a
conservatism that by any classical
definition really sounds like radicalism
and i think the nearest parallel to some
of the so-called conservative protests
we saw over the summer
was the anti-government protests that
came on the left
in the in the late 1960s it's a it's a
politics of what daniel bell called
anti-nomianism the distrust of all
institutional values and so i think
we're fortunate to some extent to have a
president now
who by this classical definition has
very strongly conservative instincts
barack obama so that's the the story my
book tries to tell
and um so maybe now uh where is our
moderator there you are maybe we can get
to some questions or debates or
arguments or whatever yes
there's a microphone
[Applause]
[Music]
as you really nail it right on the head
with empire of illusion it's exactly
what is happening to this world today in
the grips of these monstrous money uh
these madmen that run this money system
and capitalism and the militarization
coming out of the pentagon but i would
like to ask you
um
you speak of the spectacle triumphs of
spectacle
how have they gotten away with the
september 11th
supreme hoax big lie what do you think
of the evidence of the crime of 9 11 and
who was responsible for placing the
explosives in those new york times
let me deal with spectacle first and
then i'll deal with
9 11. um
it was interesting hearing uh sam's
analysis some of which i agree with i'm
actually a fan of eisenhower and in
political terms define myself as a
conservative in a sense that uh
embracing karl popper's kind of
piecemeal engineering uh the the deep
distrust of utopianism but i think sam
has confused something
and that is that we have shifted from
conservatism
which in many ways was a positive force
and is a positive force in democratic
societies
to corporatism and that's something very
different
that the kind of
penny
capitalism that took place i grew up in
a farm town where farmers came in and
stole their goods even a regional
capitalism where the guy of the load in
in our local hardware store sat on the
school board that has been destroyed for
corporate capitalism uh which
has radically upended our politics and
when you talk about clinton uh clinton
made a very conscious decision to
uh take corporate money and do the
bidding of corporate donors he
understood that uh if he did that he
could have fundraising parity with the
republicans which he did by the 1990s
and of course now the democrats get more
and but to do the bidding of corporatism
men uh he accelerated what began in the
reagan administration which wasn't
conservatism but a kind of coup d'etat
in slow motion in which the citizens
were utterly disempowered to serve
corporate interests uh and that became
uh justified through the utopian
ideology of globalism of free-market
capitalism something carl pullani in his
great 1944 work the great transformation
uh understood that when a society loses
the capacity for the sacred when
you
build a system where human beings are
discarded like human refuse as we are
seen with our blue collar and i come out
of the blue collar so it's something
that has affected my own family uh you
build a kind of neo-feudalism uh and
that's where we're headed so i think we
have to make the distinction between
conservatism
and corporatism and we live in a
corporate state as sheldon wolin in
democracy incorporated probably our
greatest living political philosopher
has explained inverted totalitarianism
unlike classical totalitarianism finds
his expression in the anonymity of the
corporate state not in a demagogue not
in a charlatan
in a in a charismatic leader uh it uh
it doesn't tear down a structure uh
purports to cherish democracy electoral
politics while subverting uh the levers
of power uh it in in classical
totalitarianism
uh you you
politics always trumps economics and
inverted totalitarianism economics
trumps politics with different kinds of
ruthlessness and i think that
transformation while we still use the
language
of traditional
conservatism and the iconography of
american patronism has masked something
deeply insidious uh which is why we are
where we are now just on 911 uh i my
friend amy goodman unfortunately we get
these questions all the time i i i am a
denier in that sense
i don't think it was a conspiracy um
uh i covered al qaeda for the new york
times out of paris including huge
investigations into muhammad atta
and i i think the reason 911 worked is
because otta was brilliant and
disciplined obviously deeply psychotic
and without it without him it wouldn't
have worked uh just to be fair to you i
also have not studied the structural
analysis and which some people have who
make that claim that uh
you know this was orchestrated but um as
someone who did spend a year of my life
covering al qaeda it's my impression
that uh it's more that the bush
administration was asleep at the switch
unless that there was active involvement
i don't believe there was active
involvement in the attacks of 9 11.
for next please for mr hedges
uh obama was against invading iraq in
2002
he promised change in 2008 once he was
president he appointed george bush's
secretary of defense to be secretary of
defense and now the american military
presence in iraq and afghanistan is far
greater than it was under george bush
please explain because obama's a brand
uh obama uh
you know he
uh think of obama the way uh remember
when calvin klein and bennetton
associated risque style and hiv models
and all this stuff
to
give their products an edge and a
progressive appeal
but of course
the end result was the same which is to
make
consumers confused a brand with an
experience
that is what obama provided uh he has as
you correctly point out not veered from
uh the policies endorsed either
financial or military by the bush
administration uh the kinds of arguments
that occur between the democrats and the
republicans are as freud says
essentially about the narcissism of
minor difference
we
see the rise of the corporatism
corporate state in every aspect
including the health care debate any
uh factual
discussion of health care in this
country would begin with the
acknowledgement that the for-profit
health care industry is the problem and
must be destroyed
this
[Applause]
this is an industry
this is an industry
that has the legal right
to hold sick children hostage
while their parents bankrupt themselves
to save their sons and daughters
and the inability to have a rational
discussion
around health care
is driven
because obama
sadly is largely a figurehead
and has been emasculated by the
corporate forces that have orchestrated
the largest transference of wealth
upwards in american history
and are destroying
a country
that i love
[Applause]
[Music]
another question for you chris
hey these guys are feeling i know i feel
but i gotta ask this if
you had been president in 2007 and your
uh treasury secretary came to you and
said you got to come up with a quarter
of a billion to
save the financial industry or there's
going to be some kind of armageddon what
would you have done
um
the decision to
commit
12.8 trillion dollars in guarantees
loans
uh
to a financial system dominated by
speculators and remember
that in the 17th century speculators
were
hung
uh has empowered a criminal class
that
has not only trashed the global economy
but robbed
small shareholders
many of whom are sitting in this room
who month after month
put money aside for retirement and
college
and were wiped out
and
those who wiped them out figures like
richard fuld from lehman brothers
walked away with 485
million dollars in bonuses and
compensation
wall street
is run by a criminal class
at this point
and
most of them belong on trial
not
subsidized
in the most
disgusting example of corporate
welfare
in human history what is so myopic about
what's happening
is that
corporatism
is
actually destroying
the socialism that's trying to save it
um we a year from now
these corporations are not going to pump
this kind of liquidity into the market
and we are going to be bereft of
resources to respond to the growing
desperation that is sweeping across the
country so um
yeah i think most of these people belong
behind bars
and this is for mr tennant house
first of all i'd like to see
to for you to defend yourself and
secondly
i wanted to ask you
a in regard to your book
uh the the
historian the political historian
schlesinger jr
said that conservatism and liberalism
came about every 30 years
do you propose that is that part of your
your thinking
um that's an interesting
question um right you're talking about
the cycles of history that both
schlesinger's first elder and then
younger disgust
i
draw on
a parallel idea
that schlesinger also had some interest
in that was proposed by
quite brilliant and unsung
uh political journalist from the 1950s
uh named sam lou bells hammer lubell
wrote a really ingenious book called the
future of american politics
and he had what he called the solar
system theory
of uh democracy in america as far as the
two parties go that what seems to be
an equally balanced two-party system
is actually is actually a history of
cycles in which one party dominates
the other that's the sun party he called
it
in his solar uh metaphor and the other
party becomes a minority party the moon
party that orbits around the center so
for ex for instance
in 1860 with his in essence the creation
of the modern republican party the
election of abraham lincoln republicans
really dominated our politics until
1932
there were two democratic presidents
elected in that period grover cleveland
who governed more or less as a clinton
or eisenhower did and woodrow wilson who
was elected because there was a split
within the republican party that opened
the way for him and theodore roosevelt
broke away from the republican party in
1912.
with the election of franklin roosevelt
in 32
we saw the rise of the democratic sun
which lasted either until 1968 or 1980
depending on your point of view that is
either with the election of nixon or
then reagan in those and we're not we
have now entered a period that one ended
in i think 1992. i think actually the
conservative movement ended with the
election of bill clinton we sometimes
forget that out of the last five
presidential elections a plurality of
votes was won by democrats four times
the only time the republicans won was in
2004 an election that was misrepresented
as a great sweeping mandate when in fact
it was the closest re-election the
sitting president in modern history it
will have the smallest governing
majority than than since mckinley at the
end of the 19th century
what happened was in an analysis not so
different i think from uh what chris
might say is the republicans had seized
so much control over the political
apparatus and the institutions in the
culture that in 2000 they were able to
put their guy in office
and um at that point with uh september
11th the republicans have their
opportunity rather the conservatives
within the republican party
there were an opportunity to pursue
their agenda any way they liked because
of september 11th with the consequences
we saw
so
we have now begun a period i think of
democratic uh domination and i would not
be
misled by all the noise and shouting and
uh fringe insurgencies we're seeing on
the right when a party is has no ideas
and no serious governing philosophy
which the republicans now do not have
that's when the noise gets loudest in
the late 1950s and early 60s another
period when the republicans were on the
margins with the moon party the loudest
voices came from the john birch society
remember uh their explanation of the
universe that dwight eisenhower was a
communist who reported to a superior
communist his brother milton eisenhower
and the government was dominated by 70
or 80 percent of uh soviet agents who
wanted to poison us through fluoridated
water
this was the ideology of the hard right
back then it's not remarkably different
from some of what we hear now
the
the birthers for instance a classic kind
of conspiratorial view of government so
my answer to the question is that we
have actually entered a period dark
though chris may think it is of
democratic party domination now you know
to um as far as chris's argument about
corporatism versus conservatism because
someone uh wanted me to address that
that may be true
i'm not sure this will appall many um
how
terrible that is and how even important
it is because
um our system is one of
uh dominated by a sort of a centrist
consensus i think
most people don't stand all that far
apart from one another on a continuum in
other words if in a country of 300
million people a very large number of
them however diluted they may be
think that a capitalist system is the
one that's going to work then that's the
one we're going to have that i don't
think it's imposed by evil tycoons they
may exploit it they may exploit our
fantasies and illusions
and uh misplaced ambitions but this is
still an aspirational nation
most people i think i may be mistaken
look back on our history and see much to
admire and applaud in it and see great
advances we've made not always directly
and not always as
far
um in the
precise direction we'd all like to go in
but essentially one of improvement and
further democratization
and
to as long as a majority of the nation
kind of thinks that way we will get the
elected figures we have i don't think
our nation is really a conspiracy so
that's my answer there george you should
say something i want to just add one
thing
i think it's true that the pendulum
basically does go back and forth and
clearly last november 4th it took a
decisive turn but each time it swings it
kind of incorporates what just came
before it it doesn't negate it it
incorporates it and what's just come
before
obama's presidency
is
the most
far-reaching radical in sam's words
and i think effective assault on the
idea that government has a central role
in the well-being of american citizens
in our history i mean we've always been
an anti-government country
the revolution was an anti-government
revolution and that idea has been
powerful but it's always been tempered
because there were elements of both
parties that saw something important in
government during the civil war lincoln
represented the idea of strong
government teddy roosevelt did for the
republican party against the trust
woodrow wilson brought it to the
democratic party with a different idea
about um what what chris calls
corporatism roosevelt sort of was the
um
the the apogee of the idea of government
centrality in our lives but it has been
so undermined by
both a sustained political and
propaganda assault i mean the the media
plays a big role in this and also by the
failure
of 30 years of government
to reverse the decline in living
standards
of millions and millions of americans so
that now and this is something i found
while reporting last year in ohio during
the campaign people who
stand to benefit enormously from health
care reform
are deeply suspicious of health care
reform
now why is that have they been deluded
by fox news i try to stay away from the
conspiratorial explanation because i
think it takes away
the agency and the ability of
individuals to kind of come to their own
conclusions this is why i focus on
individuals in my reporting what do they
think about their own lives that's what
ultimately matters and in ohio what they
thought was one obama is two-thirds arab
as one woman told me but two
i'll ask where'd you hear that on the
internet
but two
that
the government isn't gonna do it
whatever they do they're going to either
screw it up or it's going to benefit
either rich people or the shiftless idle
poor who are on welfare it's not going
to benefit me that's what i was hearing
from third generation coal mining
families in the appalachian part of ohio
who were the backbone of the
pro-government democratic party during
the period of roosevelt and truman and i
think obama understood that and he had a
hard time with those voters he
eked out just enough votes in those
areas to win ohio and to win
indiana
but
if he is going to be a successful
president he has to convince those
people and millions of others that
government can be a force for good in
their lives because they're not looking
for government to do something they are
skeptical bitter angry and that's why
they're always a very easy target
for
um for the right wing and when obama
made that
slip about you know bitter voters
clinging to their guns
it was a very unfortunate thing to say
because it was i thought condescending
but he was hitting at exactly what i'm
saying and i think he was right that
these voters have been
seeing their lives getting harder and
harder for so long that they no longer
trust the democratic party or the
government to do anything about it and
right now i'd say obama is running some
risk especially in his economic policies
of a backlash next year even if we're at
the beginning of an age of democratic
dominance i think there could be a real
backlash because some of these policies
don't seem to be benefiting anyone but
uh an elite health care reform well you
know i'm sure obama himself is an
advocate of single payer in his heart
but he's not going to get it because as
sam says we're not a nation of
single-payer supporters so he's he's
getting he's he and congress are in that
in the unbelievably um disappointing and
and and slow and sort of repellent
process that is legislative democracy
are trying to reform the health care
system i think that will be
the key to whether he he and the
democrats um
do well by the voters next year if they
cannot control both
the legislative and executive and get
health care reform the voters will
punish them badly a year from now let me
just quickly add something to that
having spent two years writing a book on
the christian right
i spent a lot of time in these former
manufacturing
centers like youngstown and and george
is right this bitterness and much of my
own family comes from former mill towns
in maine utterly destroyed by nafta
nafta 1994 passed by democratic
administration thrust a bat a knife into
the back of the american working class
it was a tremendous betrayal
and when you talk about blue-collar
workers being angry at liberals
and voting against their own interests i
think that's incorrect
liberals betrayed the working class in
this country and the working class
understood the vast hypocrisy on the
part of a bankrupt liberal elite that
continued to talk in the language
of democracy
and
workers rights and year after year
supported a democratic party that
betrayed those rights uh whether it was
so-called welfare reform or the
destruction of glass-steagall
and what we have done by allowing
corporations to literally dismantle our
manufacturing base
a frightening kind of alienation and
engender deep personal and economic
despair among the working class
but permanently disenfranchise the
working class these jobs at least the
kinds of jobs that you had in mills and
steel mills is not they're not coming
back
it's why
you have
people you know struggling
two three four jobs taking jobs in
walmart where they're below
the poverty line and that disempowerment
of the citizenry that violation of the
american working class is creating an
oligarchic system and
you cannot sustain a functioning or a
healthy democracy in an oligarchy and
that's something that even the ancient
greek writers on democracy like plutarch
and thucydides understood so i think
that we are not seeing traditional
conservatism we are seeing something far
more radical uh in the form of american
corporatism well it is no loyalty to
america in terms of globalization and
corporatism which
is literally hollowing out our country
from the inside and the rise of the
corporate state has grave political
consequences as we saw in italy and
germany uh in the early part of the 20th
century and i just um
[Applause]
have a question yeah oh yeah go ahead
much of what the three of you have said
i feel
is attributable to a phenomenon that
goes by the name of the overton window
which describes shifting what is
currently acceptable to a more radical
position
um so that we accept things like fox
news which is really fox propaganda we
accept things that the corporate is has
enjoys personhood
which is the position of the supreme
court after the last few decades
and
other examples many of which i think
that you guys have detailed
what i want to ask you is the
republicans slash conservatives have
been very successful
at moving the overton window and the
liberals slash democrats have been
notably unsuccessful
can you give us your ideas as to why
that is so can i offer one quick
explanation um
that's uh uh mentioned in my book
in
a very
brilliant uh political analyst who once
actually worked in both the kennedy and
johnson administrations said when it he
said conservatives have
a genius
for the semantics of political debate
he said for instance
national health insurance is recast as
socialized medicine
and
um
the
opposition to a minimum wage is called
the right to work the southern strategy
is another racial bigotry richard
goodwin wrote that in 1967
and the actual terms are still
in use today
and what the right was able to do at
that point was to create a rhetoric
that was more effective in reaching the
public sam why why don't chris's terms
by maurization neo-feudalism corporatism
uh push aside
socialized medicine
um and and the rest of the rights
uh slogan well one answer to that would
be that um
here's an interesting contradiction we
have that now those are the terms you
use george i don't know if chris
embraces them but chris
exactly
yeah okay
embrace them but he used them well
here's part of the here's part of the
problem it was something i wanted to
mention before
everything chris said about um the
working class and and the blue-collar
worker is true and he said that the jobs
in the manufacturing jobs are not coming
back what happened to john mccain in the
2008 primary when he went to michigan
and said exactly that
he lost badly that's why my book is
called empire of illusion
well the problem is if if so much if the
very voters
that are affected
by these drastic
downshifts in their economic status
won't accept the argument when it's
presented to them
then you have a kind of cognitive
dissonance which is part of the problem
let me just say a second thing that the
terms that that um chris used and and
that you mentioned here
george i fear i may be wrong but they
don't res
those are terms that even if they are
advanced
in the interests of the working class
sound like the language of the harvard
seminar room
whereas
the what the the addendum that goodwin
had was the reason republicans are so
good at this or he really said
conservatives because in those days
there were liberal republicans and
moderate republicans there aren't any
more there were back then
is because yeah two right is because
they always seem to make the issue
national security or the national
interest well basically sam the
republicans from mccarthy to
reagan and gingrich seized the populist
language
and took it from the left and moved it
to the right and populism has this very
old history in our country it goes back
to jefferson and jackson in the 1890s
farmers and workers joined together to
create the people's party which was a
populist party in the 30s there was a
challenge to roosevelt from the left
coming from huey long and others that
was populist in the 60s there was
populism in the language of the
protesters but it it moved to the right
chris is essentially in the tradition
of left-wing populism i mean what chris
has said today
is in different terms and maybe it's the
language of the harvard seminar room
maybe it's not is very much the same
point of view that the pot that the
farmers of the 1890s had that the
bankers and the railroads and the robber
barons as they called them then maybe it
was a better language maybe it was more
colorful um robber barons has stuck with
us because it's such a good term maybe
the right wing had that genius for
finding those terms that stick and
that's half the battle in politics it is
an undercurrent in american politics
that has been with us from the beginning
and chris is a very articulate spokesman
for my feeling is it doesn't win
it doesn't win elections but it what it
does do is push the democratic party to
the left we are a reformist nation we
are not a radical nation i think sam's
right about that and
i think chris's language and point of
view
will not
become majoritarian and will not win
national elections but it could
force the democrats who do win elections
to be
more radical in their reforms let me let
me just quickly first of all
you know
most of my relatives
at best finished high school they can
certainly understand this language
however infected i have been by harvard
second of
all um
we forgot
karl popper's great dictum
that the question is not how to get good
people to rule
the question
because most people attracted to power
are
mediocre at best and often venal
the the question is how
do we stop the powerful from doing
as much damage as they can to
us and that becomes by building
movements
that frighten those in power you talk
about sam talks about nixon being the
last liberal president and he's right
but uh richard nixon at his heart was
not a liberal he was just frightened of
movements
of the labor movement
of the civil rights movement
and of the anti-war movement and all of
the correctives in american democracy
have not come from the top including the
new deal
they came from movements
the suffragists
the liberty party that fought slavery
and
the bankruptcy of american liberalism is
that it became entranced by power
our job if you care about the working
class in this country is to build
movements
movements as i used to live in france
and saw
that frighten people in power people
like richard nixon who did not have a
moral bone in his body
to pass the clean water act and
support civil rights legislation
and that's been our failure
we have been seduced by a corporatized
democratic party
and
and that has had
terrifying consequences for our
democracy actually the reason nixon
passed civil rights legislation and
advocated affirmative action was because
he knew it was going to break up the
democratic party and that's exactly what
happened
that's how machiavelli and richard nixon
was
which by the way
is not necessarily
the worst way for a politician to
operate so uh what's our next question
for one more question i would throw in
bismarckian might be the best uh
description um as journalists this is a
question for each of you um 24-hour news
uh has increased the speed of speed
speed of news so uh information uh the
news is getting dumber secondly uh i'm
sorry you said the news is getting is
get dumber yeah uh it's dumbed down uh
blogs allow everybody to retreat into
their own groups and not have any proof
of anything and we have hallucinations
of death panels and 9 11 conspiracies
and thirdly
uh mainstream media
uh hosts seems seduced uh very often by
the illusions and myths of the
power elite if you want to call them
that and like they won't quite like the
whole lead up to the iraq war there was
no evidence for the weapons mass
destruction but they all believe it so
what can journalists do to
bring more reality
into the debate and more proof and
higher standards so that we have real
information to reach real solutions
i think the first thing they can do is
survive i mean
you've that's a a brilliant distillation
of what is wrong with our media the
thing you said about people moving into
their ideological corners as more
websites proliferate i think cass
sunstein who now works for the obama
administration called that
niche extremism in other words the more
sites there are the more segregated we
are ideologically and the more extreme
we become because the web is not a
source of
news it's a source of opinion and it
preys upon and is parasitic upon
news which comes from other sources
like the new york times for example well
right now the new york times is trying
to fire a hundred people
um well we're offering them buy-outs
now
i don't know what chris thinks about
that so maybe i shouldn't mention um you
know the washington post is
becoming a shell of itself the los
angeles times long ago stopped being
itself the chicago tribune
i'm sure you've got your florida
counterparts um
how's the herald doing is very tough i
mean the fact that the saint petersburg
times is still alive is due to the fact
that it's supported by a non-profit
institute the pointer so
we are the greatest threat right now to
maybe to our democracy is the fact that
they're the economic model that
supported serious
news gathering and in my case serious
narrative journalism in the long form
it has collapsed and no one has figured
out
how to replicate it on the web so
the the the first question is not you
know what can journalists do to improve
it's what can journalists do to stay in
their jobs
it's a cultural problem we are shifting
from a print-based society to an
image-based society something writers
like neil postman wrote eloquently about
and that has terrifying consequences
we are a society utterly awash in lies
skillfully manipulated images
that make us confuse how we are made to
feel with knowledge
you talk about health care
why do we
fear
universal health care or why do some
elements of the society fear it well
because uh we speak
talk and think in the idiom of popular
culture which is about uh linguistically
at about a sixth grade level
and
the refusal
to uh
to disconnect from these images uh and
uh
and and
and study issues
outside of the jargon and cliches that
are handed to us by one side or another
has rendered us impotent this is not a
new phenomena throughout history cicero
wrote about it uh when he decried the
spectacle of the roman arena
and
we are
moving
away
from nuanced thought from
the struggle with ambiguity uh uh for
this kind of childish can uh that as
someone mentioned fox news that
dominates most of the cable news
networks and so when we watch the death
of newspapers uh you know
philadelphia inquirer san francisco
chronicle all in bankruptcy proceedings
uh the new york times
struggling we are seeing
the dying gasps of a culture that is
severing itself from print and entering
an age of terrifying illiteracy
there have been other periods in human
history when populations have been
illiterate uh but no society has been
able to replicate reality to such an
extent that we confuse pseudo events and
images for reality itself uh a third of
the country is illiterate 42 million
americans uh uh cannot read and about 50
million americans read at a fourth or
fifth grade level and then there are
people who are functionally literate
um but who don't read anymore uh and
that has political and social
consequences that i think we are
watching
in as we see the death uh of print and
we and and i think george is right a
democracy
that severs itself from the print-based
world
and from newspapers which for all of
their flaws and and they have many and
their subservience to advertisers and
commercialism uh nevertheless whole
entire cities community means that huge
sections of america will in essence go
dark nobody will be at city hall nobody
will be covering the police and the
ability for corruption and the abuse of
power by our power elite will grow
exponentially
thank you thank you all very much that
wraps it up i hope you've enjoyed it as
much as i have
ladies and gentlemen mr tannenhaus has
one last comment
please
supreme court
uh all i was going to say is i'm afraid
both my colleagues are absolutely right
i wanted to add one more thing however
and
because there was much talk about
newspapers
um
i think what we're most in danger of
losing i think there is a fair amount of
reading
in some ways all too much reading that
goes on in front of computers and online
and people are
assimilating little bits of information
as both my co-panelists have described
what i worry about most is what kind of
writing we're going to get from the
internet not just what people read but
how do you take essays like george's a
very brilliantly reported
stories from iraq six and eight and ten
thousand words i don't see how they're
going to be read in any form but a kind
of
concrete holdable print form
and that
may actually change
the way prose is written in this country
are you offering me a buyout
so i i'm really uh you know as a guy who
edits a book review i'm uh really
worried about that too
so thank you all
thank you
[Music]
[Applause]
there will be autographs in the
autograph area to follow the directions
of the volunteers and be sure to buy
some books thanks
[Music]
a panel discussion on u.s politics and
culture with authors george packer chris
hedges and sam tannenhouse to find out
more go to
miamibookfair.com
we'll be back live at miami book fair
shortly
coming up chris hedges argues that
america's liberal class has collapsed
and with it the citizenry's protection
against what he deems the corporate
state
mr hedges contends that the liberal
class which includes universities labor
movements the press the democratic party
and liberal religious groups has been
gradually corrupted by corporate
entities and without its existence there
will no longer be a structure of checks
and balances against corporate interests
chris hedges presents his thoughts at
powell's books in portland oregon
it's an hour and a half
thank you
uh this book had a kind of funny genesis
uh it began as a book for cunniff on
the fate of
the u.s media
in particular newspapers where i spent
most of my career as a journalist
and i certainly agreed with the editors
at cunhaff that
the collapse of newsprint
and
large metropolitan dailies is
catastrophic for our country
and yet
having spent many many years inside
these institutions 15 of them with the
new york times i'm hardly blind to their
failings
uh and when i turned the manuscript in
they hated it
um
they described my critique of the
american media as
filled with negativity which um
they uh
generously offered to remove
before they published the book
you can imagine how that went over
so i was out the door
with the manuscript
and as i wrote the book
i kept running into the fact that the
press was hardly hardly existed in a
vacuum
that the press was one of the pillars of
the liberal establishment that has
certainly failed us
but there were other pillars of the
liberal establishment all of the pillars
of the liberal establishment
which in the last few decades have
reduced themselves to functioning
primarily as the role of courtiers
to the power elite and to the corporate
state
these would include the church the
liberal church which i come out of
my father was a presbyterian minister i
myself graduated from seminary
it would include the democratic party
it would include labor unions
culture
as well as universities
and so i broadened the focus to look at
the liberal class
to look at what happened to those
liberal institutions
that were vital
in maintaining
a democratic state
and
i ended up going back
to world war one
uh world war one
or certainly the eve of world war one
was the moment
when
powerful popular movements
that represented the interests of
ordinary americans threatened the grip
on power of the oligarchic elite
dwight mcdonald who i admire greatly
wrote
that
the war was the rock on which these
movements broke
and they broke
because
world war one saw the birth
of the system of mass propaganda
which ever since has saturated our
culture with lies
it saw the rise of the committee of
public information or the creel
commission led by george creel former
muckraking journalist who appropriately
ended his career working for joe
mccarthy and richard nixon
in the 1950s
and the anti-communist witch hunts
and the house on american affairs
activity
because the war
had no popular support
wilson in fact ran for
re-election on the slogan that he kept
us out of the war
but the bankers
wall street
had lent tremendous sums of money
to the british
and the french
and if the germans won the war that
money was not going to be repaid
and so there was
pressure
from the financial elite
to push us into a conflict
that had no popular support at all very
little popular support wilson and
walter littman and
arthur bellard all of them understood
this
and so they created uh
this
remarkable
system
to saturate the country
with propaganda crossing the lines of
many disciplines they had their own film
division they had a news division that
pumped out uh one endless uh sort of uh
pro-war news story after another
manufactured of course all of the
atrocities attributed to the hated hun
they used graphic artists
they used radio they established
speakers bureaus
and
it was the first time
where there was a conscious
understanding
that what moved
the mass of people
was not fact
or reason
but the manipulation of emotion
they drew on the work of trotter and le
bone and finally sigmund freud
edward bernays came out of the committee
for public information the father of
modern propaganda indeed his book
propaganda was one of the books that was
closely studied by goebbels as the nazis
built their own propaganda machine
and
this
insight into mass psychology and bullard
when he argues he was bullard was one of
uh woodrow wilson students at princeton
and along with lipman walter littman who
comes across as a very dark figure with
his book public opinion and the and that
phrase manufacturing consent how does
one manufacture consent the lard writes
to wilson as their setting attempting to
set up
the committee for public information
truth and falsehood
are arbitrary terms
there is nothing in experience to tell
us that one
is preferable to the other
there are lifeless truths
and vital lies
the force of an idea
lies in its inspirational value
it matters very little whether it is
true
or false
and this
understanding coupled with the resources
of the state
to saturate the country with propaganda
was effectively used by the power elite
to destroy
all of those broad-based social
movements
that
were bringing this country towards
socialism
uh
you remember eugene debs pulled a
million votes
uh there were huge publications appeal
to reason was the fourth largest
publication in the country uh was a
socialist publication the masses we had
several dozen socialist mayors
we had strong push within the cio the
wobblies
and
and so there was a kind of twinning
of the
war propaganda machine uh
as not only a vehicle
to uh garner mass support for an
unpopular war but to break the back of
these movements
and they succeeded and some of the most
poignant writing about this is done by
randolph-born and jane adams two of the
amazingly heroic figures who resisted
the tide and what uh depressed them so
deeply was uh
how swiftly the intellectual class many
of the socialists themselves
like sinclair lewis and others were
seduced
into the war effort replacing the
tangible goals of hygiene and good
public housing and good public education
and fair working conditions with that
abstract goal of making the world safe
for democracy the war to end all war
so that the actual physical forms of
repression embodied in the uh sedition
act and the espionage act
were used on a relatively
marginal segment of the society that uh
that still held out
and by the end of the war
the
those who had built this system of mass
propaganda
and lasswell writes about this in his
book
immediately found employment
on madison avenue they went to work for
corporations
who
upended traditional american values of
thrift
of self-effacement
of
uh
and replaced it
with consumption as a kind of inner
compulsion with the cult of the self
they homogenized
culture
they destroyed regional and ethnic
cultures
and
replaced it
with corporate culture which is of
course what we call american culture but
it's not american culture was
effectively destroyed
they used the espionage and the sedition
act after the war to go after the
remnants of these movements with the
palmer raids
the deportation of anarchists like emma
goldman to russia
they shut down appeal to reason although
appeal to reason under pressure had
actually editorially supported the war
during the war
along with the masses they made war on
the wobblies
trumped up murder charges so joe hill's
executed big bill haywood ends his life
the last 10 years of his life uh fleeing
a trumped up murder charge as a refugee
in the soviet union
so
there was
a new paradigm that was created
which dwight mcdonald writes about
as one where
we entered essentially a state of
permanent war
we entered a state of constant fear
the dreaded hun was immediately replaced
with the dreaded red
and mcdonald i think makes a very
important point
that none of the social and political
theorists
of the late 19th century including karl
marx
understood
that in a system of permanent war
and skillful mass propaganda
you could get the masses to call for
their own enslavement
the only time marx writes about war is
during the prussian war and uh he
expresses the hope that prussia will win
uh because it will make the german
workers state uh closer to uh coming to
fruition
and we have essentially been emasculated
ever since
so radical movements are consciously
destroyed and liberal movements
engage in a kind of internal
cannibalization where they push out
figures who have a moral conscience
who have some kind of autonomy
uh branding them as sympathetic to
communism of course many of these people
who were pushed out were not communists
although having lived in europe
including italy uh
there is nothing under our constitution
that prohibits
uh a communist party uh i believe that
uh uh we purport to
support the free exchange of political
thought and ideas um
and uh and the liberal class without
that counterweight of radical movements
to keep them honest
uh began to disembowel themselves
now the liberal class serves an
important function
in
a state
and that function is twofold
it acts as a kind of safety valve
it makes piecemeal and incremental
reform possible and the best example of
how the liberal class works
would be
with the breakdown of capitalism in the
1930s and the rise of the new deal
we had essentially ceteris figures
like franklin roosevelt
or the great henry wallace
later in his own presidential campaign
in 48 uh tarred smeared for
being
soft on communism and turned into a
political pariah the last
major political figure we had with maybe
the exception of george mcgovern to
challenge the permanent war economy
and the
resources taxpayer resources that are
pumped into the huge defense industry
um
so
we saw the liberal class
provide channels or mechanisms within
the power structure by which the
grievances and injustices and suffering
of work in men and women could be
redressed
that's how the liberal class that is the
role of the liberal class
and it's why traditional power elites
tolerate liberal institutions and
tolerate the liberal class
so that they're they're not completely
tone deaf to the suffering of those
outside the power elite but at the same
time they are used to discredit radical
uh movements that challenge traditional
structures and assumptions
which is true today
the figure that
self-identified liberals hate most
is not glenn beck
it's noam chomsky
because noam chomsky
exposes the collaboration
of the liberal a class with the power
elite and the ways they serve the power
elite
the danger is that when liberal
institutions no longer function
when they ossify ossify calcify
uh then there is no
mechanism by which
the grievances of large sectors of a
dispossessed population can be expressed
within the system
we saw
[Music]
of course immediately after world war ii
the final
round
of the assault
on
radical and progressive
movements the remnants of them
universities purge themselves of
thousands
of professors
many of these cases it was a silent
purge
where people were just not granted
tenure dismissed for no reason after the
fbi visited a dean's office
uh
including
hundreds of high school teachers
social workers many many social workers
were purged
uh the press that's how uh probably our
greatest 20th century journalist iaf
stone
became
an outcast and a pariah
because he refused to take uh truman's
loyalty oath
and couldn't even get a job finally at
the nation magazine
well i won't go into the nation um
and uh ends up printing if stones weekly
in his basement
he writes
gutton plan wrote a really nice
biography of stone that came out
recently but stone writes or says at the
time that he felt like a ghost
um
he began a talk
in annie war talk and he said
um
fellow subversives
and and uh and the fbi um because of
course
the fbi
wasted tremendous amounts of resources
following around figures like i have
stone as they did howard zinn i use some
of the
files on zinn they were just released
under freedom of information act to
describe uh the folly of internal
security and you i can assure you
homeland security is just as buffoonish
as these guys were trying to recruit zen
on the street or
filing a report from uh someone who they
said was in sister about zinn's detailed
activities the only problem being of
course that zinn didn't even have a
sister
and
the the liberal establishment
by the end of the mccarthy period was so
craven
in its
embrace of the cold war politics that
you had institutions like the aclu
carrying out internal hunts uh for
people who were either pink or red
and of course the people carrying out
those hunts were the most craven careers
the people with the least moral
center the least moral uh the as as
adorno says the capacity to say no
so that not only did we decimate
radical progressive popular movements
but at the same time we destroyed the
core of liberal institutions as well
and this coast coincided with the rise
of the corporate state
it saw
probably the last great champion
in this country
and we will rue the day that we walked
out on this guy
was ralph nader
who pushed through one piece of great
legislation after another ralph was a
good friend of mine always says you know
the last liberal president we had was
richard nixon
well in terms of legislation that's true
uh osha the clean water act the mining
safety act 20 some 24 pieces of
legislation because
nixon was still scared
of movements
and responded to those movements
and of course there was a conscious
effort as anyone who has read the powell
memo which i quote at length in the book
to take nader down
and they created and funded powerful
right wing corporate think tanks
and centers like the heritage foundation
the business roundtable
to
destroy
any kind of populist activity
especially the kind of populist activity
that nader was so successful at when he
still had allies in the democratic party
in the 1960s
and once all of these checks were gone
we began to see
what can only be described as a coup
d'etat
in slow motion by corporations
where
they dismantled
everything that impeded
the maximization of corporate profits
they made war
on the remnants of labor unions
they passed nafta
and that was passed but for me bill
clinton is the poster child
of
bankrupt liberalism
[Applause]
clinton understood that if he did
corporate bidding
he could get corporate money
and that the working class
and labor would have nowhere else to go
and
by the 1990s the democratic party had
fundraising parity with the republicans
and by the time barack obama ran for
president
they got more
but the price of that was
a betrayal
of the working class that traditionally
the democratic party and liberal
institutions had once protected
and our great failure for those of us
who care about ordinary the rights of
ordinary citizens
is that in 1994 with the passage of
nafta we did not stand up for the
working class and turn our back on the
democratic party
we continued to support
democratic politicians who spoke in the
traditional language of liberalism but
betrayed every single core liberal value
welfare reform
we now face the prospect
with this new midterm election
of unemployment benefits
for tens of millions of citizens
running out or being allowed to run not
being extended
which will mean that many of these
people will have to attempt to survive
on the
143 dollars a month you receive from
welfare courtesy of the democratic party
the deregulation of the banking system
the deregulation of the fcc
i just spent the
full teaching
at the university of toronto
and they don't have a banking crisis in
canada
because they did not allow the firewalls
between their commercial and investment
banks which had been protected for us
under the 1933 glass-steagall act to be
ripped down
and so
we saw
the liberal
class evolve
into courtiers
for the corporate state
and yet they spoke
in the traditional language of
liberalism
and were exposed
as the two-year administration of barack
obama has exposed
the deep cynicism
and hypocrisy
of the liberal class
a tragedy if tragedy is the right word
of barack obama
is that he made a faustian bargain with
corporate interests
he sold us out
whether it's the fisa reform act that
retroactively made legal but under our
constitution is illegal the warrantless
wiretapping and eavesdropping on tens of
millions of americans
whether it is to continue the looting
by
wall street speculators and swindlers
who have engaged in massive
fraudulent
acts that are criminal
using mortgage brokers and bankers to
falsify information on loan applications
that they knew were false
to hand sums of money to people they
also knew could never
repay it
and selling
these subprime mortgages
as assets
whether it is the continuation of our
imperial wars
in iraq and afghanistan which
preemptive war
under post-nuremberg laws are defined as
criminal wars of aggression
they're a crime
and we have no right as a nation to
debate the terms of the occupation
whether it is the
swindle that became the so-called health
care reform bill
400 billion dollars in subsidies to our
for-profit health care industry
the equivalent of the bank bailout bill
for aetna cigna
wellfleet
and we are watching
barack obama hand these corporations
exemptions
because they don't want to ensure
chronically ill
children
i spend enough time in seminary to tell
you
that
we can only define
these kinds of institutions
as
institutions of death
they make their money
directly off of human suffering
and pain
and death
including the death of children
it is legally permitted
in the united states
to hold sick children hostage
while their parents frantically bankrupt
themselves
trying to save their sons or daughters
that is what corporations do
and
the failure of the liberal class
to stand up
on behalf of the weak
and the sick
to challenge the perverted idea
that nothing is sacred
that everything is a commodity
human beings are commodities
the natural world is a commodity
which corporations exploit
until exhaustion or collapse
means
that this coup
is essentially cannibalizing not only
our country
but the planet
and it is not accidental that the
environmental crisis
is
intimately twinned with the economic
crisis
because profit
comes before the urgent task to save the
ecosystem
on which human life depends
the rise
of proto-fascist movements
leaping up around the fringes of
american society
expressed
in the emotionally consistent but
irrational political beliefs of groups
like the tea party and the militias
brings with it a hatred of government
for the betrayal that government carried
out
but also a hatred of the liberal class
itself
for the hypocrisy that the liberal class
carried out
and the rage is a legitimate rage
it should have been our rage and it
should be our rage now
[Applause]
the tragedy
is that the core liberal values
which those of us who care
about
our dispossessed working men and women
those values have been utterly
discredited
it's why you have
the trash talking cable news
and uh and radio talk show hosts
attempting to tar obama and the
democratic party with not only the tag
of liberalism but the tag of socialism
because their impotence in the face of
the corporate state
is one
that they seek or they use to discredit
the very values that saved us during the
new deal remember during the new deal we
could have gone either way
go back and read smedley butler who was
hired by
a bunch of
industrialists
to carry out a coup d'etat
there was tremendous support for fascism
in the early 1930s
fortune magazine put mussolini on the
cover and lauded his
breaking of labor unions
and his exaltation of the industrial
class at the expense of workers
and we were saved
because we had a liberal class that
worked
that was able to push through the kinds
of reforms that reincorporated a
disenfranchised
working class back into the economy
we face now
a situation and the possibility of an
economic collapse
that will rival
the great depression
and
i'm sure there are many of you in this
room who read the front pages of the
wall street journal
and the new york times this morning
the
euro is collapsing because of course
they bought all our junk
the
social upheavals
are
spreading throughout the country
there's serious questions about
italy's viability and its ability to
handle its debt
and there's a limit
to how much can be borrowed
and how much can be lent
and
we have allowed
our corporate oligarchs to
take from us
the final resources that could have
saved us
from precisely that kind of social
upheaval
if you read
paul krugman's columns in the new york
times
krugman and he's right keeps calling for
another bailout
another stimulus plan to create jobs
instead of the faux jobs bill which was
just passed which turns out in fine
print to be 15 billion dollars in tax
credits for corporations
and and krugman's right
he ended a column a few weeks ago said
i'm terrified i'm terrified
but we're not going to get that money
we're not going to get another chance
we took
12 trillion dollars
and handed it to speculators who are
sitting on it
and
gambling on currency
in the 17th century in europe
speculators were hung
it was a crime
i'm against the death penalty
but hanging until choking
i could embrace
dostoevsky
was obsessed
with the breakdown of liberalism at the
end of the 19th century in tsarist
russia
that's what demons is about it's what
notes from underground is about
notes from underground is probably
philosophically the most important book
for our time
it is about the rational
liberal
defeated dreamer
who went to all of the obama rallies
and chanted yes we can
and then was betrayed
and was angry
and retreated underground
and said well only fools
and idiots and buffoons take power
rational educated people
are discarded
and dostoyevsky knew
that once
the liberal institutions ceased to
function
you entered
in what he called what he called an age
of moral nihilism
which of course eventually opened the
door for lenin and the bolsheviks
was the breakdown of liberalism in
weimar
that vomited up adolf hitler
and it was the breakdown of the centrist
liberal establishment in the former
yugoslavia which i covered for the new
york times
that gave us the repugnant figures of
slobodan milosevic franco tujman
the
failure of the liberal class
has
grave political and social consequences
because
that rage with when it has nowhere else
to go
is expressed
through
mechanisms that make war
on
the traditional liberal establishment
and are easily co-opted as the tea party
is and has been
by the very forces that created the
destruction
and that seek to wipe away the last
remnants
of liberalism
and so the question obviously
is what do we do
what must be done
to quote lenin
um
there's an interview in the book with
daniel berrigan
one of my great heroes
i come out of the
religious left
my father was a presbyterian minister
who sort of had a habit of being thrown
out of one church after another
first for his stances in the civil
rights movement
uh then the anti-war movement and
finally the gay rights movement my uh
uncle his youngest brother was gay
and lived with his partner in greenwich
village my father had a
particular sensitivity to the pain of
being a gay man in america in the 1950s
and 1960s
a stance that was deeply unpopular in
the
presbyterian church in the 1970s and 80s
but
perrigan writes correctly
that
we must hold fast
to moral imperatives to what we can
define as best we can define it as the
good
and stop worrying about where the good
goes
it is our task
to remember
that all of the great correctives to
american democracy never achieved formal
political power ever
the liberty party that fought slavery
the suffrages the labor movement the
civil rights movement
the most powerful
figure
in the united states
in 1968
was dr martin luther king
because he scared the hell out of him
when king went to birmingham 50 000
people went with him
when king got up in april of 1967 at
riverside church and denounced the
vietnam war and called america the
greatest purveyor of violence in the
world
lyndon johnson took away the four
plainclothes fbi agents
that have been assigned to protect king
and both king
and johnson
knew what that meant
there's a beautiful moment
remember king like malcolm
became a pariah at the end every he
would be booed by the black power
movement
ascension within his own ranks
southern christian leadership was
disintegrating as an organization
and king stood up two months before he
was assassinated in front of his staff
and said
i take non-violence to be my lawfully
wedded wife
and sickness in his health
till death do us part
that it
is only by going back and standing for
these moral imperatives that we have any
hope of protecting
what is left
of our anemic
democracy
and we have to stop asking whether it's
practical
or even rational
we have to believe
as these great figures before us
understood that the good attracts the
good
we have to do so with non-violence
because if we do not and if we do not do
it now
then the opposition to this corporate
state and these corporate forces will
embrace the violence of the state itself
and i've been there
i spent 20 years as a war correspondent
i know
the poison of violence
i know what it does
i know as nietzsche said
how it pits our monsters against their
monsters
and it is incumbent upon us to walk away
from these established institutions
even if we're alone
and believe and trust
that holding fast to these moral
imperatives will give our country
another narrative
and reclaim the populism
that was decimated
and it's not going to be easy
especially
as we see the rise
of the lunatic fringe of the republican
party come to power
they will try and use fear
to make us conform
but simple pride
should drive us at this point
not to be used again
by these institutions
and by the democrats
there has to be a breaking point if you
make a moral stance
that's camus the rebel that's the whole
point
there has to be a line that can't be
crossed
and i fear for our country
i fear for where we're going
i covered the breakdown of yugoslavia
and i see all of the same flashing red
lights
the economic crisis
the bankrupt liberalism the way the
airwaves are taken over by idiots who
have one talent and that is to mobilize
hatred
with undercurrents of racism
towards muslims
towards undocumented workers
towards barack obama himself
and
it's in our hands
it's in our hands
defenseless under the night
our world in super lives
yet dotted everywhere
ironic points of light flash out
wherever the just
exchanged their messages
may i
composed like them of eros and of dust
beleaguered by the same negation
and
despair
show an affirming flame
thank you
so we're please wait for the microphone
before you ask a question uh
go ahead
we'll just wait for the microphone
please
thank you very much
really spectacular um nasa's top climate
scientist jim hansen
has uh said that if we burn all
available fossil fuels which we show
every sign of doing
it will create a dead planet like
penis although maybe not quite as hot as
this room now
uh so the powers that be are
dedicated to having us ignore that and
to not address it what can we do to take
appropriate action to save
well
everyone and everything
well i i wrote i wrote a book before
this called empire of illusion the end
of literacy in the triumph of spectacle
which is about the retreat into these
electronic hallucinations
the kind of magical thinking that is fed
to us by the corporate machine that
reality is never an impediment to what
we want
and
of course that's tossed to us by oprah
and the christian right
and self-help gurus in hollywood and
it's magical thinking it's what all the
twilight of all dying civilizations
engage in you can read cicero
complaining about the arena and how the
spectacle in the arena has poisoned
political and civil discourse in the
declining days of ancient rome joseph
roth wrote about it with the collapse of
the austro-hungarian empire
and that's precisely what's happened
because all the evidence is staring us
in the face
not only the evidence of scientific
reports but the physical evidence of the
death rattle of the planet itself
and yet we pretend it's not happening
we believe in the false magic of science
and technology as if somehow these are
neutral forces that will save us
science and technology serves human
ambitions most of which at this point
are military and corporate and that is
why
barack obama the leaders of the
industrialized world and their corporate
puppeteers
in copenhagen allowed kyoto to be
shredded
and you're right if we stopped emitting
fossil fuels today
we would still by many estimates rise to
550 parts per million 350 parts per
million being the level by which we can
sustain life as we know it
and we have to understand that these
forces are not going to protect us
they're not going to save us as things
melt down as naomi klein has pointed out
they will retreat
into enclaves heavily guarded enclaves
where they will have access to security
goods and services that are denied to
the rest of us
which is why all resistance now is local
the more we can do to be self-sustaining
the more freedom and power we have
and that's why uh sustainable energy uh
the food movement are absolutely crucial
and don't be fooled these are soon going
to become expressions of a political uh
ex politicized expressions
i just did a story for the nation
magazine on camden new jersey which per
capita is the poorest city in the united
states and not surprisingly the most
dangerous
and there's no supermarket in the center
of camden
because we've allowed agribusinesses to
create a system i also live in new
jersey where all of our all of my fruits
and vegetables are trucked across
country
and poor people can't afford tomatoes
so we don't sell it to them
and if you want to eat in camden
you have either churches fried chicken
or donut shops
grease
and sugar
food deserts
you can go to cold out areas of west
virginia and it's the same
and these post-industrial pockets
as our society is reconfigured by
corporate forces into a neo-feudalism
will only expand
and it is incumbent upon us to wake up
to understand what these forces are
doing to the environment
and that
corporate capitalism which is distinct
from the penny capitalism that existed
in the farm town where i grew up where
farmers would come in and have a market
and sell their their their vegetables
and their
their fruit
and it's distinct from the regional
capitalism of the small business owner
who has a a factory or or or a hardware
store and lives in the town and sits on
the school board corporate capitalism is
something else it is supranational
that destroys like a parasite the whole
state that allows it to thrive which is
what nafta is
and
now we're watching large-scale factory
closures over the border in mexico
as these industries
move up
move overseas uh into the
the cut rate embrace of china's or
vietnam's totalitarian capitalism
reid there was a good book written by a
berkeley
anthropologist on
on
working conditions in southern china and
he said in sort of classical economic
terms since many of these people don't
even receive their wages they can't
actually be considered as
labor
and the message that is being delivered
to the american working class is you
have to be competitive
you have to be competitive with prison
labor
and so yes you're right
and i
speak at the end of the book about
climate change and how it is twinned
with this
um
magical thinking this divorce from
from reality from fact and of course
courtesy of exxon mobil how many
millions of dollars did they spend to
confuse people
about
uh
the science
of
of climate change
thank you
uh wait for the mic please
go ahead
that's a little scary um thank you so
much for your talk tonight um
i you've written a lot recently about
losing hope and certainly have spoken
quite a bit about that tonight and yet i
understand as as
has been told to me by my veterans for
peace friends that you're planning on
joining the action in december on
december 16th in washington
um the veteran-led action against the uh
current wars that are continuing to
perpetuate themselves i was wondering a
why now
and b
what would you say to people who are on
the fence about whether or not they
might want to join us
uh well i've joined other actions this
is the first time i've agreed along with
daniel ellsberg and medea benjamin and
ray mcgovern and several veterans to go
chain myself to the
fence of the white house
[Applause]
because it's all we have left it's our
bodies
and um
and i think time we don't have much time
left
we
we cannot keep borrowing much longer to
sustain an empire and a level of
consumption that we can't afford
and collapse
especially when it's not expected when
people aren't emotionally
psychologically and intellectually
prepared for it
as i saw with the breakdown economic
breakdown in yugoslavia unleashes very
very frightening movements and the
undercurrent of violence in american
society runs very deep
and so um
i uh i think that it's incumbent upon
all of us
to begin to carry out physical forms of
protest and stop worrying about whether
anyone joins us
um
because
that act of rebellion and i suppose this
exposes my anarchist roots i
you know i distrust power in
any guy's any ideological form i think
that the moral life requires constant
rebellion a constant push against
centers of power
and i i believe that we've certainly
reached a point where in non-violent
form
we must begin to take radical measures
because as yates said we live in a
moment when the best lack of all
conviction
and the worst are full of passionate
intensity
at first glance this looks like a very
impressive turnout i'd like to see you
speaking to 10 000 people tonight or to
70 000 people's which is the number that
came out to hear barack obama when he
gave his campaign speech in portland i'd
like to know if you're seeing an
increase in awareness of the things
you're saying you're talking about the
concepts an increase in interest in in
your speeches around the country and i'd
also like to know who are the leaders
are there any leaders actually in office
or potentially in office
to uh to raise awareness and talk about
these things well there are certainly
good people who've been have elective
office and and uh i think electoral
politics is not going to be on the
national level i think it's pretty clear
it's not going to be a solution to our
problems because even when you get
people who have a conscience people like
conyers or kucinich or bernie sanders
let's look at the health care bill when
it came down to the public option not
one senator or house member voted for it
not one including those people who had
stood up and said they would fight for
it and i think that is indicative of
absolutely how much control the
corporate state has there's a very good
book by probably our greatest living
political philosopher sheldon wolin
called
democracy incorporated and sheldon who
taught at berkeley and later at
princeton uses the word inverted
totalitarianism to describe the
political system we live under
and by that he means that it's not like
classical totalitarian movements where
you have a radical or reactionary force
that seeks to overthrow a decaying
structure and replace it
but you have
a a totalitarianism totalitarianism that
finds its expression in the anonymity of
the corporate state that you have these
forces they purport to pay loyalty or
fealty to the constitution to electoral
politics to the iconography and language
of american patriotism and yet they have
so corrupted the levers of power as to
render the citizenry
uh impotent
and that in inverted totalitarianism
you have a situation where economics
always trumps politics whereas in
classical totalitarianism politics
trumps economics
and wolland said that the way that the
masses are pacified
is through credit because real wages for
90 percent of americans have been on a
steady decline since the early 1970s
and
cheap mass-produced goods
well now the credit is gone
for most people
and
the mass-produced goods
are becoming because of the deprivation
among our permanent underclass
unaffordable
and i spoke to olin
not long ago and i asked him if you take
away those two mechanisms of control
can you see the possibility of inverted
totalitarianism flipping
into a kind of classical totalitarianism
and he agreed that we could we're not
immune from it
we're not immune from these forces
we're no different from
you know the
the germans who were in despair in the
late 1920s or the yukoslavs or anyone
else
uh and unfortunately the systems of mass
propaganda and the resources in the
hands of those who oppose democracy at
this point especially after citizens
united's how they took down russ
feingold for every ad on tv russ
feingold there were five or six ads
trashing the guy and we didn't even know
who paid for them the new york times
just found that 40 percent of the
chamber of commerce budget that 80 about
83 billion dollars
paid for by the pharmaceutical insurance
company and they used the chamber of
commerce as the attack dog
and we never knew until now
in the first two chapters of your book
as you're laying out the different uh
elements of a real powerful
movement that the first world war
destroyed uh the only uh angle of people
of faith that you mentioned was really
the social gospel in the theology of
walter buchenbach but rashan bush or
russia oh sorry
and i wonder if you could um
so something was notably absent was that
the evangelicals that the i think they
call themselves the fundamentals at the
time right such as william jennings
bryant you mentioned he wasn't a
fundamentalist he wasn't evangelical
really there's a difference okay all
right um so i wonder if you can comment
on today uh on on figures such as um
jim wallace uh
uh
cause could we see a return of the uh
fundamentalists of these
social conservatives too i don't want to
quibble over semantics fundamentalists
uh
and evangelicals at that time were at
war with each other because the
fundamentalists who believed in the
strict inerrancy of the bible saw
evangelicals who were charismatic and
thought that there were many ways to
come to christ and spoke in tongues as
satan worshipers there was a huge
division uh so you did have a
progressive evangelical movement uh rash
and bush i'm very critical of russian
bush
because what happened with all of these
progressive movements is they made the
fatal error of trusting in the state
they put all of their faith in the
mechanism of the state
without realizing that social movements
always had to be antagonistic to power
and always had to force power
towards a corrective
karl popper in the open society and its
enemies writes
that
the
we shouldn't ask
how do we get the good people to rule
that's the wrong question that most
people attracted to power are at best
mediocre which is obama or venal which
is push
the question is how do we stop the
powerful from doing as much damage to us
as possible
and
that that you know the there was after
the the self-slaughter of world war one
all of the dreams of human progress
that being achieved through social
movements shattered
there was a great deal of despair and
there was
a book
epistle to the romans written by carl
bart
that
in the aftermath of the war took down
this naive belief that we were going to
create a utopian or a christian society
on earth
and and the liberal church never
recovered from that
i think
my anger towards the liberal church
comes over the issue of the christian
right
i have a problem with wallace by the way
because uh i can you know i i have read
the bible um
as closely as jim wallace has and i can
tell you uh that it is utterly
inconsistent there are whole passages
that are morally repugnant
and
to somehow
deify that book which wallace does
although his politics are good
i just find that kind of thing
intellectually bankrupt and kind of
frightening
there are many ways to achieve the moral
life
every society every religion produces
valiant and great figures including
islam i would add
who rise up on behalf of the oppressed
to fight the oppressor some of those
people embrace religious iconography and
language some do not um
uh and uh there are numerous routes to
i happen to come out of the church but i
hardly believe that that's an exclusive
path to define
authority and i think that the my anger
towards the liberal church is that
they watch the rise of the christian
right
uh which uh let's be clear these people
are not christians they're heretics
they have utterly perverted and deformed
the fundamental message of the christian
gospel jesus did not come to make us
rich
jesus did not come to bless dropping
iron fragmentation bombs all over the
muslim world
and
liberal
ministers
who went to seminary as i did
and studied the christian gospel walked
out the doors of those seminaries saw
these heretics and said nothing
they remained silent
and that's why they have nothing to say
to us now
of course it would be difficult and
painful to challenge these people they
have resources that we don't
but
how can you
closely study the life of jesus christ
who was turned on by the crowd abandoned
by all his friends stripped hung on a
cross with criminals and left to die and
not get it
that is the price
for
the moral life
as martin luther king said in one of his
great sermons
jesus didn't come to bring peace of mind
and
my sadness
over the church
is they forgot the radical message of
the gospel itself
uh and guys i i wrote a book about the
christian right called american fascists
the christian right in the war on
america i was trying to reach out to him
and
look at this as a mass movement a mass
political movement
that
fuses the language of american
nationalism with the
language of the christian religion
and uh
when that happens
you get fascism
with
wrapped in the american flag and
clutching the christian cross
thank you chris um
i spent the last 30 years in the labor
movement trying to put the movement back
in the labor movement and now i was i
came out of the anti-war movement but i
saw the labor movement as the way
to change this country i saw what
happened during the great depression and
you know it wasn't the
the wonderfulness of fdr it was the of
course the sit down strikes the
general strikes and whole cities being
shut down and that's how do we get back
there how do what do you see we have to
stop trusting in bankrupt institutions
and
and we have to you know we have to go
out and look i'm not i've held any war
rallies in lafayette park i don't expect
to go down there and see thousands of
people i'm not going to pretend that
being handcuffed is a very pleasant
experience
but that's the kind of thing we have to
begin to do
and
you know
i've watched in war zones how solitary
acts
of defiance
have an immense power
that ripple outwards
across a society and at the moment are
often seemed futile
1968 in prague
you have a czech student to protest
the occupation who
walks i believe into wenzelos square was
it joe and burns himself to death
hushed up in the state media
nothing said
and yet in the velvet revolution which i
covered
a poster with his face is everywhere
and
i tell this story in my first book war
is a force that gives us meaning
which for me exemplifies the power
of rebellion or defiance
and it is the story of a muslim farmer
fazel footage
i heard this story from a serbian couple
draga and
rosa sorak
they had lived in a safe area called
garagia
that was under intense bombardment and
shelling joe sacco wrote a great book
about it called garageda
and
like many
ethnic serbs they threw their lot in
with the muslim-led government and did
not join the besieging serb forces but
as the surge tightened and the paranoia
arose the muslim police came one night
and took their eldest son zoron away and
in the parliance of the dirty war he was
disappeared he never returned he was
executed
their second son who had been fighting
with the bosnian serbs died in a car
accident they were left childless
zoron's wife was pregnant
and she gave birth to an infant girl
and because there was no food
and because of the stress she was unable
to nurse the child
and the child was dying
they were feeding it weak cups of tea
trying to keep it alive
and after 10 days at dawn there was a
knock on their apartment door
and it was fazel fadich
an illiterate
muslim farmer
and a pair of rubble boots
with a liter of milk
he had three great brown and white milk
cows
that he milked at night to avoid sniper
fire
and he came back
the next morning
and the morning after that
and the morning after that
and the morning after that
for a year
and all
of the muslim neighbors
when they saw that he was giving milk
which was precious was worth a lot of
money
to keep alive a serbian
infant
began to spit on him
and insult him
and revile him
and i heard this story from the soroks
they said we hate the serb we hate the
muslims and yet it is our duty to tell
you that not all muslims are bad
and so of course i went into garage da
and i found fodic
his cows had been slaughtered for the
meat his apartment
block had been bombed into rubble
he was sleeping on a cement floor on
newspapers and by day collecting with
several other older men worm eaten
apples and selling them on a sidewalk
and when i told him i had seen the sorox
he said
in the baby
how is she
now in that act
lies an ocean of hope
he stood up and shamed everyone around
him
to defend protect
and champion the sanctity of all life
that little girl will grow up and she
may never meet that man
but she will know as a serb
that she is alive
because of a muslim farmer
that kind of activity and moments
of extremity
ripples outward with an undeniable power
and i think we have to regain that form
of resistance
uh and it's lonely
and it's hard martin luther king writes
about it
at the end of his
strength to love where he
breaks down in the kitchen
and he thinks he can't go on there's one
more death threat on the phone
and
we have to remove our trust in rotten
institutions that speak
a language which no longer reflects the
ultimate concern of those institutions
and trust finally
in ourselves
and
maybe by the end of your life and my
life
things will be worse
probably they will be worse but that
does not invalidate what we have done
we trust in the good we believe the good
attracts the good
we cannot know where the good knows
but faith is finally believing that it
goes somewhere
chris
having read all your books i uh deeply
respect what you've done tonight and
what you did on k booth this afternoon
and i was so glad i've been trying to
talk to the unitarians about getting you
to town and it kind of fell flat but
here you are
and i just barely found out you were
here thanks
um
i know that you deeply respect noam
chomsky
i wonder if
all in all when he rejected
9 11 as a
false
claim in this country
whether or not you had any question
about his ability to question
you know the corporate fascism that we
live under
i i don't want to get into 9 11. um it's
a little close to home because i covered
al-qaeda for a year um and uh i am
willing to concede that i didn't do the
structural studies that is used to talk
about how the buildings collapses on the
other hand i uh by the end of that year
uh much of my work was retracing every
step muhammad atta took including in
spain the last 10 days when he went and
it is my belief
that 9 11 would not have happened
without atta
that it that it didn't come out the
government was asleep at the switch
which is pretty much defines eight years
of george bush
but that's not i know it's a long and i
have friends who are
as passionate about it as you but it's a
long and difficult argument that i don't
want to descend into here well chris we
have a bill before congress for the last
four years
this young lady next to me and i have
put together a bill with a third party
and we've presented it to 19
congressional offices to get a new
investigation
of 911 because
i wanted to ask you this is really my
question all right let's let's talk
about it afterwards because we have
limited time
very quickly
i don't want to get into the 911 stuff
it's a long and it's long and
complicated and i get it from davidson
laura as a friend of mine and a fervent
and i'm not you know in the end i'm
enough of a reporter not to be an
absolutist
um and i didn't report it
so i mean ultimately i don't know but
okay go ahead
who's next uh
god
okay over here sure let's that's right
okay the right side
oh that's true okay that's right uh
definitely the left side then
i really do enjoy i i haven't read your
other books but i've been enjoying this
one and seeing the the youtube videos of
you and learning about your analysis and
it's very helpful
but i try to share your ideas with my
children and young and young people and
some of your despair
and hopelessness
is hard it's hard for people to to take
and what comes back to me in these
conversations
are people
the kids raising
things about institutions that maybe
don't look like the liberal institutions
that
you and i
are familiar with and that you write
about
but a whole range of of grassroots
local things that are going on today
not out of labor not out of anti-war not
out of poverty
but that that have hope for young people
and they see this as a mechanism
maybe to bring about change with some of
the institutions that we've
embraced over the years are collapsing i
could you talk a little bit i i fully
support i mean i mean i think the
argument is
that uh
i begin the last chapter by quoting the
great anarchist alexander harrison
who tells a bunch of anarchists trying
to overthrow the czar
you think where the doctors
were the disease it's not our job to
save a dying system
it's our job to kill it
and i think that these movements which
are attempting to sever themselves from
the grip of the corporate state or signs
of hope
on the other hand i don't like as a war
correspondent the words pessimism and
optimism
people who had a very pollyannish view
of the world around them in wars did not
live very long there was a very well
known correspondent in sarajevo who
he drove a thin-skinned vehicle which
meant in essence it wasn't armored i had
an armored car
and he painted on the spray painted on
the side of his car
save your bullets i'm immortal and in
the morning he would uh well you gotta
admire this sort of hubris of it uh he
would
drive across the tarmac
uh
the airport which was controlled by the
french who we all referred to as the
fourth warring faction and the war in
bosnia to kiss all yak to buy cigars and
then would smoke them on the way back
well he's a [ __ ] now
i had another friend who somehow
believed he couldn't get hit and he
stood up in the firefight and shot
through the head and killed
look it was our job to coldly assess
reality to determine what weapon systems
were at the end of that road and what
the capacity of those systems were to do
us harm and then to act if we can't
understand the reality around us no
matter how bleak it is we can't even use
the word hope because we're not
responding to the real responding to the
fictional
and of course it's bleak but i didn't
make it up i don't make up clients uh
climate science uh i don't make up the
vinemarization of the american working
class i don't make up the fact that one
in four children in this country depend
on food stamps to eat or that 2.8
million people were driven from their
homes because of foreclosure and bank
repossessions matched again by this year
that's about 8 000 people a day none of
this is made up it's just that the pain
has become because of
a corporatized commercial media largely
invisible to the rest of us it may be
visible on a local level uh but we don't
hear the cries of our own people and so
i'm with i'm with these kids and i think
everything they're doing is important
and great on the other hand
i think we also have to understand
what's about
to befall us and to be prepared i mean
the the secret of surviving in a war
zone is to know how bad it is and how
bad it's going to be and in fact that
makes survival both in a physical sense
and a psychological sense uh far more
uh you're far more able to endure
i was wondering in your bibliography if
there was something in your research
that uh since you're so well-versed that
you found uh profound or awakening to
something that you have not been aware
of
well
you know it's always humbling
to be a reader
and
i found a lot of amazing stuff i mean i
think dwight mcdonald's incredible and i
urge you all to read him
a really great thinker beautiful writer
uh
unrepentant anarchist
thrown out of he was a briefly a
trotskyite but he wouldn't follow the
orthodoxy of the party and trotsky
sent a message to the
trotskyite party in new york and said
everyone has a right to their own
stupidity but comrade mcdonald abuses
the privilege
he was invited up to uh columbia in 1968
uh and everybody was wearing little
mouth buttons and and he goes where are
the black flags where are the anarchists
i really rely a lot on the writers of
the 1950s c wright mills riceman
jane jacobs
because i think and i and they resonate
with me with a tremendous power there's
a beautiful book by the way by malcolm
cowley called uh exiles return which is
an intellectual history of the bohemian
movement after world war one it's
brilliant a brilliant and kind of syrian
analysis
of how the bohemians the beats and
ultimately the new left essentially
embraced the corporate values of
hedonism and consumption it's really
stunning book again beautifully written
um so
uh yeah there are a lot of books
that
uh
you know are when you begin and when you
write a book you read around a book that
are very very humbling um and they're
out there uh
uh but i think that that 50th generation
is important to me because
they still remember
what was destroyed
they remember what was dismantled and
when you sit down with a figure like
reisman the lonely crowd or or the power
elite mills what's stunning is not it's
not only how prescient their analysis is
but
but how they knew the consequences of
where it's just almost eerie
that they saw what that disintegration
would bring
um so are those those last great public
intellectuals who actually wrote to be
read unlike most academics i'm not sure
who they write for but certainly it's
not to be read
but people who sought to communicate and
understood that lucid clear language
is a form of lucid clear thought
go ahead
yeah i'd like to uh quote a definition
of a liberal that i saw on a bathroom
wall in wisconsin in 1970
a liberal is someone who listens to both
sides of the argument and then cuts the
baby in half
anyway
my question is i'm glad to see the
regular use of the a as an anarchist
word
um and i was wondering it has has
something changed in your thinking
because you you generally seem
uncritical of
the authoritarian currents within
certainly uh the religious left
and and generally uh sort of a critique
of authority does not
other than of you know right authority
oh i'm very critical of the
institutional church i mean if i wrote a
book i went no but but you're you're you
know i mean
berrigan by anybody who had any contact
with him was was a maniacal
authoritarian the real problems with the
authoritarianism of the black church i
think this is an argument some people
have made well you know the great
anarchist the great theologian paul
tillich wrote that all institutions
including the christian church are
inherently demonic
and i'll buy that
i
i was the only
member of the reporting staff of the new
york times to have a seminary degree so
they kept trying to recruit me to cover
religion
uh well you can imagine how that went
over having watched 40 years of the
church persecute my dad
and i kept telling them i'm the last
person that you want
to like go to a convention of southern
baptists
i've got so much emotional baggage that
i carry into the room
[Music]
so
i do make a huge division between
fealty or loyalty to religious values
and
religious institutions which
like all institutions serve human power
and i think that you know julian bendo's
great
work in the 1920s treason of the
intellectuals talks about that in order
to maintain not only intellectual
independence but intellectual honesty
one must be perpetually
uh alienated from all
forms of institutional power and i do
differentiate between institutions and
movements
that movements have
when they're right specific goals
they're hardly free from the kind of
antagonisms jealousies backstabbing and
reid garrow's biography of king if you
want to know what
king went through
but but movements are different in that
they they don't seek to perpetuate
themselves reinhold never writes about
how
institutions can never achieve the
morality of individuals because under
pressure
institutions always retreat into
mechanisms which ensure their own
survival and you see that with the press
i think part of the failure of
the the dwindling
uh
print-based media
is that
uh uh as advertising revenues decline as
circulation declines as this uh monopoly
that once newsprint had of connecting
sellers with buyers vanishes
they become even more craven in their
service to the power elite so the new
york times is running story after story
about lifestyle stories about you know
the house in the hamptons or the forty
thousand dollar kindergarten well it's
not your lifestyle it's not mine but it
is the lifestyle the person they want to
reach
and who their advertisers want to reach
um and i think it's a good example how
dying institutions
um
very swiftly walk away from the very
principles uh that one once made them
important in the society and the
churches certainly no exception
um
john nichols is recently talking about
voter turnout and he made the statement
that if
we came above more than say 55 or 58
voter turnout we would have a more
socially democratic country do you
believe that if we could
get what is essentially the underclass
or the lower class to actually turn out
and vote that our political institutions
could become
more of the public will
no
um
look at 2006 the democrats retook
control of congress based on the issue
of the iraq war
and what did they do they continued to
fund the war and increased troop levels
by 30
million
uh 30 000 in iraq
the
in issue after issue after issue all of
the promises that are made
are utterly repealed
once they get to washington which is run
by corporate lobbyists i don't think i
think until we have serious campaign
finance reform until corporations are
not allowed to game the system i mean
what is the what do 45 000 lobbyists do
in washington aside from right our
legislation well they grease the palms
there's a word for it it's called
corruption
uh and the the system is so far gone
that we can't depend on the system to
reform itself
it's a kind of
tautology um you know why do you become
the head of the banking committee
because you want the money
from the banking committee it works
um the whole system is so rotten
that i think that
to place faith in electoral politics is
extremely naive
i'd like to hear your take on wikileaks
and our government's war on uh sanjay
well thank god for
wikileaks he's done us a great service
and uh shamed
the american press into actually
practicing a little journalism
so
i'm all for him
okay we i guess we can move
okay go ahead we'll do the back
hi um
in the last part of your book you talk
about the importance of
movements as a mechanism protect
democracy
and 11 years ago today actually
a convergence of social movements in the
united states led by youth primarily
shut down the
wto ministerial in seattle
and
anybody remember that one
out of that
came a social forum movement in the
united states
that formed itself and after katrina
organized itself for a social forum in
atlanta and 07 where 10 000 activists
many of which i would say probably have
anarchist tendencies but certainly food
tendencies
were there
discussing
significant events and how to deal with
neoliberalism
they did that again in detroit just
recently in july where something like
eleven thousand activists registered
from all across the country
so i'm kind of hopeful in that you would
address those types of social movements
in your
uh discussions because i
i'm i knew dan berrigan i'm not dan
berrigan most people are not dan
berrigans we have to fight within groups
and social movements
and i know you know that i just didn't
see it addressed in your book
i think it's a good point i mean i think
it's
probably a fair criticism um
i don't i don't know that there's one
route to fight back
um
i my personal constitution is one that
doesn't make me particularly amenable to
groups
uh
i covered the first gulf war
in which i defied all of the pool
restrictions went out
spent most the time of the marine corps
the public relations campaign the pool
system was run by the army and the
marine corps and their infinite wisdom
understood that this was just one more
conspiracy by the army against the
marine corps
so
let me into first battalion first
marines and i shaved off all my hair and
had a uniform and
never used my press credentials
until uh dick cheney who was secretary
of defense sent a list of 14
journalists that he wanted expelled
before the invasion of kuwait of which i
was a prominent member but unfortunately
for them they couldn't find me
the end of the war rw apple
johnny apple said look i just have one
question for you he said what is it
about you and authority and i said
johnny i don't have any problem with
authority
as long as they don't try and tell me
what to do
he said you dumb f
that's what authority does
so i think that i think
i think that there are many ways
to
resist
i think movements are really important
but as you know from coming out of
movements
they require a lot of emotional
maintenance
that's you know we're all limited in
terms of what we can do
and my focus is as a writer which
ultimately is a solitary
form of protest
and so we need the berrigans
uh and we
need uh
the activists who show up at the g20
we need both we need everything and i
think it's incumbent upon all of us to
search within our own conscious
our own consciousness for for how we
respond but i'm with you and um and i
think that um
you know i think you pointed out
probably a fair failing at the end of
the book that i probably should have
focused a little more on that thank you
where's the mic i guess over there over
there
yeah
well wait for the mic wait for the mic
indeed
um ralph nader said that uh he thinks
now the way things have gone with the
rich owning the the media message that
our only salvation is a good guy that's
rich
and so my question is
do you know any really good rich guys
like ted
like teddy roosevelt or fdr oh teddy
roosevelt's awful um
well uh
well i love ralph and i actually slogged
my way through the book um and i but i
did ask him when in human history the
oligarchic class had ever stepped in to
save anyone
and he sort of mumbled something about
fighting robber barons or something uh
and then he said something that sort of
broke my heart
he said look
it's all we have left
and and and ralph who
has a kind of eternal optimism maybe
that i don't share
um
uh
i think was really seriously trying to
appeal to enlightened figures of the
oligarchy class which is why he names
them although i can't figure out why
yoko ono was in there
but i
it's not worked
um the rich take care of the rich
um and boy human history has borne that
out so
i would break as i'm a huge admirer and
friend of ralph but i would break with
him on that one yeah i don't think i
don't think the super rich are to save
us
okay right over here with a red hat
purple
so thank you for coming i heard you on
the radio this morning
first time i've listened to kpop in a
long time
i have a question regarding to the fact
that every time i spend money we're
voting to keep those things in business
right yeah
and christmas is right around the corner
so in my thought i'm 23
a lot of family i could buy presents for
and if we're spending money which is
obviously like supporting these big
businesses
which support like
the propaganda and the media and support
all of these things that keep us down as
you know the lower class people
why is it this group like what can we do
especially like us young people
how are we supposed to like
overturn this is it just like giving up
on like
spending money i mean is that an answer
or spending money on what we i always
tell my students when they get out of
school i said don't get in debt i mean a
lot of them already have tremendous debt
because
in this country can you imagine in
france if they told
university students they'd have to pay
fifty thousand dollars a year to go to
college
it'd shut the damn country down
um what are we doing i mean people from
your generation are graduating and
that's what they want you know
college until i was 24 i was like well
i'll go to college when i'm 24 because
then i'm not on my taxes then i thought
well ultimately like i have a luxury i
can read and that is something that the
majority of the world's women can't do
and if we can self-educate then we
should be educating the people around us
because
obviously like-minded people create the
most social changes
have you read wendell berry who wendell
berry
berry after you buy my book
wendell berry is one of the great
prophets
oh
and
he he's an amazing figure and he writes
on precisely this issue
um we have to learn to live with a new
simplicity
70 of the american economy is driven by
profligate and wasteful consumption
uh and
um and you're right we have to the the
more we can sever ourselves from that
consumer society the freer we become
uh and i recommend barry to you he's a
great great writer
i think we should all talk to each other
more none of us that like here we should
be spreading the news and let people
know
that we're here because like-minded
people stick together change things all
right
thanks
this event was hosted by powell's books
in portland oregon to find out more
visit powells.com
the survival of the jewish state jeremy
benami founder of j street is the author
the next three hours is your chance to
talk with author and journalist chris
hedges the pulitzer prize-winning
foreign correspondent will take your
calls emails and tweets on topics such
as war religion and politics
chris hedges holds a masters in divinity
and is the author of nine books
including war is a force that gives us
meaning
losing moses on the freeway and his
latest the world as it is
chris hedges in your most recent book
the world as it is dispatches on the
myth on on human pro of human progress
you write brace yourself the american
empire is over and the descent is going
to be horrifying
how did you come to that conclusion
well first of all i spent 20 years on
the outer reaches of empire as a foreign
correspondent so i've seen an aspect of
empire that most people have not unless
you're in the military or perhaps the
foreign service
and i think all of the red
signs the the sort of red warning signs
are there i think also the fact that i
spent so long outside the united states
gave me a kind of perspective when i
returned
i understood how radically the country
had changed in the two decades that i
was away i think for those who had
remained
in within the borders of the united
states those changes had been more
incremental and perhaps less perceptible
what are some of the symptoms the signs
that the american empire is the biggest
sign is
uh the fact that we are following the
trajectory of all
empires which is that they expand beyond
their capacity to sustain themselves
we have run up the largest deficits in
human history which in the bottom line
is we can't repay it
we have done so at the cost of our
infrastructure our public education our
working class we're hollowing the
country out from the inside and the
physical evidence is all around us
plunging roughly one third of americans
into poverty or near poverty according
to the latest
statistics
our bridges our roads are collapsing
libraries are being closed fire stations
are being closed these are the signs of
a nation
or let's call it an empire
that
is reaching a kind of a terminal point
and
and if we don't radically
recharge our course
then the collapse is going to be very
frightening and very chaotic
in empire of illusion which you wrote
and published in 2009 you write
those captive to images cast ballots
based on how candidates make them feel
they vote for a slogan a smile perceives
sincerity and attractiveness along with
the carefully crafted personal narrative
of the candidate it is style and story
not content in fact that inform mass
politics
precisely and
the uh
structure of the corporate state
as well as
the imperial state remains untouched
it doesn't really matter which political
party holds office uh the policies of
george w bush have been assiduously
carried out uh for the large part by
barack obama and even figures like dick
cheney have confirmed this whether it is
the so-called war on terror the refusal
to restore habeas corpus
the eavesdropping wiretapping and
monitoring of tens of millions of
americans which under our constitution
should be illegal passed for the fisa
reform act which barack obama supported
whether it is the looting of the u.s
treasury on behalf of wall street
all of these are policies which are
bipartisan
and that is because we have undergone i
think in the last few decades a kind of
slow motion coup d'etat a corporate coup
d'etat whereby the citizen is rendered
impotent and it is solely the interests
of corporations uh which are paramount
uh within the circles of the power elite
i mean one could take many examples but
obamacare would be a good one uh i share
the right wings critique of obamacare
it's a disastrous bill
it was written by corporate lobbyists 2
000 pages of it
it is essentially the equivalent of the
bank bailout bill for the pharmaceutical
and insurance industry 400 billion
dollars in subsidies meanwhile uh the
white house handed out exemptions
uh because these corporations do not
want to ensure uh chronically ill
children i mean think of it in moral
terms it really means that we live in a
country where it is now legally
permissible for corporations
for-profit corporations to hold sick
children hostage while their parents
frantically bankrupt themselves trying
to save their sons or daughters this is
the kind of world the corporate state
creates
and uh and the democrats
and the republicans are both handmaidens
of corporate interests which is why
congress has such a low approval rating
i mean the american public's not fooled
by this in 2010 death of the liberal
class came out
here's a quote the election of obama was
one more triumph of illusion over
substance it was a skillful manipulation
and betrayal of the public by a
corporate power elite we mistook style
and ethnicity an advertising tactic
pioneered by calvin klein and benetton
for progressive politics and genuine
change
sure obama functioned as a brand now
remember 2008 the financial collapse
wall street was terrified uh they
thought they'd been found out
they thought they would have to pay a
price for their criminal activity
fraudulent activity in malfeasance
and obama functioned as as a brand in
the same way that people of color or hiv
positive models were used by bennetton
and calvin klein to associate their
products with a risque lifestyle and
progressive politics
but as with a function of all brands we
confused a brand with an experience
obama won advertising ages top annual
award marketer of the year
because the professionals knew precisely
what he had done he beat nike apple
zappos uh and that's what he was he uh
you know to quote cornell west became
essentially a black mascot for wall
street
one of the themes in a lot of your books
is criticism of liberals why
because the liberal class was never
meant to function as the political left
the liberal class was meant to function
as the political center
and i spent a lot of time in death of
the liberal class going back to the
radical and populist movements
at the turn of the century which were
very powerful uh
anarcho-syndicalist unions like the
wobblies the old cio eugene debs the
socialist candidate for president
uh pulled almost six percent of the vote
900 000 votes in 1912. uh
publications like appeal to reason and
the masses which were socialist
publications had wide circulations
appeal to reason was the fourth
most widely read
periodical in the country at the time
before the war
and
we had about two or three dozen
socialist mayors well what happened was
the war itself uh and wilson had run for
re-election in 1912 on the slogan he
kept us out of the war but with the
collapse of uh the eastern front uh with
zara's russia the collapse of tsarist
russia and the bolshevik revolution
there was the capacity of the germans to
send i think upwards of a hundred
divisions to the western front and the
bankers on wall street who had lent
tremendous sums of money to the british
and the french were terrified that that
uh if they lost if the british and
french lost the war they'd lose their
money
so there was heavy pressure on the white
house aided by the kaiser's decision to
begin to try and create a naval blockade
around britain which sank three or four
american ships uh to go into the war but
it had no popular support and we created
and i write spent a lot of time writing
about this in depth of liberal class
the first
system of modern mass propaganda the
committee for public information known
as popularly as the creel commission
because it was headed by a figure named
george creel
now the committee for public information
and the sort of uh you know dark figure
the the grand inquisitor type figure
becomes walter littman who ends up
writing a public opinion in 1922 sort of
the blueprint for control manufacturing
consent is his phrase and it's how you
use propaganda effectively uh to
manufacture consent and you don't
actually need the harsher measures of
the espionage act and sedition act
except for the most recalcitrant forces
or radical forces randolph-born jane
adams debs himself ends up going to
prison uh but propaganda becomes uh
in the in in the right hands in the
hands of the state uh a much more
effective tool
to herd people where you want them and
the most important thing about the
committee for public information is that
it drew on the understanding of crowd
psychology or mass psychology pioneered
by figures like le bon trotter and of
course sigmund freud that people were
not moved uh by fact or reason but
manipulated by emotion and uh
and this
system of mass propaganda uh which
created a kind of uh permanent fear
of of of course the hun
was transferred the moment the war was
over to the dreaded red and there's a
great writer i like very much dwight
mcdonald who writes of this period and
he said essentially the war world war
one was the rock on which these
movements broke now this is absolutely
vital to understanding what happened to
american democracy because these
movements never took formal political
power and yet they were the true
correctives to
the in in terms of opening up our
democracy the liberty party that fought
slavery the suffragists the labor
movement later the civil rights movement
uh these were movements uh that
pressured
the liberal class to respond we saw
perhaps the best example of it during
the great depression where you had
figures like roosevelt and his vice
president henry wallace and uh these
were
liberals who responded to the plight of
the underclass and make made incremental
and piecemeal reform possible that's
what the liberal class is supposed to do
uh when it works and conrad black when
he writes his biography of roosevelt
said that roosevelt's greatest
achievement was that he saved capitalism
and black was right and what we've seen
with the destruction of those radical
and populist movements in the name of
the red scare in the 50s remember with
the mccarthy hearings we saw thousands
of university professors social workers
journalists
essentially purged
from their positions i have stone
probably our greatest investigative
journalist becomes a non-person he can't
even get a job at the nation magazine
and
uh and that was disastrous because we
lost the pressure on the liberal
establishment and then in the name of of
of uh sort of the battle against
anti-communism we hollowed these liberal
institutions out from the inside so that
by the 1970s let's say there was no
longer any bulwark to protect us
from
the corporate state and we were
transferred i think correctly in the
words of the harvard historian charles
mayer uh by the early 1970s
from
from an empire what he calls a
production to an empire of consumption
we began to borrow
to maintain both a lifestyle and a level
of consumption as well as an empire we
could no longer afford and and that the
impediments to that which had been in
place were essentially removed and you
end up with what i would say are faux
liberals people who speak the language
of traditional liberalism like bill
clinton and yet serve the interests of
the corporate state so it's under a
democratic
administration under clinton that we get
some of the most egregious assaults
against the working class in this
country nafta
the greatest betrayal of working men and
women in this country since the
taft-hartley act of 1948
the destruction of welfare
i mean one of the reasons they keep
extending unemployment benefits is
because courtesy of bill clinton once
those unemployment benefits run out and
you do not have a job you have to
attempt to live on about 143 a month
courtesy of the welfare system the
deregulation of the fcc so that you have
rupert murdoch's news corp and clear
channel buying up literally thousands of
stations radio and television stations
consolidating it into
one entity the destruction of the
banking system canada doesn't have a
banking crisis we have about a hundred
bank closures a year but canada has none
because it didn't tear down that
firewall put in place the 1930 in the
united states by the 1933 glass-steagall
act it didn't tear down the firewall
between commercial and investment banks
in short it didn't allow gamblers or
hedge funds to take over the banking
system this was all done under clinton
and obama comes in and essentially
codifies
the destruction of both domestic and
international law put in place by the
bush administration so that uh
he doesn't restore basic civil liberties
uh
in fact he carries out a a further
egregious assault against them the
capacity of the executive branch to
order the assassination of american
citizens this new military detention act
where whereby people can be uh picked up
if they are deemed in the nebulous term
a terrorist
and denied due process and held in
military briggs uh so uh i i think that
uh understanding the uh
the structures
and the foundations of power and how
they work is extremely important and
some great political philosophers like
sheldon wolin uh probably our greatest
living political philosopher
in his book democracy incorporated
sort of spelled it out and he calls it
the system we live under inverted
totalitarianism
by which he means that it's not
classical totalitarianism it doesn't
find its expression through a demagogue
or a charismatic leader but through the
anonymity of the corporate state that in
inverted totalitarianism you have a
system by which corporate forces purport
to pay loyalty to the constitution
electoral politics the iconography and
language of american patriotism and yet
have so corrupted the levers of power as
to render the citizenry
powerless
chris hedges back to your book death of
the liberal class you write that the
creed of impartiality and objectivity
that has infected the liberal class
teaches ultimately the importance of not
offending the status quo the
professionalism demanded in the
classroom in newsprint in the arts or in
political discourse is code for moral
disengagement
of course because what you end up doing
is paying deference to institutions
like goldman sachs
uh which are criminal enterprises you
pay deference to uh power centers that
have long ago walked away from
responsible citizenship
whether it's coal companies uh in
appalachia
or whether it's chemical plants that are
polluting rivers or whether it's wall
street and i think that inability to
make those moral judgments has rendered
the liberal class not only useless
but despised by large segments of
american society and i think frankly
they have every right to be despised uh
because they posit themselves as sort of
the moral voice the conscience
of the nation uh and yet i think it
failed miserably and my book death of
the liberal class is really an attack on
the pillars of the liberal establishment
the liberal church which i come out of
i'm a seminary graduate my father was a
minister grew up in the church
the press and i also come out of it 15
years at the new york times over 20 as a
journalist
labor unions which of course have
withered and now we're seeing a final
assault against public sector unions the
last sort of readout of unionized
activity in the united states culture
which has become commercialized junk
largely and education itself which has
uh become
increasingly geared towards
keeping people within their economic
strata and giving them the vocational
skills to serve the interests of the
corporate state
chris hedges back to your most recent
book the world as it is first of all how
is that book organized
uh it's organized around these are
essays i write a weekly column for bob
shearer's great website bob shearer used
to be the editor of ramparts and
he's a great admirer of his work and a
great friend
anyway he runs this
website truthdig
and i write a weekly column so these are
over the last five years some of the
columns that i've written and it's built
around uh
issues of the middle east i was the
middle east bureau chief
for the new york times i spent seven
years in the middle east it's a region i
know
uh intimately well and most of that time
i'm an arabic speaker in the arab world
or in the occupied territories so i have
a particular sensitivity to the pain
particularly i think of palestinians but
also i think for many within the muslim
world and i speak out i have spoken out
quite strongly on their behalf
it's built around empire
and
these are sort of the themes that i hit
within my books but also tend to hit in
my weekly columns
in the last column in the book they kill
alex it's called who is carlos arredondo
he's the father of a young marine
who was killed in iraq
and uh it's the story of the pain of
that family and the loss of that son and
and i'm very sad to report that just a
few days ago
alex's brother who was also a veteran
committed suicide
what did
the father do after he found out his son
was killed
he
went to the van where the
two marine officers
had driven to his house to
inform him about the death of his son
with a can of gasoline and lit it on
fire
in 2005 chris hedges you wrote the book
losing moses on the freeway the ten
commandments in america who are or were
patrick and tyrone
patrick and tyrone i
when i graduated from college at colgate
university i moved into
or across the street from a housing
project in boston in roxbury the mission
main and mission extension housing
project which at the time was one of the
specs since been raised and rebuilt but
at the time was one of the most
dangerous spots in the city a 60 percent
vacancy rate
the street i ran a small church there as
a seminary and i was attending harvard
divinity school
but commuting into
cambridge to go to classes and
the street
in back of my house gore had the highest
homicide rate at that time in the city
of boston patrick and tyrone were two
kids
they were heroin addicts
and
i always say that my two and a half
years in roxbury is when i learn to hate
liberals
because i was commuting into harvard
where everybody wanted to
you know empower people they'd never met
they liked the poor but they didn't like
the smell of the poor
and the
matching the rhetoric of this this
classic sort of liberal
christianity with the reality on the
streets of roxbury was a huge wake-up
call for me
um
and i was at the time
a member of the greater boston ymca
boxing team
we used to go down to charlestown and
fight for 25 a fight on saturday nights
and i i physically threw them off my
street
they were
pushing heroin on kids on the street i
actually caught them raping a 14 year
old girl
and beat them up
and i don't say any of this with any
kind of pride
it was a deeply troubling
time for me
and i used all of the mechanisms of
authority which in many ways i had moved
to roxbury to defy to make their lives
miserable i went to their they were
skipping schools so i went to the truant
officers they had
you know they had uh petty crime uh had
committed petty crime i went to
probation officers i went to the police
they lived for a while in an abandoned
house and i would
uh take out the fuses because they had
you know rewired the fuse box
uh and then eventually at the end they
broke into my house
and were waiting for me with lead pipes
and the reason they were unable to
attack me is because another boy that i
had been
close to and tutoring he and uh one of
the guys i lived with have been tutoring
and math
um
uh stanley found them i saw the back
window of my house broke and mance and
climbed in
and uh informed me but it was it was
really uh um
earth-shattering
period for me because i realized in some
sense and i write that in the book that
i was the enemy that when i was fearful
and cornered i reached out to the very
levers of control
that these people could never reach out
to that i had that ability
to make the system work on my behalf
because i was white and i came from
privilege and i was educated in a way
that they didn't
and and i think that that was a really
important lesson for me in terms of uh
of of you know white supremacy and white
privilege and what it means and and i i
kind of bear it as a mark of cain and
yet i did it
while evangelicals often champion a
gospel of greed and personal empowerment
liberals often speak on behalf of
oppressed groups they never meet
advocating utopian and unrealistic
schemes to bring about peace and
universal love
neither group has much interest in
testing their ideologies against reality
why did you leave roxbury and the
seminar
um
well i went into seminary to be an
ordained minister and i became
increasingly disenchanted
with both
liberal institutions like harvard
divinity school as well as the liberal
presbyterian church which i came out of
that i felt that they paid lip service
to the poor
as well as lip service to values that in
fact they were not willing to fight for
and so it was a rupture with the
institutional church which was
particularly painful because i had been
raised within the institutional church
not only was my father a parish minister
for all of his life
but my mother as well was a seminary
graduate although went on to become a
professor so
you know it was a really difficult time
this was an institution that had
nurtured me
i think i still
speak
uh and think in the way that it taught
me uh that is sort of ethically and
finally perhaps even religiously these
are not values i've necessarily
discarded
but i
had at that point a huge
uh
schism with the institution itself and
i'd always written i i had been editing
my high school paper and all that kind
of stuff and had published in the
christian science monitor when i was in
college and uh very uh interested in
what was happening in latin america at
the time
these were military dictatorships
pinochet and chile the dirty war in
argentina
the death squads in el salvador this
kind of stuff
and my second year in divinity school
developed a friendship with a great uh
journalist robert cox who had been
editor of the buenos aires herald and uh
bob
was an amazing man he uh at the height
of the dirty war
would publish the names of the people
who had been disappeared the night
before on the front page
until he himself was disappeared and
he's only was only saved because he was
a british citizen later united anyway he
was at harvard and um and that was for
me a huge window uh into
i think what journalism that had a kind
of moral center could be
uh
bob's uh great sort of intellectual
mentor was orwell and uh so i i left
divinity school i would go back and
finish but i left to go to latin america
studied spanish with the marinol fathers
in uh coach obama bolivia and when i
left i took on bob's advice the uh
collected letters essays and journalism
that four volume set by orwell that i
carried with me through that whole year
and read and re-read and underlined into
this day i think for anyone who cares
about writing and cares about journalism
as a kind of secular bible
in that book moses you write about your
last night in roxbury throwing a bottle
at the church where you had served and
then driving off are you still a
christian are you a christian um
it depends on whose definition
uh you know the london review of books
reviewed a book i wrote where i you know
i've been battling these new atheists
the late christopher hitchens and sam
harris and dawkins and others
and their judgment was that i was a
non-believer i would call myself
certainly a non-traditional believer but
in the end still a believer
in
the core message of the gospel in the
beatitudes i mean i find
one of my frustrations with
some of the right wing evangelicals is
uh this emphasis on law which is uh a
hubria concept i mean the new the the
ten commandments were not uh their
product of moses uh let's put the
beatitudes up uh in courtrooms i'm all
for that uh and i think that that there
was a transformation in terms of uh the
the theological outlook
of the christian gospel as opposed to
what it went before and it's a
theological outlook that i embrace and
admire and seek to live by
but in terms of polity in terms of a
particular denomination whether they
would consider me a good christian
probably suspect most of them probably
would not
good afternoon happy new year and
welcome to book tv's in depth program
this is our monthly program with one
author looking at his or her body of
work and this new year's day 2012 author
journalist and columnist pulitzer prize
winner chris hedges is our guest for the
next two and a half hours we're going to
put the numbers up on the screen if
you'd like to participate 202 is the
area code
737-001 for those of you who live in the
east and central time zones
202-737-002 for those of you in the
mountain and pacific time zones and you
can email mr hedges at book tv at
cspan.org or send a tweet at booktv is
our handle twitter.com
booktv and we'll get to those calls in
just a minute mr hedges has been writing
non-fiction now for about 10 years he
began with his national book critic
circle award
finalist book war is a force that gives
us meaning which came out in 2002 what
every person should know about war in
2003
losing moses on the freeway 2005
american fascists 2006 and then in 2008
a book came out it was originally called
i don't believe in atheists it is now
called when atheism becomes religion
that's in 2008 collateral damage also in
2008 empire of illusion a bestseller
came out in 2009 death of the liberal
class was also a bestseller 2010 and his
most recent
compilation of his columns from truthdig
came out last year the world as it is
american fascists and i don't believe in
atheists or when atheism becomes
religion where did those books come from
i think from the same place actually
my
frustration part of my frustration with
the liberal church is that they didn't
call out the proponents of the gospel of
prosperity
the idea that jesus came to make us
wealthy
the idea that jesus who was a pacifist
would bless the dropping of iron
fragmentation bombs all over the middle
east is heretical
and uh and the liberal church
equivocated uh in the name of dialogue
in the name of tolerance word by the way
martin luther king never used
and
and and my
i think my anger had and what had been
done to a religious belief system that i
admired uh and that i think is worthy of
emulation
uh the infusion of the worst aspects of
american consumerism
and imperialism into the christian
religion
and the failure on the part of the
liberal church to denounce it
and that doesn't mean i'm not against
evangelicals i in fact write in the book
that the real opposition to the gospel
of prosperity and this rapacious right
wing that is seized an element of the
christian church will not come from the
liberal church but will come out of the
evangelical movement i believe
and so
my frustration
over what had been done and then the
same kind of cheap
uh characterization of christianity that
was done by
the new atheists
uh you know they attack a form of
uh or a caricature of religion that i
also detest
uh but they can only attack that
caricature and i've debated
uh both members of the christian right
and of course uh christopher hitchens
in berkeley and uh sam harris at ucla
and
they can't hear what i'm saying
they can only attack their caricature of
who i am and that's what the christian
right does as well so if i am debating
the christian right as i have
then i am a proponent of godless
secularism if i am debating a new
atheist then i believe in magic and
angels and miracles uh which i don't um
and
uh
and i think that fundamentalism can come
in secular form it can come through the
language of scientific rationalism uh
the the political agenda of figures such
as uh hitchens or harris is really no
different from the christian right uh
because uh they elevate western
civilization so they are attacking the
muslim hordes because they're barbaric
whereas by the christian right they're
sort of forces of satan but the result
is the same and what it really is at its
core is a form of self-exaltation in
both cases it is about elevating me
above everyone else morally spiritually
intellectually and abrogating the right
to impose what i define as a virtue by
force uh on those who are different and
both the new atheists do it and the
christian right does it and
when atheism becomes religion came out
in 2008 it came out after uh public
debates with sam harris and the late
christopher hitchens
mr hedges writes
about the atheists they see only one
truth their truth
human beings must become like them think
like them and adopt their values which
they insist are universal or be banished
from civilized society all other values
which they never investigate or examine
are dismissed
when were you with the new york times
1990 to 2005 and why did you leave
well we had a little dispute over
something called the iraq war
uh and uh i'd spent a lot of my life not
only of course in the middle east but in
iraq
i understood like most erebus
that
the uh arguments used to justify the
invasion occupation of iraq were
non-reality based they weren't i'm not
this is not a political discussion it's
uh the idea that we would be greeted as
liberators and there wouldn't be an
insurgency that democracy would be
implanted in baghdad and emanate
outwards across the middle east
that remember the oil would pay for the
reconstruction i mean these were just
spun by people who had no idea what they
were talking about
and but to get up and say that despite
the wealth of experience that i had
within the region and within iraq itself
became deeply polarizing and i gave a
commencement address i i that i'd been
saying it but you know it came to a sort
of a head when i gave a commencement
address at rockford college where i was
booed off of the stage had my microphone
cut
people stood up and started shouting
things against me at one point they
stood up and said god bless america and
i was actually escorted off of the
uh platform before the awarding of
diploma since they didn't want any sort
of fracas uh by
close contact with students um
and uh and this got picked up by fox and
the sort of trash talk media uh which
looped it you know hour after hour and
the new york times responded by giving
me a formal written reprimand now we're
guild at the times which means we're
unionized and the process is you give
the employee a written reprimand
and then the next time they're fired so
i i faced a difficult choice which is
that i would have to
uh in essence muzzle myself in service
of my career
uh but you know on a fundamental level i
was very close to my dad who was a great
minister and an activist in the civil
rights movement the anti-war movement
the gay rights movement his brother was
gay and he was very outspoken in support
of gay rights you know i realized at
that point that to do so would be to
betray my father and i wasn't going to
do that and so i left the paper
and the world as it is mr hedges writes
i have never sought to be objective how
can you be objective about death squads
and el salvador massacres in iraq or
serbian sniper fire that gunned down
unarmed civilians including children in
sarajevo how can you be neutral about
the masters and profiteers of war who
lie and dissemble to hide the crimes
they commit and the prophets they make
that's from his most recent book the
world as it is and now it's your turn
david in hobe sound florida
you're on with chris hedges please go
ahead thank you and good afternoon uh to
both of you uh
you know
you spoke of your admiration for dwight
mcdonald
the only thing with which i agree with
leon trotsky out about is when he said
that everybody has the right to be
stupid but comrade mcdonald abuses the
privilege well uh you i'm glad that
you're on so that america can see who
writes for the new york times but
get to the question i was i called to
ask you said in while you were making
speeches for one of your books that
if we went to war with iraq you would
not pay your taxes where do you get all
that it was iran it was iran not iraq
i said that if we went to war with iran
i wrote an article for the nation
magazine that said i would not pay our
taxes my taxes that's correct
and what about his point about liberal
journalists
writing for the new york times i don't
think the new york times at this point
can be considered a liberal newspaper
remember that it was one of the chief
propagandists or cheerleaders for the
war in iraq uh
it uh and and had to write sort of a mia
culpa afterwards
uh it completely missed the looming
financial meltdown because instead of
walking into poor neighborhoods where
families were being given subprime
mortgages that bankers and
and mortgage brokers knew they could
never repay and then of course these
things were fraudulently diced up and
sold as assets
uh they were running down and doing
lunch with robert rubin um uh the new
york times
uh
you know in the words of sydney
schanberg who
also had a break with them when he tried
to take on real estate developers or
friends of the publisher
papers like that are important in the
sense that they stop things from getting
worse schanberg says and i think that's
right
but this says
it sets very narrow parameters by which
it operates and the closer you get to
the centers of power the less
established media institutions like the
new york times will take those centers
on the further you get from the centers
of power i.e within the outer reaches of
empire the more latitude you have which
is why i spent most of my career very
far away from washington
next call for chris hedges comes from
lakeside california mike
you're on book tv on c-span 2.
feast fans top hello and i remember mr
head
i remember mr hedge's uh
book a war as a force to give a meeting
and writing that book back in that time
era
being the california i can tell you that
was burley dude
i just got a couple quick questions
uh
what's your hedge's uh
form of music and has you ever heard of
the uh science fiction author frank
herbert wrote the dune series which is
basically science fiction
telling truthful tales about power
and my third question was uh did you
think of the new trend
in the pharmaceutical community to sort
of
blame everybody's uh genetic makeup for
uh
you know character defects and that sort
of corporate nexus all right mike thank
you for all those questions mr hedges
okay i can't i haven't read the dune
series so um i i can't respond to that
one uh i think what uh the caller is
question is talking about is something
called biological determinism the idea
that morality is determined by biology
i would certainly say that biology
has a heavy influence in how we respond
as somebody who has been
repeatedly in war zones i know that when
you're afraid as i've been you start
sort of thinking with another part of
your brain and yet i finally don't
believe that biology is a prison
and that i would break with the
biological determinus
i think that
we do
perhaps not as much as we think but we
do have a capacity for independent
action and i have seen people sacrifice
even their own safety or lives
to protect others
and so
i find the whole idea of genetic makeup
or biology determining how we act and
determining morality frightening because
i think it absolves us of of moral
choice
in empire of illusion at no period in
american history has our democracy been
in such peril or the possibility of
totalitarianism
as real our way of life is over our
profligate consumption is finished our
children will never have the standard of
living we had this is the bleak future
this is reality there is little
president obama can do to stop it it has
been decades in the making it cannot be
undone with 1 trillion or 2 trillion in
bailout money nor will it be solved by
clinging to the illusions of the past
that's what you wrote in
20
2010 i believe 2009 is when empire of
illusion came out and this email we have
received from barlow humphreys
i have read your books and continue to
read your truth dig columns and
understand the points you make when
criticizing what is wrong with our
government and country i think they are
brilliant listing problems and
shortcomings is useful to appoint
however i would like you to list also
those positive things that an individual
can do to correct the problems you so
clearly outline
well
i think that
referring to the passage that you just
read
if we don't radically reconfigure our
relationship
uh to the consumer culture to the fossil
fuel industry and to the environment we
are finished
that the climate science is in
and
we cannot continue to live as we have
been living this doesn't mean a
diminished
life
in fact one could argue that breaking
from the addiction of rampant
consumption is spiritually healthy
that speaking to the rest of the world
not through the language of violence but
through
a regained kind of humility
is something that is salutory
but the fact is
we must
radically
confront
the destruction
that humankind is carrying out against
the ecosystem if we are to have any kind
of sustainable future so uh i think the
work of bill mckibben and others is
extremely important especially against
this tar sands effort to bring this
pipeline down through canada
which i think hansen calls the end game
or something to that effect i mean that
basically our chief nassau's chief
climate scientist
in essence saying it's over uh and yet
we're sitting by pretending it's not
happening we're shredding uh kyoto
you know we've done nothing in
copenhagen nothing at durban what can we
do well i'm a great supporter of the
occupy movement
because i think that here
people are carrying out acts of civil
disobedience understanding that within
the system itself there is no way to
halt uh corporate malfeasance and and
corporate criminality uh and i
have invested a lot of time in it um and
i think that uh
it's a it's a huge glimmer of hope
lucius sorrentino emails into you mr
hedges the occupy movement has been
criticized for not having a political
agenda aim or purpose other than
creating an internet mem
the 99 percent versus the one percent
and drawing attention to the problem
what do you see as the future of occupy
wall street as in so far as political
activism goes
i disagree that it doesn't have a
message i think the message is very
clear
and the message is the corporate coup
has to be reversed
the corporate overlords have to go
i covered the revolutions in
east germany czechoslovakia and finally
romania
and we used to hear the same criticisms
leveled against the organizers for
instance in east germany that they what
are your demands well uh
the
movement understands that
you know there there are certainly
things that i think most people within
the occupy movement would support are
revoking corporate personhood campaign
finance
uh
a serious jobs program especially
directed at the young moratorium on uh
foreclosures and bank repositions all of
which i support and all of which i think
are important but they're not going to
come
as long as the political system is held
hostage uh to corporate interests as
long as we live in what sheldon woollen
calls this system of inverted
totalitarianism uh and so they
keep it focused on the fundamental
problem and of course the power lee uh
criticize it criticizes the movement for
not making specific demands for not
funneling this energy back into
a dead system
and i think the most telling moment for
me
uh came when there was a coordinated
effort by 18 cities to shut down occupy
encampments including in oakland
l.a
new york
and for me that
was an indication of how tone deaf
and out of touch those in power are the
idea that they could physically
eradicate these movements and you not
address
the injustices
and suffering that had given birth to
these movements
if they functioned as a liberal class
should function
let's go back to roosevelt and wallace
if they uh were serious about attempting
to save corporate capitalism they would
have immediately announced a one
trillion dollar jobs program targeted at
uh people under the age of 25 a
moratorium on
on
bank repossessions and foreclosures uh
and uh
for giving one trillion dollars in
student debt i mean these would have
been the kinds of steps uh that might
have been able to begin to ameliorate
the anger uh the legitimate anchor that
has gripped many many many americans and
yet they think they can use a
militarized police forces and i've been
in the middle of it i mean this is like
being in a star wars movie they're
stormtroopers in essence a command
helicopters up in the sky these are
peaceful protests
uh directing traffic
uh you know
instances of very brutal behavior pepper
spraying beating i was arrested outside
goldman sachs people were being
slammed into the cement
to think that they can counter this by
force i think is deeply misguided and
shows how out of touch those in power
are
next call for chris hedges comes from
seattle bob thanks for holding you're on
book tv
yeah hi mr hedges i really appreciate
your work uh
say uh you know when the
so former soviet union collapsed
the
the message that we received here was
that capitalism
was the victor
there was no alternative to
capitalism on bridal capitalism
and of course during the last great
depression of the roosevelt
administration communism was
an active threat to the elites here so
possibly out of fear the new deal was
enacted
since there was a vacuum created by the
collapse of the former soviet union
the elite well the people here had no
alternative
so the elites of course no longer have
any fear of the people because of course
capitalism
is the only answer it's the victor uh
but let me ask you a question uh of your
current um
crop of political uh people in this
country
who would you pick as someone that could
uh rebalance uh the equation here
okay bob we got the point thank you mr
hedges well first of all let me talk
about capitalism i'm not actually
you know i'm not a marxist i'm not
against capitalism uh but there are
different forms of capitalism there's
the penny capitalism of the farmers in
the
small farm town in upstate new york
where i grew up who brought their
produce in and sold it there's the
regional capitalism of the local
hardware store owner or small business
owner who lived in the community
paid taxes sat on the school board then
there's corporate capitalism and that i
am against that's something else it's
supranational it doesn't care about the
interests not only of the community but
the nation state itself
it will tear down as it has trade
barriers
and drive production overseas
that's what nafta did and of course now
we're seeing large-scale factory
closures over the border in mexico as
these corporations
move to the cut rate embrace of china's
totalitarian capitalism
or vietnam or bangladesh where people in
sweatshops are paid 22 cents an hour
or even prison labor and because
of globalism because of corporate
capitalism because the destruction of
nation national boundaries
workers in this country and everywhere
else are told that they have to be
competitive on a global scale which
means being competitive with people who
work in sweatshops or or prison labor in
china and it's corporate capitalism that
i find frightening i'm a huge in terms
of political figures i don't believe
that given the configurations of our
political system
we are going to mount uh a serious
challenge to it through the electoral
process i think the challenge will come
through the occupy movements uh and i
don't think these movements are going
away
uh you know it
when you cover the revolutions in
eastern europe you became very cognizant
of that timetables were impossible to
predict overthrowing the communist
regime and poland took
10 years
in east germany it took 10 weeks and in
czechoslovakia it took 10 days
no one really knows these movements have
a kind of life of their own how they
spring
you know i was in leipzig
on the afternoon of november 9th 1989
with the leaders of the east german
opposition and they said well maybe
within a year there will be free passage
back and forth across the berlin wall
within a matter of hours the berlin wall
at least as an impediment to human
traffic no longer existed and that was a
huge lesson for me that even those most
closely associated with these movements
don't know where they're going and
oftentimes don't even know what their
potential is um
so
i put my faith in movements i think karl
popper in the open society and its
enemies was right
the question is not how do you get good
people to rule that's the wrong question
most people papa rights who are
attracted to power are at best mediocre
which is obama or venal which is bush
the question is how
do you make those in power frightened of
you and that comes through movements and
the destruction of those movements labor
movements
all sorts of social movements including
communist unions uh which were the first
sort of integrated organizations in the
country why great
public intellectuals and artists like
paul robeson joined them because it was
the only place a black man with any
dignity uh could often go uh these have
all been decimated and and that has been
catastrophic to uh our democracy i think
we have to put our faith back into
movements which of course is what the
occupy wall street is it's a movement
in the chapter in uh illusion of wisdom
in the book empire of illusions mr
hedges writes our elites the ones in
congress the ones on wall street and the
ones being produced at prestigious
universities and business schools do not
have the capacity to fix our financial
mess
indeed they will make it worse they have
no concept thanks to the education they
have received of how to replace a failed
system with a new one they are petty
timid and uncreative bureaucrats
superbly trained to carry out systems
management they see only piecemeal
solutions that will satisfy the
corporate structure their entire focus
is numbers profits and personal
advancement they lack a moral and
intellectual core they are as able to
deny gravely ill people medical coverage
to increase company profits as they are
to use taxpayer dollars to pedal costly
weapon systems to blood-soaked
dictatorships the human consequences
never figure into their balance sheets
the democratic system they believe is a
secondary product of the free market
which they slavishly serve
next call for chris hedges comes from
westport connecticut lois you're on book
tv on c-span 2 good afternoon good
afternoon so glad to see somebody like
mr hedges on
c-span
um i i feel strongly that the liberal
media and the government work together
and by doing so they both gain advantage
one instance that gave me this idea was
a few months ago there was an article by
bill keller in the new york times
magazine
was pictures of
osama bin laden
and obama
on the bottom of that article
and
since i assume that the media is corrupt
and the government is corrupt
wouldn't it be good to expose this
unspoken alliance
couldn't that help our country
thanks a lot
well you put me in the awkward position
of defending the new york times um
i don't think it's quite that
black and white
i don't think the new york times is
corrupt
um i think that the new york times is
certainly an institution that
uh who's a sort of unofficial credo
and i say is someone who worked within
the institution for a long time is
do not significantly alienate those on
whom we depend for money and access
that doesn't mean that they won't
alienate them at times i think the
sin of the traditional media like the
new york times
is more the liable mission now certainly
they served as propagandists uh rather
naive and unwitting
propagandists uh for the bush white
house in the lead up to the iraq war
repeating all sorts of claims and
putting things on the front page that we
now know are untrue with very little
vetting or i think journalistic
integrity
and yet uh
i think that there are many people
within the newspaper uh who care about
news who care about journalism who care
about truth and the best reporters care
finely about truth and we talked earlier
about objectivity and impartiality uh
when one uh
feels for the suffering of uh those in
sarajevo and i was in sarajevo during
the war that doesn't uh give them an out
in terms of speaking the truth and
writing the truth uh even about systems
they may
or people they may empathize with
i covered
after the first gulf war i was in
northern iraq in the kurdish held
territories and i wrote very harsh
articles about disputes even arm
disputes between kurdish factions
corruption cigarette smuggling uh
to the point where some of this stuff
was even read uh by the propaganda
broadcasts directed at the kurdish
territories uh out of baghdad um and yet
you know as orwell said if you look at
journalism as a as a product that we as
journalists have to sell what it is is
our credibility that a lie may work in
the short term and a liable mission is
still a lie
but in the long term it destroys you so
uh it's not incompatible to feel uh and
also to speak the truth uh and i think
that the the problem with the new york
times is not so much what it covers but
what it often doesn't cover uh the fact
as i mentioned earlier that in the
build-up to the subprime mortgage crisis
they weren't out there in poor
neighborhoods
that they gravitate towards the centers
of power
and and leave
the struggles and the suffering and the
injustices that are visited especially
on the weak and the vulnerable unheard
i think that the
media has done a horrific job in terms
of
uh
highlighting
what tens of millions of americans are
enduring i mean the 47 million americans
who live in poverty now spend about 35
percent of their income just on food to
eat and yet they're largely invisible
especially on the commercial media now
uh
we are seeing the rise of a non-reality
based media that's fox news
cable news channels
that
are not rooted in verifiable fact and
this frightens me very much whatever the
limitations of the new york times and
they have them i
and i've been very critical of them
including my book death of the liberal
class they are rooted in verifiable fact
that discussions are
based around verifiable fact and with
the rise of so-called media outlets that
discard fact where where opinion becomes
interchangeable with fact
then you enter a kind of totalitarian
state because people are allowed to
believe
whatever they want to believe or
whatever they are made to believe and i
see the kinds of attacks that are made
by the right wing against the new york
times it's not so much ideological i
don't think the new york times at this
point can be classified as a liberal
newspaper
but i think it's much more pernicious
that what they're attacking is
reality-based media and essentially
trying to destroy it uh before they drop
that sort of iron curtain of propaganda
around all of us uh mr hedges from your
first book which was a finalist for the
national book critic circle award for
non-fiction uh war is a force that gives
us meaning you write the enduring
attraction of war is this even with its
destruction and carnage it can give us
what we long for in life it can give us
purpose meaning a reason for living you
go on to write the communal march
against an enemy generates a warm
unfamiliar bond with our neighbors our
community our nation wiping out
unsettling undercurrents of alienation
and dislocation
war in times of malaise and desperation
is a potent distraction
and finally
despite all this i am not a pacifist
there are times when the force wielded
by one immoral faction must be countered
by a faction that while never moral is
perhaps less immoral
and i say that with a great deal of pain
because i know what violence does i know
the poison that it is
and yet i was as i said in sarajevo uh
when it was being hit with two thousand
serbian shells a day
a constant sniper fire four to five dead
a day two dozen wounded a day
including two thousand children being
killed in that city 45 foreign
correspondents
were killed there
dozens were wounded and we understood
those of us who were in that besieged
city
completely surrounded that if the serbs
broke through the trenches or literally
they were defended by sort of world war
one style trenches around the city
a third of the city would probably be
massacred and the rest would be driven
into
displacement and refugee camps
and we'd seen it in the drina valley
we'd seen it in vukovar we knew what the
pattern was we knew what the modus
operandi was
and one understands when you are faced
with
the very real possibility of
not only your own
annihilation but the annihilation of
your family your children
your community
how you pick up a weapon
now uh unfortunately once you do that
you cross a line
uh you are not free from the poison of
violence and initially those who
organized the defenses in sarajevo kane
were gangsters they came from the
criminal class cello and others and when
they weren't shooting at serbs across
the barricades they were raiding the
apartments of ethnic serbs in the city
eluding them and sometimes executing
them
and
you know one of the reasons that i am
such a strong and vocal supporter of the
occupy movement is because it is
non-violent
and the corporate corporations know only
one word it's more they will push and
push and push until there's a reaction
and i want that reaction not to descend
into violence because i know what
violence does that that violence even
when it is employed an ostensibly a just
cause
as nietzsche said uh pits your monsters
against their monsters and then it just
always becomes tragic
i don't believe in just war um i think
sometimes human beings
are
pushed to such an extent
that violence is inevitable um but the
consequences for those who employ
violence on on both sides is
catastrophic
next call for chris hedges comes from
lexington kentucky joe thanks for
holding you're on book tv on c-span 2.
hey c-span happy new year to you guys
you too happy new year chris hezes i
watch you on league tv i like your stuff
thank you
and uh just wanted your opinion on
um
the
just your personal opinion on
who actually
controls
our world
who controls the world chris tell us i
know you know
well uh i think
the world is a big place uh but
certainly the most powerful entities are
these huge corporations corporations
like goldman sachs for instance
uh because i spent so much of my life in
the developing world places like africa
latin america and the middle east just
to give you a small example
i saw what happened when uh commodity
futures were bought up by corporations
like goldman sachs and a wheat for
instance which it has in the last year
increased by his price increased by 100
percent
uh i saw the human consequences of that
the children who were malnourished and
even in some cases died of starvation
because they couldn't afford to eat
um
you know we the wars in both iraq and
afghanistan have very little popular
support and yet for a handful of
corporations lockheed martin uh northrop
grumman and halliburton
uh that they're immensely profitable as
war is for
a certain tiny segment of the power lead
and always has been as smedley butler
said you know war is a racket
so i i think that we
unfortunately have created a world where
power has become centralized
in the hands of a select group of
corporations that are more powerful than
the state itself
that
it is within the american political
system impossible to vote against the
interests of goldman sachs and unless we
thwart that power
we
are doomed because
corporations unfettered capitalism and
carl piliani wrote a great book about
this in 1944 called the great
transformation uh turn everything into a
commodity in that sense karl marx was
right i mean unfettered capitalism is a
revolutionary force and
human beings become commodities the
natural world becomes a commodity that
you exploit until exhaustion or collapse
and that's why the environmental crisis
is intimately twinned with the economic
crisis and if we don't somehow find a
mechanism or a way to break the power of
those corporations
they will trash the continue to trash
the ecosystem to the point at which
life for huge segments of the human
species will be unsustainable
chris hedges david chow's emails into
you from new york city do you see
today's economic and political climate
as somewhat resembling that which
existed in germany during the 1930s
well noam chomsky uh and i'm a great
admirer of chomsky has made that
comparison uh i think
in some ways yes it's always difficult
to make those historical analogies
because uh one has to be very cognizant
of the
major differences including the massive
war reparations the defeat of world war
one
uh the fact that germany had no real
tradition of a liberal democracy
under its monarchy
but i think that there are some
frightening
similarities the most important being a
kind of volumization of the american
working class uh
the the disenfranchisement of working
men and women uh the uh you know used to
be in this country uh going back to the
50s into the 60s that
you could work in an auto plant or a
steel mill
and make a salary that would actually
support a family and allow you to buy a
small house and send your kids to
college and you had medical
benefits and a pension plan and uh
all of that's vanished
that we have thrust our working class
into the service sector economy low-wage
economy households not only do people
tend to work
within the working class more than one
job but almost everybody in the house is
working in order to keep afloat
and that has been a devastating change
and i think
one of the rise
or the rise of the christian right as i
argue in american fascists is directly
linked to this despair
this
because these economic dislocations
bring with it destructions of
communities destruction of families
substance abuse domestic abuse all the
attendant problems that come when
communities break down and people
retreat from this reality-based world
which
uh frankly almost destroys them almost
has destroyed them into a
non-reality-based belief system in all
totalitarian systems or
non-reality-based belief systems a world
of magic of historical inevitability a
world where god intervenes on your
behalf
and i think the only way
to bring these people back
into a reality-based world is to
re-enfranchise them within the economy
and i think uh this is something that we
saw in weimar uh that uh that it was
despair and all the great writers on
totalitarianism hannah aaron
carl popper
fritz stern
use despair as that starting point that
drives people
into
these very frightening movements and i
think that despair is very prevalent
within american society and very
dangerous
in his 2005 book losing moses on the
freeway the ten commandments in america
mr hedges writes we watch him passively
as the wealthy and the elite the huge
corporations rob us ruin the environment
to fraud consumers and taxpayers and
create an exclusive american oligarchy
that fuses wealth and political power we
watch passively because we believe we
can enter the club it is greed that
keeps us silent
susie in l.a good afternoon
chris i want to thank you for your
thoughts and your books
they're very deep and they really open
many of our minds to some very important
concepts
and you really try
at least for my observation to
you know present a lot of deep thought
and objective reality
i was troubled however in the area when
you talk about the middle east because
you talk about your history in terms of
knowing
arabic and
the people there but i was wondering
also if you had an equal knowledge of
hebrew and the people on that side
well i lived in jerusalem for two years
i don't speak hebrew that was a
conscious decision because when i worked
in the middle east to be working in
syria or baghdad and to speak arabic and
have any hebrew words creep into your
arabic
could immediately land you in prison
although i have to say that eventually
in both iraq and iran
i was thrown in prison anyway or jailed
for brief periods of time
i have a great
uh admiration uh and affection for
israel uh and i think that the
um
parameters of the debate about uh the
middle east and about the
israeli-palestinian conflict in israel
are far broader
than they are in the united states
my opinions are not particularly
controversial in jerusalem among most of
my friends who sort of yawn and pour
themselves another beer
but they are in the united states uh the
newspaper ahrefs for instance
the israeli newspaper rx i think has
probably the best coverage of the
palestinians of any paper
in the country uh and all of these
articles are written by israeli jews uh
danny rubenstein uh amir haas
uh gideon levy uh these are really great
great great journalists um and and do
israel credit uh so
i think that the
uh frustration for many of us old middle
east hands is that uh we saw
possibilities uh in oslo and in the
relationship between yitzhak ravine and
king hussein and i knew king hussein
and
and covered rabine
and with the assassination of ravine
we watched that hope
essentially vanish and israel uh as the
united states has
essentially uh become captive to a
really rapacious right wing i mean for
instance is the israeli foreign minister
avidor liberman who has openly called
for the ethnic cleansing of
israeli arabs and palestinians i mean
this was unthinkable when i first got to
jerusalem in 1988 and
for me it's really a debate about the
health of the middle east and the health
of the israeli state itself
i don't think that responding to
a historical injustice
through the use of force and occupation
is in the long term
productive
for the state of israel itself uh yet at
the same time of course i i uh adamantly
oppose
uh and there are those uh within the
arab world who call for the destruction
of the state of israel i i uh most
states including our own uh i've spent a
lot of time in pine ridge for a new book
were founded on historical injustices
but i think we have to work out as we're
being wanted to uh an accommodation
whereby which both peoples can live in
dignity
chris hedges uh what is pine ridge and
when will this new book come out
i've been working for two years with the
comic artist joe sacco
on a book called days of destruction
days of revolt that will be out in june
and we have gone to the sacrifice zones
the poorest pockets of the united states
camden new jersey which per capita per
capita is the poorest city in the
country also the most dangerous
pine ridge south dakota
uh it's a
lakota uh reservation
um where the uh average license life
expectancy for male is 48 the lowest in
the western hemisphere outside of haiti
we've worked a lot in the coal fields of
southern west virginia
and i mean the destruction of the
appalachian mountains is truly
frightening
um
you know instead of sort of burrowing
for coal they're just blasting the
mountains into a moonscape into rubble
destroying the water destroying the air
none of this is going to come back
it's just it's cannibalism and then
finally in the
tomato fields and the agricultural
fields in florida with
primarily undocumented although not
exclusively undocumented workers uh to
take a and the last chapter of zuccotti
when we began the book
uh we did give it the title days of
destruction days revolt but the revolt
was conjecture and then uh towards the
end of it suddenly flowered this
movement which became a kind of
expression of what we
felt
would be a response we didn't know what
the response was going to look like but
we felt there would be a response a
popular response
and it's a look at
um
you know what happens when you kneel
before the marketplace
and when human lives the course of human
life and human community are determined
by the dictates of the marketplace and
there are no impediments to corporate
control because these sacrifice zones
are now expanding outwards across the
country i mean roughly one-third of this
country already lives in pretty extreme
poverty or certainly struggles and that
will only grow
if the corporate state is not stopped
because their goal is to reconfigure as
they and they were already very far down
that road into a kind of oligarchic
neo-feudalism where you have a rapacious
moneyed entitled elite which controls
the economy
systems of communication education
as well as political power a sort of
thin managerial class and then
two-thirds of the country are left
scrambling to survive
you're watching book tv on c-span 2's
in-depth program chris hedges author
journalist pulitzer prize winner is our
guest this month mark in sonora
california good afternoon
hi mr hedges um
we had mentioned earlier about um
uh going into i think that the other
caller i think he said um iraq and we
were talking about iran and i'm kind of
um wondering what do you think
would take for us to get into iran and
then what do you think would be the
advantages and the consequences if we
don't
um well first of all i i covered iran i
spent a lot of time there including
sometime in iranian jail cells i was
actually deported at one point in
handcuffs
my best guess is that the iranian regime
is trying to build
a nuclear weapon
but
having come in out of the middle east
and spent as long as i have in the
middle east
that doesn't worry me what worries me is
the transference of that technology to
non-state groups
iran has an address um and and states
that have an address
are i think very unlikely to use those
weapons
i think that iran wants it as a
defensive measure i think they
understand that if iraq for instance had
had a nuclear weapon in the way that
north korea has nuclear weapons they
probably the americans would not have
invaded
um i'm not pretending to speak for the
iranian regime but this is my assessment
i think pakistan is probably in fact in
terms of the proliferation of nuclear
technology
more dangerous than iran and and frankly
pakistan is more unstable pakistan
frightens me more than iran does
so uh
okay will they eventually get a weapon i
suspect they will
uh i think attacking them uh would be
deeply counterproductive um
first of all there are roughly a
thousand sites that have been picked out
many of these are in highly populated
areas so the loss of civilian life would
be catastrophic
remember that
iraq is primarily shia and i think that
an attack on iran would be interpreted
throughout the muslim world as an attack
on shiism itself two million shiites
in saudi arabia
bahrain is primarily shia
shia minorities in countries like
pakistan itself
and
i think then you would have a kind of
conflict go
regional
it is my understanding
that the iranians if attacked even if
americans are not directly involved and
it is primarily an israeli attack
although i'm not sure that's possible
because i think they have to fly over
iraqi airspace
they will obliterate
any american bases including the green
zone
uh
uh in
iraq with of course uh heavy loss of
american life so um
i i don't want to defend the iranian
regime they're a pretty perfidious group
uh yet at the same time i i think that
attacking iran would really be um a
disaster
chris hedges how'd you earn the honor of
being handcuffed and deported from
iran and
if people wanted to read one of your
books and hear that story which book
should they read
i don't know that i put that story in a
book
war is a force that gives us meaning has
sort of the most personal accounts it's
a meditation on war
uh starting
it's not chronological but it's a
meditation on what ward does to
individuals and societies and uh i draw
from many of the conflicts that i
covered roughly a half dozen uh from
sarajevo and kosovo to
the first gulf war where i was actually
captured and taken prisoner by the iraqi
republican guard in basra
um
and you know i've never gone back and
reread it it was such a painful book to
write so i can't tell you whether the
iranian story is in there but in short
what it's just a silly foreign
correspondence story um we can fill up
three hours of those if you want
but what happened was i uh was supposed
to interview the president raf
sandinojan and uh
um uh
and i went to get a visa
robson johnny and i was supposed to get
a visa
and they at the embassy i can't remember
where it was bahrain or somewhere they
gave me a multiple entry visa by mistake
and so the the um iranian official took
white out
and whited out the multiple entry and
wrote like one visit
so i got to the airport very late at
night and they
these border guards or you know this the
the sort of customs police accused me of
forging the visa
so
they locked me in a room at night and um
i did precisely what you were not
supposed to do which was throw a fit
and actually broke chairs against the
wall and this is just juvenile behavior
but i did it and of course they got even
angrier and the next flight out was five
or six in the morning it was turkish
airlines flight and so these you know
big guards came in and
handcuffed me and took my passport
and escorted me on to the turkish
airlines flight and by this time i'd
been 24 hours without sleep so my eyes
were sort of red and i was unshaven and
i had to go on to this turkish airlines
flight in handcuffs of course all the
passengers thought i you know was i
don't know selling drugs or something in
iran and they gave my passport to the
captain of the plane and said that i was
not allowed to have my american passport
back until i had reached turkish
airspace so that was my did he give it
back to you he did i also was in that's
not the only time i was in a jail cell
in iran i was also picked up by the
caspian sea where i didn't have
permission to be
and they have people's militias called
besiji and so they captured me and they
decided to put me on trial in the
morning but they wanted to wait for a
big crowd because it would be sort of a
fun event and they put me in a jail cell
there um and i always carry a book with
me so i had dostoevsky's the idiot i
read 170 pages of the idiot in an
iranian jail cell
and my translator was out there
frantically
and sort of
charmingly trying to get us out and at
about two in the morning
an iranian police officer came open my
cell door
said he would escort us
to
the limits of the province and um
and when we got to the limits of the
province we got out of the car and i
tried to give him money actually um and
he said no no i he said i hate this
regime he's now get in your car and
drive all the way to tehran and don't
stop and so i was spared being
i was spared the people's trial which
i'm sure i would have been found guilty
of something
richard laurel maryland good afternoon
you're on book tv on c span 2.
thank you uh
i've had a question in my mind
ever since 9 11
that never has really been
it has been addressed rather sparsely in
the media but uh
pappy cannon
on uh mclaughlin show and i'm gonna
paraphrase what he said was
that
we need to realize that
with the occupation of religious sites
or sacred areas of the middle east
by the united states and united states
support of israel
these are reasons
why
9 11 occurred perhaps
and
until we address those issues
we will continue down the same path
mr hedges
well the caller raises an important and
delicate point um
what were the attacks of 9 11 huge
explosions and death
above a city skyline has a peculiar form
of communication
it was straight out of hollywood
where did these attackers learn this
tactic from us
when robert mcnamara began bombing
uh north vietnam
uh bombing attacks that
would leave hundreds of thousands of
civilians dead
he said it was i quote a means of
communication with hanoi
and what happened on 9 11 was that those
means of communication were brought home
to us
9 11 for me was one of the great
tragedies
historical tragedies of our country
because
the only way to fight terrorism and
terrorism has been with us since uh
solas wrote about it in the jukarthan
wars is to isolate terrorists and
terrorist groups within their own
societies
and you do that by garnering the empathy
of those
people
in those countries where terrorist
groups operate
and i covered al-qaeda for the new york
times based in paris
after 9 11.
and we had garnered the empathy not only
of the world but the muslim world
muslims were appalled at what had been
done
in the name of their religion
you had uh senior islamic clerics like
sheikh tantali at al-azhar in in cairo
denouncing 9 11 as a crime against
humanity which it was and then going on
to denounce osama bin laden as a fraud
somebody with no theological training or
theological or religious legitimacy and
therefore no right to issue fatwas or
religious edicts
and if we had the courage to be
vulnerable
if we had built on that empathy we would
be far safer and more secure today than
we are instead we responded just as
these terrorist groups wanted us to
respond and that was to begin by
dropping iron fragmentation bombs all
over the middle east
uh the search for al qaeda is not a war
you can't have a war on terror it's a
tautology terror is a tactic uh it
should have been handled by the
intelligence community in the same way
that black september was handled by the
mossad and even then innocent people
died they killed an innocent waiter by
mistake at one point thinking sweden uh
but certainly not by conventional
military forces and so i think we played
right into the hands of the very forces
that we have been trying to defeat uh
911 and al qaeda were used as excuses to
curtail
uh democracy civil liberties
at home uh we we openly began to employ
torture
not only in places like guantanamo
but
at our black sites around the globe as
well as against dissidents like bradley
manning and i think that there's been a
frightening erosion of everything that
we value and hold dear
and that we consider sacred uh and uh
and uh
you know the people who perpetrated
these crimes of 9 11 probably couldn't
be happier
steve in uniontown pennsylvania please
go ahead with your question or comment
for chris hedges hi peter uh it was only
a few months ago i called in and uh i
got through and um
when michael moore was there and i
suggested getting chris hedges on and uh
well uh here he is i'm so powerful we'll
give you the credit thanks um chris a
question about um
uh corporate personhood um
they've used uh corporations have
exploited the 14th amendment says to
like
get more power and uh
i was wondering if it's possible now and
this isn't facetiousness uh the 13th
amendment
uh outlaws slavery right so
if
these legal persons are owned by uh
private private people or shareholders
wouldn't it be possible to free them
free the corporations from this
ownership
through the 13th amendment and some you
know
uh somehow to disempower them
and uh i like to see cornell west on
some time thanks
well that would be great if we had a
judicial system that didn't serve the
interests of the corporate state
and citizens united is a clear example
as to who this supreme court serves it's
not us it's them
and i think the power of the occupy
movement is that it realizes that
uh so many segments of our government uh
and and institutions including much of
the media are just wholly owned
subsidiaries of corporations uh that we
have to confront that power directly
through civil disobedience which
includes
uh the willingness to be arrested uh
that is the only hope we have left i
think of affecting any kind of
fundamental and real change appealing to
the systems of power including the
judiciary i think at this point is not
going to work
this is book tv's in-depth program our
monthly author program where we focus on
one author and his or her body of work
this month it's chris hedges for that
last caller
cornell west has done in depth and you
can watch that at booktv.org
in its entirety just use the search
function up in the upper left hand
corner the producer of this program is
tonya davis fargo north dakota ed you're
on with chris hedges hi
uh mr hedges a speculative question
what might mr blank find a recent
chairman of goldman sachs have meant
when he responded to a question about
goldman sachs's market activities by
saying i think
i or we were doing god's work i or we
were doing god's work
thank you ed
self-delusion
um would probably be the first word that
would come to mind uh for me figures
like blankfein and others
should be put on trial for the
activities that they have carried out
and i think the failure of a functioning
judiciary to
prosecute what are clear acts of
fraudulent activity and manipulation of
markets
the ability of these corporations to not
only
loot the treasury but now essentially
borrow
money without interest
while
the rest of us are shackled in a kind of
debt peonage i mean this is just uh
indefensible in a functioning democracy
and uh
you know it's it's a it's an odd
situation to be
a dissident or a critic
and call for the rule of law on the
political spectrum traditionally
those who call for the rule of law and
the restoration of the rule of law are
considered conservatives uh
and yet that's essentially what people
such as myself are doing i think it's
the radicals who've taken power
uh because that's essentially what we're
asking for we're asking for the
application of law uh to be applied
against all people impartially uh and
fairly and it's not being done
uh philippe emails into you mr hedges
interested in hearing your opinions
concerning wikileaks its antagonism with
the new york times julian assange and
bradley manning
well the new york times uh i wouldn't
call it necessarily antagonism because
of course they printed
much of the wikileaks document what you
had was uh they took the information and
there was uh both on the editorial pages
and even within the news page as a kind
of character assassination of julian
assange
i think wikileaks was
you know
whoever leaked it whether bradley
manning leaked it or not we don't know
but whoever leaked it exposed clear war
crimes including the killing of
reuters
journalists in cold blood and many
civilians through that video
where helicopters are attacking civilian
vans
and i think that um
there is a moral imperative for those
who see war crimes i mean this is what
post-nuremberg laws are about uh to
report them even when they are in uh
they contravene
uh security requirements and uh
this is what dan wellsberg did when he
leaked the pentagon papers so uh i think
that we can go back to the pentagon
papers uh for an analogy although i
think the pentagon papers were probably
far more destructive
in terms of the release of that
information to the wider public than
anything that came out of wikileaks a
lot of the wikileaks stuff and you know
there's so much of it i can hardly claim
to have read all of it but i read a lot
of it is just gossip uh frankly uh you
know cables and foreign leaders we don't
like and sort of embarrassing things
that ambassadors said
uh
hillary clinton calling on
diplomats to spy on people at the u.n
this kind of stuff
but within it was some significant
information that i think
should be made public should have been
made public so that we could begin to
understand uh what has been happening in
in the conflicts in iraq and afghanistan
we have an hour and a half left with
chris hedges he is the author of nine
non-fiction books beginning in 2002
war is a force that gives us meaning
2003 what every person should know about
war
losing moses on the freeway came out in
2005 american fascists in 2006 i don't
believe in atheists which is now in its
re-print called when atheism becomes
religion that came out in 2008
collateral damage in 2008 as well
empire of illusion 2009 the best-selling
death of the liberal class in 2010 and
his most recent book the world as it is
came out in 2011. well every month when
we have the author on we always ask them
about what they're reading some of their
favorite books and influences as we
continue our program we want to show you
that now
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
oh
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
and we are back with our in-depth guest
chris hedges mr hedges you are currently
reading the cross and the lynching tree
by james cohn what is that
one of the most important books of
theology
of the last few decades
cohn's an amazing theologian
and this book is
uh which he spent 10 years writing
is a look at the utter failure on the
part of white theologians and the white
church to respond to the lynching of
black men and women the reign of terror
in jim crow
south
and he argues correctly
that the failure on the part of the
white church
to understand that
the crucifixion of jesus was a lynching
um meant that it couldn't see the power
of the crucifixion
uh and fundamentally the message of the
gospel itself within its midst
and uh it is
really a stunning
stunning work uh
it's just filled with intellectual and
emotional depth charges
that uh whether you're a believer or not
you should pick up and read
milky russell tweets in to you mr hedges
can chris talk about the issues
a black man might face saying the same
things you're saying
to a white audience
well
look at what's happened to cornell west
uh when he has gotten up and criticized
barack obama
he's been attacked
roundly including within the black
mainstream media
to get up and speak an uncomfortable
truth
as cohn has done throughout his life
is to have a lot of people turn away
from you to turn their backs on you
i've spent
over two decades of my life living among
people who are not white
and i speak spanish
as well as arabic
and french
and
it has been a long process as a white
privileged male to begin to understand
the reality of white supremacy
both as it manifests itself within the
heart of the empire and on the outer
reaches of empire
there are all sorts of assumptions that
i can make
that people who live in marginal
communities and people of color cannot
make
and
uh
it's important i think for those of us
who come out of positions of privilege
and we spoke about the two and a half
years i lived in roxbury to put
ourselves in these environments
because
we're forced to confront our own
blindness
and
when you develop close relationships
with people who suffer
whether they're palestinian or whether
they're african-american in the inner
city
when they become people you love and
care about
and you see how entire systems are
conspired against them
it becomes painful for you
but i think more importantly you begin
to see
all the things that up until then you
were unable to see
uh and that
and that that blindness that there will
always be a kind of gulf between you
and those who are oppressed
there will always be
an inability to understand
you get as close as you can you work as
hard as you can and then you accept
your own deficiencies
and
i i think that very very few
people
one of the books you put up there was
litwak the historian who's really a
remarkable historian wrote
a trilogy of books that i'm about to
start i teach in a prison i'm about to
start in a couple weeks and i'm teaching
those three books
and it's
the aftermath of the civil war
reconstruction
jim crow and then he wrote a beautiful
sort of thin essay contemporary essay
called when is free free
but very few
howard zinn had it but i think very few
people managed to cross those lines and
it it really takes a lot of time a lot
of effort
a lot of work and a lot of
self-reflection and self-criticism 202
is the area code 737-001 for those of
you in the east and central time zones
202-737-002 mountain and pacific time
zones book tv at cspan.org is our email
address at book tv is our twitter handle
angela in farmington california you're
on with chris hedges
thank you thank you for taking my call
can you hear me we're listening please
go ahead thank you oh see
you mr hedges you and others like you
are the lighthouse in this foggy world
can you be so kind
mr obama who is a constitutional
attorney
is disheartening that very sign to
detain someone on suspicion it is most
most troubling
can you lend an opinion please it is
very very disheartening thank you
well i think one of the tragedies of the
obama administration is that here you
have a chief executive who's clearly
intelligent
he's trained as a constitutional lawyer
and yet he's done so little
to not only defend our constitutional
rights
but reverse
the assaults against
constitutional rights that were
put into place by the previous
administration obama clearly understands
where the centers of power lie
he knows that in order to remain in
office he must serve those centers of
power
but sadly
its opportunism its careerism uh he has
decided to betray
uh the majority of the citizenry uh
in order to accrue for himself
uh the
um
the perquisites of power uh but he's
done so at our expense and this is the
tragedy i think on many levels bush was
cert probably clueless i don't think
obama's clueless and and in some ways uh
that makes him even more guilty mr
hedge's rights in death of the liberal
class 2010 is when that book came out
the election of obama was one more
triumph of illusion over substance it
was a skillful manipulation and betrayal
of the public by a corporate power elite
we mistook style and ethnicity an
advertising tactic pioneered by calvin
klein and benatan for progressive
politics and genuine change
john is in chicago john you're on book
mr head is so tv to listen to you
i i do feel that you disparage the
democracy in the united states i
i've been working on the south side of
chicago for about 50 years
and i think the progress that has been
made
in
my area of the world
it is
substantial and it's been done without
revolution and in a democracy
and i i
i feel that obama
has all sorts of problems and he yet at
the same time i think that he is a
leader of significant
uh of significance and i i'm sorry that
you
it seemed to be
against democracy as being practiced in
the united states now
well i wish democracy was practiced as
it should be in the united states
and i certainly feel that i as a writer
and a citizen
am fighting as hard as i can
to reinstate
uh democratic prerogatives
and democratic rights that have been
taken from us not simply by obama this
has been something that's been going on
for a while
but i think we have to restore power to
the citizenry by resting it away from
corporations and i do believe obama has
been complicitous
in
uh the diminishing of our
of our rights and of our of our
political power
next call comes from anchorage alaska
sharon you're on book tv on cspan2 with
chris hedges
it helps if i push the button sorry
about that sharon
am i on now you are okay good good
afternoon
i want to go back to your book days of
destruction
and ask you
um do you make any mention of the
chinese in africa
i'm interested in your thoughts on this
issue
uh days of destruction days of revolt
has not come out yet it's coming out in
june and it is focused uh solely on the
united states
so uh we don't write anything about
uh
africa uh joe sacco and i are are
profiling what's happening internally
within within the united states
mr hedges we're getting a lot of emails
tweets and and uh on this topic and so i
wanted to have you address it this is
from empire of illusion 2009.
universities have trained hundreds of
thousands of graduates for jobs that
soon will not exist they have trained
people to maintain a structure that
cannot be maintained the elite know how
only to feed the beast until it dies
once it is dead they will be helpless
don't expect them to save us they don't
know how
well there you go that's the occupy
movement um you know we are the people
we've been waiting for
and uh i think the power of the occupy
movement is that they understand that
political truth
uh that the elites aren't going to save
us um the elites are
uh through
probably the most sophisticated system
of mass propaganda in human history uh
and they're constantly taking our pulse
and having focus groups and finding out
what we think so they can parrot it back
to us
that's what the public relations
industry does and does very well
to manipulate our emotions
i think that the those who have
gravitated toward the occupy movement
understand
that
the elites
essentially serve interests that are not
our interests and that it is incumbent
upon those of us to
get out and carry out acts of civil
disobedience if we are going to protect
those interests
next call for chris hedges comes from
new milford connecticut george you're on
book tv
hi mr hedges um i'd like to ask you
about you mentioned smedley butler a
little bit ago
could you talk a little more about
general butler and his role in the 1930s
plot to seize the white house and also
if you could speculate on why we know so
little about that plot and about general
butler himself thank you
well butler who i think served 33 years
and four months or something in the u.s
marine corps
after the war began to reflect i think
we have a current uh
figure andrew bacovich who was a colonel
in the military
also engaged in that kind of reflection
after he left service
began to look at why interventions were
carried out on whose behalf they were
carried out and butler writes that
he commanded units that invaded
you know the dominican republic to make
it safe for sugar interests and
cuba to make it safe for banking
interests
and
wrote this pamphlet which is very long
quite powerful called war is a racket in
which he lays that out uh and it's also
interesting as you point out in a kind
of historical footnote is that in
opposition to roosevelt and the new deal
there were industrialists powerful
industrialists
uh
uh henry ford and others
who uh
essentially wanted to carry out a coup
d'etat i'm not 100 on the henry ford
thing so i'd have to go back and check
my history books but certainly powerful
industrials that tried to recruit butler
to carry out a coup and and he exposed
them
chris hedges is our guest gretchen
fallon from arlington virginia emails
into you i'd like to thank you for
helping me with your writing to navigate
these last several bleak years i met you
during desert storm shield you were
interviewing my marine corps husband a
battalion commander in particular i
thought you were clear-eyed and
unsentimental in seeing that the people
in uniform were honorable smart savvy
and often far more skeptical of coming
conflicts than their civilian masters
the beat goes on iraq afghanistan and so
much more how can our leaders continue
to be so out of touch gretchen fallon
harlington virginia well a huge fan of
her husband colonel fallon who
commanded a marine corps battalion
that i spent a lot of time with first
battalion first marines
and that went into kuwait was one of the
first battalions that went into kuwait
and um
uh
you know when the military is good
they're really good
and when they're bad they're really bad
and in marine corps sort of the extreme
example of that
when they come in like
colonel fallon they're remarkable men
and uh
he
remember after the war
uh
i remember two moments you know colonels
are sort of isolated figures within
battalions and so we talked a lot i
remember one time he asked me what
because i never sort of entered like to
interview anybody above the level of
lance corporal the higher up you get the
food chain the more
sort of uh spin you get um so i tend to
like ernie pyle stay with the lower
ranks but he wants to ask me what he
what do my men think of me and i said
you know colonel
uh to be honest they don't really like
officers um but they all say colonel
fallon cares about his men and he got
choked up and uh and at the end of the
war he had seven wounded one of them
pretty seriously and uh
and i told him i thought i said you know
having spent you know weeks and weeks of
you i think you're really a really great
commander
um
and a great leader and uh
he said um
um i got all my men home
and you know on that level he's a
vietnam vet
um in some ways you go to people like
that and there's no one who hates war
more than they do
the good ones
and they want to take all their men home
and
um because of my relationship with the
marine corps i spoke to about 250
colonels and lieutenant colonels on the
eve of the iraq war
and got up and gave this long hour-long
talk so i this thing was really not a
good idea
and
all those people because they were
putting their men on the line
uh because it's them who pay the price
there was no disagreement they
understood this
was folly
um they did their duty
um but they knew it was
insane
and um and you saw
shinseki and a few other military
leaders at very high levels walk out of
this
program because of that
so the idea that somehow
the military is a monolith
um or that you don't have figures like
colonel fallon and having spent time in
the military i i have tremendous respect
for them and and i and i think in some
ways we've done a terrible disservice to
them i mean the idea that somehow it's a
volunteer force and therefore they ask
for what they get
we have plunged
thousands of families in this country
into
perpetual grief and loss
and for what we don't have a right to do
that we don't have a right to do that to
these men and women as i said i'm not a
pacifist but you only go to war as a
last resort as a final imperative
because the costs are so grave and
so
that comment from gretchen means a lot
to me because i'm a great admirer of her
husband
why did you choose to make the speech at
rockford college in 2003
why'd you choose that college why'd you
choose then did you know what the
reaction was going to be
no i didn't
i had been saying similar kinds of
things for some time my book war is a
force that gives us meaning had come out
that fall and so
inevitably i would be asked about the
impending invasion of iraq
now if i was a good careerist i would
have dodged the question but i felt that
was morally not
permissible
the only thing i knew about rockford
college is that one of my heroes jane
adams had graduated from there i didn't
know that subsequently the trustee board
had posthumously tried to revoke her
diploma
so i thought oh well they're just all
pacifist socialists like jane adams no
wonder they invited me
and got up there and uh ran right into
the buzz saw so no i wasn't at all
prepared
for what i had to do was very
uncomfortable you can watch it on
youtube um to be booed and hissed by a
crowd and uh
you know at one point have people
actually climb up on the podium and try
and push me away and
and then be
attacked over and over you know hour
after hour
and yet you know someone said to me one
of my friends said well maybe you should
have like you know given the average
follow your dream speech or maybe you
should have tried to moderate it i got
about five or six letters from students
there who thanked me for what i was
doing and i always said you know what i
was really only talking to them uh
that's it everyone else i don't care
about so
uh i think i did the right thing um i
paid a price for it i mean nobody likes
to lose their job and i lost my pension
and
my medical benefits and all i paid a
price for that of course but um
you know
war is not an abstraction to me and and
and you know without being melodramatic
i've lost
friends in these conflicts
and i will go back there and i i want to
at least go back from these zones of
privilege and comfort that i live in
and be able to say that i did everything
in my power however futile it was
against these conflicts
and i hope that you know maybe i'll have
earned the right to ask for their
forgiveness
who is eunice my wife
you dedicate several of your books to
her and you've taken to writing it in
latin the dedication the
little
why is that
oh because i think it's
uh
um
it's beautiful latin poetry and um it's
a kind of
uh except for i suppose latinos it's a
kind of code between me and her
she's almost a co-author i have to admit
she's
um
she's an actor but she's a great writer
and everything i write is filtered
through her hands i mean there are pages
in empire of illusion that are basically
she wrote several pages
two harbors minnesota
sam go ahead with your question or
comment for chris hedges
yeah chris say uh
thank you for taking the call but i'm
i'm wondering if you have any opinion
about what corporate america has done to
the native american and our culture
you know the fact that they are all
living on
poverty-stricken reservations
and then on the other side they have
these multi-million dollar casinos that
they're running sometimes in some of the
states as well i wonder what your
opinion on that was
well it's the idea that gambling and
this is just outside of reservations but
i think within the country at large that
somehow gambling is a form of
development you see of course
a big push now to build casinos in
philadelphia i live in princeton so i'm
following that debate it's about an hour
away
and
this has worked for a few indian tribes
so there's an indian tribe in
connecticut that's for it's worked very
well for uh but like there's one casino
that nobody goes into on pine ridge pine
ridge is a pretty desolate bleak area
so
uh if you look at the totality of indian
casinos uh they've actually not been
particularly lucrative you you have a
few sort of sterling examples uh where
people have actually been able or tribes
have been able to make money
but pine ridges is a you know it's the
poorest second poorest county in the
united states
uh
uh at any one time 60 percent of the
people on pine ridge are living without
electricity and running water uh it is
it is really i mean it
you almost have a hard time believing
you're in america frankly
chris hedges mark peterson emails into
you i'm a great admirer of what you're
trying to do as a historical liberal i
find myself perplexed that passion i
feel for the ron paul candidacy
ron paul for me is a sort of funny guy
um
i mean says a lot of good stuff but for
me libertarianism is sort of a
pre-industrial ideology
the idea uh the government should be so
diminished
well i mean the problem is that
government is anemic in the face of
corporations like exxon mobil and
citibank and goldman sachs and bank of
america
and
we need to find leverage by which these
monopolies can be broken up and the
power of these corporations can be
curbed and so
i think ron paul is pretty good on in
terms of empire in terms of fiscal
responsibility
uh
in terms of
constitutional rights
but the core of his message
which is essentially the gut government
is one
that
i think isn't going to do anything to
diminish the power of the corporate
state
this is from peter eggenberger another
email your claims about the way the u.s
is run seems plausible but hasn't it
always been run along similar lines
since 1776 furthermore haven't elites
always run societies
yes and i think that one could argue
that
the battle for
american democracy has been one long
battle against those elites
uh that you know the the native
americans african-americans women
men without property none of these
people were invited to the
constitutional conventions
uh it became a battle to open up
american society and these radical
movements did that
so
uh
none of these radical movements achieve
political power
but they were
potent forces that the power elite had
to wreck with and i think the
destruction of those movements
has disempowered us i mean one could
argue that in april 1968
the most powerful political figure in
the united states was martin luther king
uh um johnson was scared to death of him
a year or before king had denounced the
vietnam war
and that's because when king went to
memphis 50 000 people went with him and
i think we have to rebuild those
movements for those of us who care about
democracy and care about justice it's
not our job to take power
uh you know julian bender wrote a really
great book
a french intellectual called the treason
of intellectuals and he said that you
know we have a choice in life
we can serve uh privilege and power
or we can serve justice and truth
and those of us who commit to serving
justice and truth the more we make
concessions
to those who serve privilege and power
the more we dilute the possibilities of
justice and truth and i think king
malcolm x frederick douglass
randolph-born jane adams eugene debs
mother jones you know all of these
people are figures that didn't make
those concessions uh and they never
achieved formal positions of power nor
frankly did they ever
strive to achieve formal positions of
power
but they defended the interests of the
dispossessed
this tweet from nyc 118 for you mr
hedges what do you think of oprah's role
in the culture and religious pursuit of
personal wealth
negative
um oprah peddles this fantasy that we
can have everything we want if we just
focus on happiness and
grasp that we are truly exceptional and
dig deep enough within ourselves
and this is just magical thinking
it's not just pedal by oprah i don't
want to pick on oprah
the christian right does it hollywood
does it corporate corporatism does it
tony robbins self-help gurus do it uh
and and it's just a myth and frankly
it's a myth that's used to beat up on
the poor so there are no jobs in camden
they used to make campbell's soup in
camden even that's gone everything's
gone
the schools are dysfunctional gigantic
dropout rate
the streets are unsafe
and to somehow tell a poor black child
who's not getting an adequate education
not being raised
in an environment that provides safety
and security and nurturing
and upon that uh being tossed out into a
city where there is no work that they
have to dig deep enough within
themselves uh is really a way for us to
turn our backs on the vulnerable and the
poor and to say you are responsible
this is what the called cultural
messages you are responsible for your
fate and that's just the way the
corporate state wants it as it sheds job
after job after job as larger and larger
segments of american society are reduced
to
uh subsistence level without any kind of
job security without any kind of
adequate health insurance
that it's sort of their fault
because they haven't managed to tap into
their inner strength
this is
not only delusional uh but
in the end i think callous
to the weak and the poor and and to the
working class
does campbell's have any presence left
in camden yes they have a they have a
kind of international office but it's a
completely gated community so you take
the train into camden you get on a
campbell's bus you go through
the gate um and you don't go out again
uh so they have a presence but they
don't make suit there anymore
glenn freeland michigan good afternoon
you're on book tv on c-span 2.
thanks very much mr hedges some people
now say the holocaust is a lie at the
time at least
some people
uh had the excuse of saying they didn't
know because there was no television and
internet and stuff like that now with
what's going on in syria you can see the
torture and the atrocities and all that
kind of thing and the peaceful
protesters they're they're carrying
signs that uh
save the uh old i guess it comes
primarily from the holocaust all it
takes is um for good people to do
nothing
and evil people will triumph for or
whatever exactly it is um i don't know
exactly what you should do but when you
see um some of this atrocious stuff
coming out of syria in particular and
some of these other arab nations going
on now don't you think we should be i
mean i'm not talking as some
uh um
trigger happy armchair warrior or
anything i was against the iraq war
what's your
don't you think there's something more
we could be doing um in situations like
syria now
well
i supported the intervention in bosnia
i was much more skeptical about the
intervention in libya
we became embroiled in a six-month-long
civil war in libya
hundreds of people thousands of people
perhaps died we don't know the actual
count
once you stop using cruise missiles and
sophisticated weaponry like that
you inevitably have civilian casualties
i think intervention in syria would
probably
not be quick or easy
and
in terms of loss of life
as we saw in libya may in fact drive up
the body count
the problem with syria as is the problem
with libya
is that they are sort of the ceausescus
of the middle east if you remember in
the revolutions in eastern europe
uh the polish
government
uh eventually uh
built a a
a a kind of coalition with solidarity
uh era connector in east germany and the
communist regime went down as it did in
czechoslovakia relatively peacefully
there was violence but not
uh
not as we saw in ceausescu where
ceausescu sent down
uh troops and murdered
thousands of people in timisoara which
is the city where the rebellion began
and i think in libya and syria we've
seen the same kind of recalcitrance on
the part of the regimes they're quite
happy to kill their own and it's it's
really tough to know how to respond
but i think libya is an example of
perhaps how we don't want to respond in
syria
you know
what we have to do is put as much
pressure as we can on the outside but i
think becoming embroiled in a syrian
civil war is not
astute
about 50 minutes left with this month's
in-depth guest chris hedges for what did
you win the pulitzer
it was i was part of a team of reporters
that won the pulitzer prize for our
coverage of al-qaeda and i was based in
paris and i covered al qaeda in europe
not in germany i don't speak german but
in
the rest of europe including
london britain and uh and the middle
east
and he is the author of nine non-fiction
books his most
recent book is the world as it is a
compilation of his columns from truth
dig and his newest book will be coming
out in june is that will that also be
published by the nation yes with joe
sacco who's done some amazing stuff
including footnotes in gaza to sorry in
queens new york you're on
happy new year
happy new year thank you for what you do
sir um i appreciate what you said about
men of privilege fighting for social
justice uh one such man uh mr john brown
uh who back in 1859 died along with his
six sons for the cause of freedom and
against slavery um uh fast forward a few
gen couple of generations and
argentinian doctor uh went to cuba to
fight also for freedom and i think in
today's world no matter where you are
what color your skin is we can all see
truth and we can all see injustice and
uh here in new york uh there's a stop
and frisk uh policy that plainly
violates the fourth amendment however
it's only brought against young poor
black and latino men and i think
whatever your color is
as human beings as americans we have to
stand up for the constitution or for the
spirit of the constitution the
declaration of independence that says
god gives rights to men that men cannot
take away and again thank you for what
you do and we would really appreciate
you to help you voice the stop and first
movement in new york city against a
violation of the fourth amendment
well i've already told carl dixon
cornell west the next time they go up
and get arrested
at a stop and frisk
event in harlem i'll join them so i i've
got a court date on
january 20th for my arrest
in front of goldman sachs so i want to
ration my quartets but after i go to
court i'll get arrested again was that
as part of the part of the occupy yes
cornell and i did a people's hearing of
goldman sachs in zuccotti park where we
had was broadcast live by wbai the
pacifica station in new york where we
had people who had lost their homes lost
their jobs
come and testify and then
several hundred of us marched to the
headquarters of goldman sachs and then a
group of us sat down and linked arms and
were arrested in front of goldman sachs
i don't know if you read your erstwhile
newspaper this morning or not or saw the
picture of zuccotti park
any reaction to the uh
to that picture and that story about the
park
it was it was barren and now they're
checking bags
right
well i mean the the the
foolishness of these corporate forces
they think that they can physically push
people out of these spaces and the
problems will go away
the problems aren't going to go away the
movement's not going to go away
and
how will it
manifest itself in the future i don't
know none of us know
but because they refuse to address
the core issues that have driven people
into public spaces around this country
hundreds of public spaces around this
country
because their only response is
essentially draconian forms of police
control
then
they're in for a really long fight and i
hope they lose
vince williard emails into you mr hedges
i have read empire of illusion three
times probably one of the most important
books that i've ever read i have read
death of the liberal class also an
excellent book dispels quite a few myths
of what it means to be a liberal my
question to you is this do you agree
with morris berman in his assessment
that america is a failed experiment and
that it will be necessary for the us to
collapse as a capitalist system for us
to move on
i would agree with morris in the sense
that we are
in the process of collapse
the looting of the u.s treasury i mean
the figures that are coming out that the
new york times reported the trillions of
dollars that have gone into wall street
uh
which they've used for these obscene
bonuses and
uh swelling corporate profits this is
our money
and it should have gone
to those people who are bearing the
price and the cost of their malfeasance
and it's not
the
unless there is a radical redirection uh
then i think that collapses
you know i'm too good a reporter to
predict the future but but collapse is
a possibility i mean let's look at the
banking crisis in europe and the euro
zone
hypothetically
we see a lot of uh
they're bleeding money
out of greece out of italy because they
don't trust the system well
countries like italy and greece are in a
terrible bind because if they go back to
their own currency
then
their banking system will go under
and uh in order to go back to their own
currency they'd have to shut down the
banks for a week or something and you
can be damn sure that by the time
depositors showed up at the bank windows
what they had in euros uh would never
equal what they were being given in
drachma lira
and the political ramifications of that
could be immense we still have a very
disturbing bubbling right wing
within countries throughout europe
and
i'm not saying that's going to happen
but it's certainly not beyond the realm
of possibility
uh the problem with the financial
meltdown of 2008 is that we never reform
the system
they're right back doing the same kind
of speculative
activity that they were engaged in
before and uh look in the 17th century
speculate speculation was a crime and
speculators were hung it was a capital
offense and now they run the government
and run the economy and we have no way
of controlling them
so it doesn't look good
because we've not addressed the core
problem and that is somehow that money
is real that we can destroy our
manufacturing base
and can make money by betting well we in
in 2008
17 trillion dollars mostly in in the
form of small holdings by people at
401ks and pension plans and money they'd
save for college vanished evaporated and
40 trillion dollars worldwide
and if speculators retain control of the
global economy then it's pretty certain
it's going to happen again
in your book empire of illusion 2009 the
end of literacy in the triumph of
spectacle
you have a chapter
where you visited las vegas for a month
or for for a while what chapter is that
on the porn industry and uh illusion of
love yeah
um
and i get very angry with the liberal
class on the left over their refusal to
condemn pornography
why is it morally indefensible to
physically
abuse a woman in a sweatshop in the
philippines
or in southern china
but somehow it's an issue of free speech
when it's done by the sex industry in
the united states
when i started interviewing these women
who came out of the porn industry
uh having suffered from post-traumatic
stress disorder
i instantly after literally a minute or
two said all these people are all have
ptsd
um and i wrote
i wrote it graphically
and brutally
and you know i think it intended to
engender a kind of disgust i never write
in the chapter we should or shouldn't
ban porn
i just said if you want to defend porn
then you better understand what it is
you're defending
these women and they're just thrown up
you know they last one or two years on
the sets and then uh you know if they
continue within the industry they just
in essence become call girls
shipped around the country and hotel
rooms aren't just awful
but
they're popping handfuls of painkillers
before they go on the sets this violence
which sells and porn is it's not the
soft lit porn of the playboy channel
anymore it's so-called gonzo porn uh the
violence is not simulated it's real
these women are black and blue by the
time they finish
they are constantly going in for surgery
for
anal and vaginal tears because they're
penetrated by
two three dozen men in the course of an
afternoon
knocked around abused insulted verbally
assaulted physically
and i was
as somebody who doesn't watch porn i was
pretty
blown away it was
really sick and i end the chapter
you know because the only emotion that
women on porn sets are allowed to
express is a craven desire to be
degraded physically and morally
physically and verbally and morally and
i end the chapter two ways talking about
these seven thousand five hundred dollar
silicone dolls uh which are anatomically
correct and people take home and buy
victoria's secret clothing for and
because in essence porn is really
finally about necrophilia and if you
look closely at the images of out of abu
ghraib they look all look like stills
from a porn film the pornification of
culture and especially the young
most of the viewers of porn
on the internet are between the ages of
about 13 and 18. um it's a completely
fortified culture uh and and i think
that um in this boy i stand with the
right wing on this i mean i think it is
a symptom of deep moral degeneracy
and
an utter failure on the part of the the
so-called liberal class to stand up for
the values it proports to a spouse it
won't take a stand against it we are
talking with chris hedges on in depth he
was just discussing his book from 2009
empire of illusion
our next call comes from john in las
vegas hi john
happy new year wonderful way to start
the new era listening to chris had his
very reasons and reasonable man but mr
hedges
i would imagine your life experience
especially as personified by your
appearance at rockwell must lead you to
the conclusion that no matter how bright
we are the man is not really a reasoning
creature but an emotional creature and
just uses his mind
to justify his prejudices and i think
the most perfect example of that your
former friend christopher hitchens i
mean for christopher hitchens
to look at henry kissinger and his
involvement in the assassination and
murder of the democratically elected
socialist salvador india in chile
and conclude that he is a war criminal
and then to look at the more egregious
behavior of george bush and his lying
within to iraq and the murder of
thousands of iraqis and the murder of
saddam hussein
and conclude he is not a war criminal in
the fact that christopher hitches would
totally belittle
anyone who remotely questioned
911 leads me to the conclusion that even
the sharpest mind can be dulled by
prejudice now we've lost that very
shocked mind
perhaps christopher hitchens had already
lost his mind before he died and i just
appreciate your comments
well
as somebody who has lived in
disintegrating societies
i would certainly agree that human
beings are not particularly rational
freud got this
in civilization and it's discontents
uh written on the eve of world war ii
where he talked about
two forces both within the individual
and within the society
one being that force of eros of love of
nurturing of protection
of life and the forces of thanatos the
death instinct that instinct to
annihilate all living things including
finally ourselves
and that these two forces are in eternal
conflict both within the individual
within societies at large and that whole
societies can be gripped by forces of
thanatos
i think the serbian society was at the
end of the war they giddily
sort of
embrace their own self-destruction and
death
i think if you look at the end of nazi
germany there's a wonderful movie
downfall that i think captures it this
german film on hitler's bunker it's
brilliant but it captures that kind of
having lived in those kinds of
environments it captures that kind of
intoxication with death and longing for
it
so uh
yeah i don't think human beings are
are rational
my struggles with hitchens
were that he
um
you know when he was on the left or the
right there was never any nuance for him
uh he he had been a former trotskyite
and he swung all the way over and became
a confidant of paul wolfowitz and the
neocons
and you know he bifurcated the world
into blacks and whites us and them and
um
uh unfortunately
you know that is uh
a vision of reality that the closer you
get to the ground just doesn't hold up
how would you describe your relationship
with mr hitchens over the years of
friends adversaries deeply antagonistic
deeply yeah
in your book war is a force that gives
us meaning you write that war finds its
meaning in death
the cause is built on the backs of
victims portrayed always as innocent the
dead become the standard bearers of the
cause and all causes feed off a steady
supply of corpses
mr hedges
what's the worst place you've ever been
or the worst situation you've ever been
in
there have been moments of course where
i thought it would be killed so i mean
but those were moments in terms of a
place it would be sarajevo because there
was no where to hide um
you sort of have to come out of the
military to understand what it was like
because you have to know the weapon
systems that were being used against us
155 howitzers 90 millimeter tank rounds
katusha rockets that are fired in bursts
of 12 or 24 and can take down a four or
five
story apartment building in a matter of
seconds killing everyone inside
this was the kind of heavy ordnance that
was being lobbed on top of us
24 hours a day
and a coupled with the sniper fire so
that that was it was like being in a
you know in a kind of
it was like being a rat in a cage i mean
you just you couldn't get out and you
were constantly being zapped and it had
the same kind of psychological effect
where it just ground you down
uh it was really
your nerves break i mean combat units
know this i mean you can't keep i think
it's uh they've done they did studies in
the military that
after 30 or 60 days of continuous combat
98
of the unit will have become
um
psychologically impaired and the two
percent that aren't were psychologically
impaired to begin with in other words
you know you stay that long in a
situation like that you inevitably go
insane which is why combat units are
rotated out of
conflict i mean you know courage is
never a constant um
despite all these john wayne movies um
and that was true sorry if it just
ground you down uh in a way that in el
salvador
you would go out into conflictive areas
but you came back to the relative safety
of the capital san salvador uh in
sarajevo there was no safe place to be
in your book i don't believe an atheist
also known as when atheism becomes
religion
the belief that we can achieve human
perfection that we can advance morally
is itself an evil it provides a cover
for criminality and abuse a
justification for murder it sanctifies
war murder and torture
for an unattainable absolute
yeah the idea that time is linear that's
peculiar to
both the hebrew and the
christian bible
uh
which was adopted by the enlightenment
the idea that you know we're we're
getting better and better uh that uh
human progress is inevitable
uh is a myth uh you know the greeks most
asian cultures see time a cyclical
that you have uh both within the
individual and within civilizations a
time of birth and maturation uh and
decay and decrepitude and death and i
think history bears that out i don't
think there's anything in human history
or human nature to justify the idea that
we are advancing morally as a species
that doesn't mean we don't make moral
advances we do but we also make moral
reverses and i think what we've done is
equate technological progress with moral
progress and that's very dangerous
that
that technology is is an instrument that
serves the ambitions of humankind but i
don't think human nature changes very
much and uh this
being lulled into this false belief that
science or technology will for instance
save us from global warming is is uh
essentially the modern equivalent to the
uh ancient religious sex that people
adopted uh as easter island was
decimated and
uh the environment
essentially destroyed to a point where
it no longer could sustain a human
population uh and i think we have to
wake up that uh there is nothing
inevitable about human progress uh
that it's far more important that we
face and confront reality and deal with
it uh
and if we don't if we keep this naive
belief in essence technology is sort of
serves
what in medieval times would have been
god
and unless we shake ourselves free from
that we're in very big trouble
in your book the world as it is the
creed of objectivity killed the news
and you quote molly ivan's in here and i
just want to read just a little bit of
that this is molly ivan's writing
i have heard many an editor say well
we're being attacked by both sides so we
must be right stems from the curious
notion that if you get a quote from both
sides preferably in an official position
you've done the job in the first place
most stories aren't two-sided they're
17-cited at least
in the second place it's of no help to
either the reader or the truth to quote
one side saying cat and the other side
saying dog while the truth is there's an
elephant crashing around there in the
bushes well she got it
um and that's why
programs like the daily show or colbert
are so popular because
uh they poke fun at this absurdity of
balance
where you get one lying pundit from the
right and one lying pundit from the
so-called left
and some cynical overpaid news celebrity
sitting in the middle
who knows that both are lying through
their teeth and refuse to say anything
and i think that that is
a kind of
betrayal of the viewer or the reader
that it's our job as journalists
insofar as we can to tell
the reader or the viewer the truth
however unpleasant that truth may be
and however it may cost us in terms of
popularity i think journalists are you
know if you go into that profession and
you're looking for popularity you're in
the wrong profession uh we should have a
kind of constant antagonism to power uh
whoever is in power i don't really care
where it comes from uh
you know figures like if stone or orwell
are sort of my heroes because of that
and these were not impartial people
these were not people who didn't have
strong opinions but but they understood
that the truth was sacred
uh and orwell liked stone they were
quite willing to anger uh their leftist
support i remember homage to catalonia
orwell's great memoir of the civil war
included a chapter where he was an
anarchist he was fighting with the poum
and uh
the the communists the communiter and
the stalinist came into barcelona and
gunned them all down and orwell put it
in and published the book while the war
was still going on it only sold 600
copies during his lifetime but it was
you know orwell said i just you know
the the the the power of the short-term
lie
is just not something i'm going to
engage in
and uh in the long term you know the
truth has to be told even if it
ostensibly hurts a cause and orwell was
shot almost killed on the argonne front
shot through the neck and wounded uh
fighting against the fascists and yet he
wouldn't he wouldn't lie on behalf of
the republicans and that really is the
gold standard uh so
these people were not in the way of of
sort of commercial journalism defined in
any way as objective or impartial
but they told the truth
chris hedges is our guest this month on
in depth we have about a half an hour
left frida in albany california thanks
for holding here on the air
oh thank you
mr hedges i'd like to know what your
thoughts are on slavery blacks in
america and reparations for
for the oppressed
the oppressed black population
i think something similar to the
marshall plan would be an order
well the civil rights movement was a
legal victory
but it was not a victory in the sense
that martin luther king and malcolm x
defined it uh because they knew that if
there was no economic justice there
could never be racial justice
and i think part of the power of the
occupy movement is that it picks up
where the civil rights movement left off
uh that economic justice is the only way
to finally overcome
racial injustice
that for the bottom two-thirds of
americans that the the civil rights
movement
pulled about a third of the
african-american community into the
middle class but remember if you look at
the statistics
uh now as the bottom is falling out on
the middle class it's african-american
families that are suffering
disproportionately even within the
middle class itself and i think one
could argue that for the bottom
two-thirds of african-americans in this
country things are worse than they were
when king marched in in memphis or
birmingham or selma and so
we as white americans have a special
responsibility because of the long night
of slavery the destruction of families
the destruction of religion the
destruction of language the destruction
of culture
even their names were taken from them in
the same way that germany has a kind of
eternal responsibility for what was done
to jews during the holocaust and we have
walked out on that responsibility the
best schools in this country should be
in cities like camden the most uh
intricate systems of familial and
especially childhood support and medical
care should be in the poorest aspects of
this country because these are people
who have had the least chance uh to go
anywhere and and one understands very
quickly when you spend times in places
places like roxbury or camden all of the
institutions that work to keep the poor
poor
rents in cities like camden are
staggeringly high
any kind of uh
ability to sustain yourself within the
informal economy which often revolves
either around i mean and families are
split you're either working for the
police or in the corrections system or
oftentimes you're on the street trying
to make money selling drugs uh the the
prison industrial complex and what it is
done to african americans as the great
poet uh yusuf kumanyaka has written uh
you know the the cell block has replaced
the auction block and that's part of the
reason i teach in a prison uh because
these people have had no chance and they
they know that when they get out and
they employ apply for a job even if they
can find a job to apply for they have to
check that box saying they were a felon
they're stigmatized that they can't vote
they can't get loans their credit rating
is destroyed uh and and you know i the
last time i taught there i i taught
american history what i did is bring in
copies of howard zinn's people's history
of the united states
which fortunately nobody in the prison
vetted
and taught it
when zinn is particularly conscious of
what african americans have suffered
throughout american history but i mean
there were days i just walked out
into the parking lot of prison and just
wept
because there were so many great minds
so many great kids who tend to be young
who wanted thirst for knowledge who
wanted a life
and
i understood but more importantly they
understood all of the walls that had
been built around to deny them that so i
think when you use the word reparations
i think yes
not in terms of maybe cash checks but in
terms of building social programs lyndon
johnson made a step towards this
towards bringing these people back in to
the embrace of the country as a whole
chris hedges is the author of nine
non-fiction books in 2002 war is a force
that gives us meaning came out what
every person should know about war in o3
losing moses on the freeway came out in
2005 american fascists 2006
when atheism becomes religion 2008
that's when collateral damage came out
as well empire of illusion 2009 the
best-selling death of the liberal class
in 2010 his most recent the world as it
is came out in 2011 and coming out in
june 2012 is days of destruction days of
revolt that i'm doing with the
great comic artist joe sacco so a lot of
it'll 50 pages will be illustrations and
comic panels
and uh if people want to read your
writing or read about you what's the
best website
uh truthdig i don't have a personal
website um and i don't tweet um why
oh
i'd rather read books uh i i think that
there are too many distractions
offered
these kind of virtual hallucinations uh
in order to think
you need quiet and solitude you can't
have anything in your ear and you can't
have somebody tweeting you
you know that they're going
to go at some point
at some point you will need to uh
develop your own website
no
i i don't uh
that's all about the culture of
self-promotion i think and um
it's something that i really want to
guard against i mean i don't have a
television uh i
i read i try and read every night for
you know two three four hours
putney vermont you're on with chris
hedges go ahead jack
hey uh chris you're amazing to listen to
you and richard wolf between the two of
you take up a lot of my time listening
um
i'm gonna pinpo i'm going toward the
environment there's i got a list here of
a million things and i can only have a
short time so
um
we're running out of time you know it i
know it the people that know it really
know it
we've been trying to tell them since the
70s the environmental scientists
first brought out the issue of uh it was
acid rain originally
um
the uh
progress is is pretty grim when you look
at what we just did down in
durban it's it's uh
almost criminal the response to the
united states in terms of not taking any
leadership and putting this thing off
when you have a
scientist around the world saying
we only have a short period of time here
to get going on this or we're going to
tip to the other side and not be able to
bring it back
somehow
and how are we going to do it we need to
take this from corporate and i bet
you're a marine were you a marine
no i spent time with the marines they
didn't they did they did make me boot i
will say colonel
which if you're a marine you'll know
what i'm talking about jack very quick
out of the 60s jack very quickly if you
could wrap this up
hi christian
antelope things and i'm looking at crazy
[ __ ] here on the wall that monument
they've they've black they've
they've yeah okay i'm wrapping it up
all right jack
tell you what we're going to do a lot of
comments there on the table and we'll
get an answer from mr hedges or a
comment from him as well well when we
talk about the giddy intoxication
uh with
with the death instinct i think the
uh
the self denial or self delusion around
global warming is
is terrifying because you you have two
responses equally self delusional one is
that it doesn't exist you had 50 members
of congress sign this thing when they
came in that global warming doesn't
exist or you have the self-delusion that
somehow we can adapt uh we'll just plant
palm trees and chicago kind of thing
and the fact is if we don't break the
back of the fossil fuel industry and
carbon emissions have gone up this last
year we're cooked we're finished i mean
even if we stopped all carbon emissions
today
temperatures would still rise by many
estimates to about
550 parts per million
350 parts per million being uh
what throughout the human history has
sustained the human species uh it is it
is uh you know the book uh
empire of illusion the subtext is that
the end of literacy and the triumph of
spectacle it is the triumph of spectacle
what are we our emotional and
intellectual energies are diverted to
what uh the the kardashian i can hardly
keep up with it the kardashians or
anthony weiner's
boxer shorts or uh i mean you know
it's just every week there's something
else uh
uh
and it's go back and read the end of
ancient rome cicero
uh you know in vain against the
uh the absurdities of
of a nero and of the coliseum and uh the
investment of emotional and intellectual
life into the arena uh and and look at
the entertainment industry the way
sports uh professional sports college
sports uh celebrity culture
has essentially
uh they flicker like the images on the
wall of plato's cave and and we're
unable to see uh that the world's on
fire and so i think the caller is right
that it really is that dire it really is
that serious
uh and yet uh
the culture of celebrity uh and the
culture of spectacle uh and the culture
of illusion is so powerful and is
disseminated in so many ways that were
anesthetized
a couple of related emails here this is
from paul appel and we have another one
here from shepard nakbar they're both
talking about their grandchildren
what is the most effective action an
older dispensable war vet can do to help
his grandkids have a better life that's
paul lapel
and then shepard asks
i want to give advice to my 13 year old
granddaughter what country should she be
thinking about emigrating to to live a
happier more moral and productive life
canada costa rica singapore norway other
well canada just walked away from
the kyoto accords
because of the uh
tar sands so i'm not sure canada anymore
um
i don't want to go anywhere uh i want to
save this country my family's been here
for a long time 1633
there's a lot that i love and care about
uh and i think it's worth fighting for
so get up and fight and uh and that's
gonna mean civil disobedience and it's
gonna mean the discomfort of being
arrested and i think many of for me the
really great moral voices wendell berry
being one
cornell west and others
have made this decision
that
you know wendell i think wendell berry
is about 77 beautiful poet writer moral
philosopher
and he went and occupied over the
destruction of the beloved appalachian
mountains in kentucky the governor's
office
and as he went in there he said you know
going to jails more time than i really
care to donate to the us government but
he did it
uh and i've been arrested here in
washington and new york and probably be
arrested again and uh it's it's not fun
uh uh
bill mckibben was here arrested in front
of the white house bill's another one
another person i respect a lot
and went to jail for 52 hours
and i think that's what we have to do
because
i'm i'm because of my background and
because of what i've seen and
experienced i'm deeply committed to
non-violence um
and i think that
in order to make a better world
uh we have to put our bodies on the line
peacefully respectfully
through acts of civil disobedience to
challenge what i think in theological
terms could be called
these corporate systems of death when
you're on the front line like that or
with somebody like cornell west well
known
are you treated with
a deference or are you treated
differently at all yeah people know who
you are yes i am treated with deference
and
uh when i was arrested in front of
goldman sachs everyone was cuffed in
front of the cameras except for i was
not cuffed
and the
police inspector was running the
operation told the patrolman not to cuff
me i did get cuffed but not in front of
the cameras i got escorted to a paddy
wagon then i got cuffed
that's public relations so i don't know
if that's deference or astute public
relations
it's phil marilyn please go ahead
thank you very much um mr
mr hedges i think your work is wonderful
you talked about the media and how they
don't like to intimidate the power
centers
but there is one story out in um in
foreign policy that is not covered and i
think is really terrible the united
states
supports a whole lot of dictators and
thugs some of which come back to haunt
the u.s
and i would think that there ought to be
a national conversation
is it in american interest to be
supporting all these dictators
well i think you saw that in the middle
east uh the way
the american government clung to pozney
mubarak until the last minute
deeply angered an egyptian population
that was looking for genuine democratic
reform
uh whose interests uh
you know are they promoting
uh they're not promoting the interests
of their people and they're certainly
not promoting the interests of genuine
democracy
and yet they're reliable allies
in the quote-unquote war and terror
and against
the rise of islamic fundamentalism or
islamic radicalism
but you know the war on terror has just
become the new mantra
in the way that we supported all sorts
of very heinous dictators in the war on
communism including
figures like chauchesko uh or samosa
nicaragua or pinochet in in chile and uh
you know it it it becomes a kind of very
simplistic way to deal with the world
and i think ultimately
in ways that are to our detriment
because uh standing up for human rights
i mean one of the things about being in
latin america during the carter
administration was uh that carter
actually tried to take human rights
seriously and uh uh alienated the junta
in argentina uh the military hunt in
bolivia where i was living at the time
somoza himself turned away weapon ships
and so the governments of latin america
were screaming uh sort of bloody murder
uh and announcing carter as a traitor
and yet when you walk through this only
time in my life really except for maybe
in the revolutions in eastern europe or
in iran which is on the street probably
the most pro-american country in the
world
then i go through the street and people
lauded me because i was an american and
i think that
determining foreign policy based on
commercial or corporate interests
is
not only morally wrong but misguided and
winning the hearts and minds of of the
populace itself is a far more effective
tactic but unfortunately foreign policy
is dominated by these interests and uh
both military force and diplomatic
policy largely sees itself as
uh
as
making host countries amenable to to
corporate domination
american hero tweets into you glad to
see someone looking at camden new jersey
it's like a city under occupation by
some outside forces referencing your
upcoming book this email from gary
hamill and stroudsburg pa
quick two-part question why is the
political right much more articulate and
effective than the left in communicating
their political philosophy to the
working class
well that's a good question uh and i
think it's because traditional liberals
in this society
are hypocrites uh they speak in that
kind of feel your pain language clinton
being a good example of that obama does
it too and yet
assiduously betray the interests of the
poor and working men and women
and that hypocrisy is not lost
on the working class and on the poor
they see it they understand it and it
enrages them and they have every right
to be enraged they have every right to
feel the trade and that's why
i think the occupy movement is an
important movement because it begins to
speak about issues of economic justice
and it holds the democratic party and
the traditional liberal establishment
accountable for
the
destruction of those forces that once
made it possible to be a working man and
woman in this country and live with some
kind of financial security and dignity
and
those people who present themselves as
liberals within the society uh
uh
are are essentially traitors to those
interests and that's why the right wing
captures that and mobilizes it because
frankly it's true
in death of the liberal class chris
hedges writes obama seduced by power and
prestige is more interested in courting
the corporate rich than in saving the
disenfranchised asked to name a business
executive he admires the president cited
frederick smith of fedex although smith
is a union busting republican
smith who was a member of yale's secret
skull and bone society along with george
w bush and john kerry served as senator
john mccain's finance chair during
mccain's failed run for the presidency
smith founded fedex in 1971 and the
company had more than 35 billion in
revenue in the fiscal year that ended
may 09. smith is rich and powerful but
there is no ethical system religious or
secular that would hold him up as a man
worthy of emulation such men build
fortunes and little monuments to
themselves off the pain and suffering of
people like somebody you referred to
earlier henderson
north platte nebraska and go ahead with
your question for chris hedges
yes mr hedges um you were truly a truth
fair
and
i have two things i'd like to throw out
there
one is that
i keep hoping it's not true
but i have come to believe that the
elections and voting is just an exercise
in futility
it's like theater
and it doesn't make a difference
and somehow rather we're supposed to
believe that it gives us a voice and
that by voting we can make a difference
and the other thing is that
um
i'm a disabled grandma who would love to
be part of the occupy movement
but in the heart of
ethanol country
there is no occupy movement
and
what can what could i do individually
um
without transportation
uh somehow to make a difference thank
you ann
i think it is political theater i think
that's the problem
all just about every campaign
promise that was made in 2008 by barack
obama whether it was filibustering
the fisa reform act or
closing guantanamo
restoring civil liberties he's failed us
upon
uh and that's why i think that this
movement and civil disobedience are the
only weapon we have left peaceful
nonviolent civil disobedience
uh you know it's not what we do with
life it's what we do with what life
gives us
and
you know we all have limitations and
struggles
you have
personal limitations and you shouldn't
beat up on yourself for what you can't
do
you do what you can uh we change the
world i think one person at a time
uh that's why
in the christian gospels the concern for
the neighbor is absolutely paramount
especially for the neighbor who is poor
dispossessed suffering
that's what the story of the good
samaritan is at its core it's about as
the person is left beaten on the side of
the road and i think it's within
your circle when you see that kind of
suffering uh reaching out uh in any way
that you can to ameliorate it
becomes
an act that
is not only one finally that
is about compassion and empathy
but i think in the state of affairs of
america even a political act
mr hedges who else is there to stop the
wars and the banks but ron paul if the
u.s lasts that long who are we to vote
for how it and i asked that in the sense
of how closely are you following iowa
and what do you think of the process
the whole process well i try not to
follow it i don't really care what newt
gingrich said or what mitt romney said
or i mean nobody's talking about issues
frankly
ron paul talks about issues but um for
the rest of it it's just vacuous
garbage for the most part and i just
don't want to fill my head with it
um
i mean the whole republican primary has
just been
sort of the march of the trolls uh you
know one troll replacing another week
after week i think we'll probably end up
with mitt romney who's as soulless as
barack obama and as as
captured to the interests of
corporations as obama is
i just i think there are aspects to ron
paul's ideology that i find
uh
disturbing uh i think that as a previous
caller mentioned there should be heavy
state intervention into impoverished
areas not only in our inner cities but
in rural enclaves
where poverty has become
tremendous
much of my own family comes from rural
areas of maine
food deserts supermarkets closed down
loss of employment tremendous suffering
and uh
i i
you know in that sense uh and a believer
of the you know i lived in switzerland
uh and i saw
uh
a state not certainly not in any way is
a perfect state but one where everybody
had health insurance where there was no
homeless now tax rates are very high 40
or 50 percent uh has one of the best
public education systems in the world
senior teachers aren't as much as
doctors um this is more towards the kind
of society that i would like to see us
build where we distribute our resources
so everyone has a chance look i spent a
lot of time with military units and
and the best military units never leave
their wounded or dead on the field uh
even corpses uh they still mean
something they're not just commodities
although their utility to the unit i
suppose could be argued is gone and i've
seen soldiers and marines crawl out and
bring these bodies back and these were
always the units with the highest morale
and the most effective fighting capacity
it's the units who left their wounded
and dead on the field and walked away
that rapidly disintegrated and i think
that's what we're doing as a nation
we need to rebuild that solidarity that
community
that sense that when you stumble and
fall i will reach down and help pick you
up uh if we're going to make it and i
think we have allowed corporate values
whether it's through reality television
i mean reality tv is essentially about
corporatism it's about the celebration
of values
that are in that are characteristic of
psychopaths
self-aggrandizement uh incapacity for
remorse or guilt
betrayal
one builds false friendships and then
betrays them
for what for fleeting fame and a little
money
and it's just writ large throughout the
whole culture and we have to begin to
question
our value system if we're if we're going
to make it and i think
one of the most important questions is
what are we going to do about all those
people that we've
turned or allowed to be treated like
human refuse
eric tremont emails into you from albany
california although my politics are far
to the right of mr hedges i do think
that death of the liberal class is a
very interesting book in particular the
book's blistering critique of higher
education resonated with me i am curious
was this critique prompted by mr hedge's
personal experience in trying to land a
job in academia
uh i've never tried to land a job in
academia i have taught as a visiting
professor at places like princeton
columbia new york university university
of toronto
um
although i will admit that i'm pretty
clear i probably would have great
difficulty landing a job in academia
no it was more prompted by my deep love
of the humanities
you know a belief that people need to be
taught not what to think but how to
think and understanding that true
intellectual activity is by its nature
subversive plato understood this it's
about questioning structures and
assumptions of the withering of the
liberal arts which frightens me uh you
know we see like university of albany
has budget cuts so it closes the
classics department it's foreign
language departments theater departments
and everybody is sort of trotted off
towards a major in economics the rise of
for-profit universities where they don't
even teach
humanities
this is i think very frightening because
it robs us of
a vocabulary and robs us of an ability
to to critique the systems around us and
we all end up uh serving systems we're
trained how to serve these systems which
is what happened in 2008 uh a figure
like lawrence summers
who had been the treasury secretary
under clinton came back to the obama
white house
it's about funneling these he sees this
the bubble implode and he funnels
uh hundreds of millions trillions of
dollars of taxpayer money to reinflate
that bubble because they only know how
to serve a dead system they don't know
how to critique it
el paso texas jack we have a few minutes
left please go ahead
oh okay thanks a lot uh fine program say
mr hedges you mentioned about campbell's
soup and camden
also rca victor yep they used to be
there more important wilt whitman
you know i know
he wrote a beautiful poem about the
opening of a public school
and howard hanson wrote a magnificent
oratorio to accompany the words
and it's very stirring because you said
that candy should have the best schools
well if well
they have one of the greatest poems by
one of our greatest poets and maybe if
you would get a chance you would
or are you familiar with it
not that poem i am familiar with whitman
and the
chapter on
uh
camden begins with a whitman poem and of
course joe and i visited his grave which
is in the cemetery in camden as well as
his house
g wesley altoona pa
as a journalist who has devoted much of
his work to the coverage and analysis of
war what do you make of carl von klaus
vitz's declaration that wars the
continuation of politics and what advice
would you give to a recent college
graduate i presume it's g
interested in working in print
journalism or foreign correspondence
well von clausewitz is wrong war is not
the continuation of politics by other
means
war is about the destruction of all
living systems economic political
familial
social communal
war is uh something very different from
politics
which is about compromise war is about
death the essence of war is death uh von
klausowitz is wrong
in terms of a future as a print
journalist it's really tough because the
monopoly that newspapers once had
connecting sellers with buyers is gone
and that monopoly has seen newsrooms
that once had hundreds of people
radically diminished papers like the
philadelphia inquirer that once had
seven 800 reporters and editors are now
down to about 200 this is being
replicated across the country uh it is
much more difficult for
a young person who begins as i did as a
freelance reporter because there just
aren't the outlets and the internet
doesn't pay
these commercial interests don't need
uh
news organizations to connect anymore
with potential consumers
and i think this means that
journalists like
actors
classical actors like my wife will
increasingly economically have to live
on the margins that that
period when you could get a job with a
major metropolitan daily and earn a
middle-class salary probably over
and from empire of illusion
the government stripped of any real
sovereignty provides little more than
technical expertise for elites and
corporations that lack moral restraints
and a concept of the common good
america has become a facade it has
become the greatest illusion in a
culture of illusions it represents a
power and a democratic ethic it does not
possess it seeks to perpetuate
prosperity by borrowing trillions of
dollars it can never repay the absurd
folly of trying to borrow our way out of
the worst economic collapse since the
30s is the cruelest of all the recent
tricks played on american citizens we
continue to place our faith in a phantom
economy one characterized by fraud and
lies which sustains the wealthiest 10
percent
that's chris
hedges writing in empire of illusion he
is the author of nine
non-fiction books and he has been our
guest for the last three hours here on
in depth very quickly here are his books
war is a force that gives us meaning
what every person should know about war
losing moses on the freeway american
fascists i don't believe in atheists
which is now when atheism becomes
religion
collateral damage came out in 08 empire
of illusion a bestseller in 09 another
bestseller death of the liberal class in
2010 and the world as it is in 2011.
mr hedges thank you for being on book
tv's in-depth program thanks for having
me
and thank you for joining us we wish you
a happy new year this program will
re-air tonight at midnight uh eastern
time uh new year midnight and then it
will re-air again next saturday at 9 00
a.m eastern time happy new year
and now on book tv a panel discussion of
william f buckley jr's book god and man
coming up next book tv presents
afterwards an hour-long program where we
invite guest hosts to interview authors
this week acclaimed sas and author alain
de baton and his latest release religion
for atheists
in his book he argues that rather than
mocking religion atheists and agnostics
should steal the best ideas from world
religions such as the methods for
building strong communities overcoming
envy and forging a connection to the
natural world
the philosopher essayist discusses his
concepts with former seminarian and
author chris hedges
ella i wanted to ask you first sort of
broadly about the vision that you put
forth in religion for atheists which is
a kind of
utopian sort of look at or or
restructuring or reformation of
secular society and i thought maybe just
sort of broadly you could lay out
some of the ideas in the book
i suppose my starting point is secular
society has not worked everything out in
other words once we reject religion if
we reject religion
we still have some gaps there are some
problems with the way secular society
runs
and it struck me that many of these gaps
could best be understood through the
prism of religion that we have
secularized i say in my book we've
secularized badly in the sense that
we've thrown out a lot of stuff
which was associated with religion
and which is now absent from
contemporary secular life but which we
would do well to revisit so what i do is
um look systematically through three
faiths christianity buddhism and judaism
asking myself always one question what
here might we use what here might
inspire is there stuff here that we've
left behind that we could in giving up
the doctrinal side of religion um
nevertheless have benefited from that's
my starting point and so i look at areas
like community education ethical
structure uh art and architecture the
notion of an institution which of course
the faiths are
and a few other things besides
and you have some sort of very specific
proposals
um
you know examples from religious life
that you essentially would like to see
secularized
and incorporated into the wider society
perhaps you can sort of expound upon
some of those sure well one of the areas
that i look at is education and it
strikes me that religions are in a way
giant educational machines
now in the secular world we take
education really seriously um
and a lot of money is devoted to
institutes of higher education
when people are trying to understand why
we educate um one answer is skills for
jobs for the economy you know to compete
to be a competitive economy that's
simple enough but there's another
more
noble sounding ambition which creeps in
during the more lyrical passages of
politician speeches or graduation
ceremonies and that's the idea that
education should be a source of guidance
that it should help you to live that it
should be
an education of your soul
it should help you to find meaning
consolation
ethical structure
in other words that's quite a religious
ambition and in my book what i do is i
trace it and i say that started in the
19th century as church attendance began
to collapse in many parts of western
europe people ask themselves the
question
how are we going to replace many of
these good things from religion ethics
structure meaning
and an influential group of people like
matthew arnold and john stuart mill
came up with what i think remains a
really intriguing idea they said culture
will replace scripture culture the
capital c the plays of shakespeare the
dialogues of plato the novels of jane
austen in these texts in these works
there are possibilities for replacing a
lot of the direction and ethics and
structure of
organized religions now i think it's an
intriguing idea it's also an idea that
has totally disappeared i mean if you
pitched up at a modern university say
you went to harvard or cambridge
university or oxford and you said you
know the reason i'm here is that i want
to learn how to live and die i want to
know what's good and bad i want to find
meaning i want to cope with my own
mortality you know the guys would be
dialing the number for the insane asylum
it's simply not an ambition that we're
allowed to bring to bear
upon secular education
and i think the reason for that is
there's an idea that basically people
are
once and once you're an adult you're
kind of together
you know you don't need particular help
um the business of life is simple you
you know you need to get married and
have a family and find a job you love
and watch your parents die and confront
your own mortality and then put yourself
in a coffin but basically all of that is
easy you kind of you kind of know how to
do it if you're an adult
and the only people who need help are
stupid people and they read self-help
books that's the kind of dominant
secular elite ideology so the idea of
relevance and assistance and didacticism
is absent now if you look at religion
religions start from a completely
different point of view their view is
we're all of us only just holding it
together we are desperate we are
vulnerable and we need assistance right
through every stage of life
we need wisdom
and i don't necessarily agree with the
wisdom that is on offer through
religions i agree intermittently but i'm
fascinated by the analysis of our
fragility i think that's fascinating and
true
truer than the secular model
and that leads me to think that if i was
the emperor of all space and time i
would want to re-jig
how
wisdom is transmitted down the
generations
i would argue that the humanities should
go back to that 19th century vision that
neo-religious vision of using culture a
scripture i think that remains a very
good idea
um sadly neglected so that's where i'd
be more than neglected probably
assaulted
if you look i i certainly within the
united states we now only have
a hundred thousand
college graduates a year majoring in any
branch of the humanities yeah all of
these institutions like harvard neo
began to train ministers
they made that transition the one you
referred to as expounded by arnold and
mill
uh but
you know
in major universities department's
philosophy departments are being shut
university of albany just shut down all
their foreign language departments their
classics department
um
in some ways didn't that experiment fail
yes i think the fault is i mean often
people say um
you know the world is crass and
materialistic and the fault for this is
you know governments or horrible donors
or stupid students you know etc i have
to say with respect the fault really
lies in the humanities themselves
that they have failed to properly make a
case for their importance their vision
of scholarship has unfortunately been
hijacked by
a sort of neo-scientific idea that
research is what matters
and that one can research you know
poetry like one can research a
scientific problem
and
this has put generations of students off
that the humanities have committed
suicide by
being so cut off from the questions i
mean it's extraordinary when you think
about it
there is enormous innate interest in the
question of how to live i mean it's
everywhere the idea that the humanities
departments have reached the stage where
they are so cut off from the spontaneous
curiosity of people that they're having
to shut down the problem lies with these
departments they have simply failed to
analyze the needs of their audiences and
to realize that the material they're
sitting on the culture they are sitting
on is a resource to live by
and that if they handled it like that uh
their departments would be opening
rather than closing this is harold
bloom's argument i don't know if you've
read any of his stuff on the western
canon
uh and of course he faults uh the
academic hierarchy itself yeah which i
think you're doing yeah they've brought
it upon themselves i feel sorry for them
many innocent people are you know being
sacrificed in the name of this corrupt
ideology but um you know we all know it
you know it there is appetite out there
for
knowledge wisdom
structured argument etc and yet weirdly
it goes on outside the university the
university has which should have been
the center it should have been our
monasteries it should have been the
place outside of the press of capitalism
where the best arguments could be made
and rehearsed and wisdom taught and
transferred that dream and it really is
a dream it's dream written into the
architecture of america's colleges for
the most part that dream has been
betrayed and they're paying a financial
price and while i'm sorry i can only
think they have brought it upon
themselves well bloom bloom would argue
that
for those who truly
grasp as you point out the importance of
art and literature there's no place for
them anymore within the university these
people have to exist outside the united
i think you would sort of agree with
that that's right um yeah the problem is
of course they are disorganized and then
weak and one of the things that religion
teaches us is if you want to get
something to have power in the world you
need to organize you need to
self-organize so you know the problem of
the lone
you know would-be academic in their
bedroom writing a book
you know it's much weaker
and if you look at how powerful
religions are it's because of their
capacity to organize themselves properly
and it was that mill and arnold's dream
was the secular world will organize
itself around the universities
it's failed to do that
and so you propose
to create
new institutions well i certainly
propose a method of rescuing our
existing ones uh
recreating departments along you know it
seems striking to me that the
departments in higher education all
reflect academic disciplines rather than
questions of the soul so you have a
literature department which is a
completely nonsensical category
really what a literature department is
is a literature of is a department of
human relationships that's really what
it's about so let's have the department
of human relationships less of the
department of loving and dying not the
department of anthropology or whatever
so the fact the academic discipline
comes first is part of the sickness of
the university it's part of putting the
cart before the horse
i want to talk a little bit about
institutions here i grew up in the
church and as i was telling you before
you're
although an atheist far kinder to the
institution than i would be
um
you
have a kind of healthy respect for
institutions
there is certainly a strain within
a christian thought that argues that
with constantine in the 3rd century the
rise of the christian church
did as much to pervert and distort and
deform the radical message of the gospel
as
uh perpetuated yeah
i think i think we have to be careful
because certainly the temper of the
modern world it's a protestant idea uh
is that the institution is corrupt that
true religion resides in the individual
heart and that any agglomeration of
people is is corrupt while that's no
doubt true at certain points
it's also true that we have to
understand what is good about
institutions which is that they're able
to agglomerate money power intelligence
and can simply have a reach that the
individual will never have so um you
know i'm aware that in the secular world
there are lots of people trying to
change the world by writing books right
writing a book is the dominant method
and we found atheists writing books to
attack religion for example so you know
dawkins hitches et cetera they want to
bring that bring religion down so what
do they do they write a book problem
about writing a book is that you're
using one instrument to deal with
something which is utterly unsuited to
being attacked by that instrument a book
can't do very much because what you're
dealing with with a religion is an
institution which is
a book of course books are central to
religions but religions are also
community centers uh educational
machines um travel agencies music halls
uh you know
they were involved in so many different
activities and to think that a book can
sort of sharply and sarcastically just
blow this whole thing up is is to
misunderstand what you're dealing with
and
as i say i think that
we're not short of very good ideas in a
secular humanist world the problem is
those ideas generally don't have
traction and they don't have traction
because they are not part of an
organized system so for example we have
lots of professors and people writing
wonderful books about ethics how to live
an ethical life lots of stuff um and yet
you know go outside in the streets of
new york now is it happening no why is
it not happening because there is not
that thing that religions are masters at
which is the union of theory and
practice that's what's fascinating to me
about religions they are unified uh
things so that they have a branch of
them sit some uh intellects in in a
corner and gets them to write the books
but then there's also a group of people
who will be producing wood cuts that can
be read by anyone or we're producing you
know advertising billboards now in the
modern world or building cathedrals and
and it's a kind of it's what the germans
would call a gesund kunstfer a total
work of art um it isn't work of art as
such but it has that element of totality
it's basically saying to people we're
not just trying to access you through
your brain through your reason through
you know your intellect we are going to
touch you at a variety of moments in the
day through a variety of media
and
the secular world doesn't seem to
recognize that you know we've got
advertising and
the luxury industries and um the
construction industry on one side and
then we've got you know the
intellectuals in in another what you
have to understand about religion it's a
union of those it's it's construction
and it's fashion and it's music and it's
the intellect all as one embedded
pushing one thing um and i think this
point is often missed to what extent
does the
consumer society and you talk in the
book about uh public relations and uh
selling i think you talk about them sort
of catering to people's needs but of
course what they're actually doing is
catering to their emotional deficiencies
that's right that's right i mean there's
always that classic distinction in greek
philosophy between needs and desires and
that to lead a good life you have to be
able to distinguish those appetites in
you which are legitimate and linked to
serious need from those which are vain
and flighty and and evanescent link to
your fugitive desires and that part of a
good life is knowing how to separate
that we've lost that sense
that we need help in doing that i mean
the consumer society is based on the
idea
that the individual can make up their
own choice the individual is robust they
can make the difference between needs
and desires maybe little children can't
so before seven o'clock or something you
maybe can't show a certain kind of
advert but basically adults will be able
to judge their true needs so you can
have a massive poster in front of them
saying go to thailand on holiday and be
happy and it won't have an effect at all
that's why we can have these posters of
course the advertising industry
recognizes that it does have an effect a
huge impact that's why advertising is a
business um
so but then of course the next logical
step is to ask well what are we doing
allowing a system to take place which
willingly confuses needs and desires
and therefore
um prevents us from possibly accessing
our best possibilities helps us to ruin
our lives
and religion is rather an interesting
kind of model because really what it
says is you do need advertising all
around but you need the right kind of
advertising you need reminders of how to
live well because we're permanently
being pulled in different directions and
that's how a lot of
organized religions function that they
they have billboards literally whether
that billboard is a cathedral or a
temple uh or or it could actually be a
billboard it's it's an attempt to say
you need some support the whole of
religious art is really an attempt to
support a set of ideas it's a kind of
propaganda it's a massive tool to
propagandize on behalf of some ideas
isn't it also a way to delineate space
between the sacred and the profane
um
yes
to create
an area where you will take time out
from your normal life in which the
values that are most close to your heart
and close to the truth can get a full uh
chance to express themselves this is
yes this is the sacred space this is the
cathedral the church the temple the
mosque you withdraw from the hub of the
city and you're back with your true self
um and again you see if i look at that
my first question is to say okay what
are we doing with that need now where's
that need gone now you know if this was
a serious need taken seriously by
religions for thousands of years where's
it gone what are we doing with it and
you know people would say well there's
the museum
to which well in my book i argue quite a
lot about why museums are not quite
doing their job properly so
there are many many ways in which stuff
that religions are quite aware of in
terms of our inner needs have gone
unattended in the secular world
there are certainly religious scholars
who would argue that and of
course religious systems are
created by humankind and oftentimes
serve
the interests
not so much of
uh religious tenants but for those who
run them the history of the catholic
church is a pretty sordid one
what about those
sort of critics who would say well
religion itself or institutional
religion
is uh to quote the theologian tylic
inherently demonic including the church
and that
oftentimes religious institutions serve
as much as an impediment towards the
capacity for transcendence or
transformation
um that that the religious impulse that
that those
uh those yearnings to describe
articulate and honor the non-rational
forces in life
beauty grief the struggle for our own
mortality all things that you've written
about um
that uh that one has to make a very
sharp distinction between the
institutions
and the religious impulse and in many
cases and you know i covered the war in
the form of yugoslavia
the religious institutions signed on for
the crusades of ethnic cleansing i mean
they were they they lent their they gave
a kind of sacred
authority
to murder
look um without wishing in any way to
underplay the terrible role of
institutions
we also have to accept that institutions
can make things possible that are not
possible when it's just the individual
and i think maybe to take the heat out
of the out of the argument it helps to
look at other areas other than religion
where many of the same things happen i
mean take the arts and the humanities
we've been discussing it um
you know the the university as a system
um has the same kind of relationship
between uh the spontaneous inner impulse
and the system so take take the impulse
to read poetry um you can read poetry on
your own and you can have some wonderful
feelings private feelings very pure
feelings
then you can go to an institution you
have a terrible time they'll corrupt
your understanding of poetry they'll get
involved in departmental struggles
they'll misappropriate funds they'll
abuse students they'll be sexual
scandals
and the institution will be horribly
kind of corrupt right so you have the
same kind of dichotomy the purity of the
individual response the the perversion
and corruption and violence and greed of
the institution this is not just a
religious issue this is a human issue
now how we to look at that
my answer is neither one is the perfect
answer that you need both and that both
can go wrong you can have the personal
response that goes wrong because it's
not properly guided because it has no
traction because it just
is too it's squeezed out by the
pressures of life so actually you don't
read the poetry your religious impasse
is squashed because you're watching
television you know or whatever so you
know let's not romanticize the
individual genius spontaneous you know
person on the hill who feels alone
and at the same time while respecting
the terribleness that can afflict all
institutions all you know businesses
churches uh et cetera um
they are nevertheless able at their best
moments to do extraordinary things like
build a cathedral like commission in a
box mass in b minor or heathrow's
terminal 5 or the airbus a380 you know
in other words when humans come together
to do big things
the result can be very impressive but of
course it can also be destructive so i
think we should stop being obsessed with
religion as an anomaly
in the corruption that afflicts it um it
is no more or less prey to corruption as
an institution than any other human
institution and if you look at the
history of you know general motors
compared to the history of the catholic
church now history of general motors
only going a few you know decades
but even in those decades you will find
just as much you know venality
corruption abuse um
terrible stuff in the history of general
motors as you will in a in a
representative chunk of the history of
the catholic church now spread the
history over hundreds of years and the
catholic church starts looking really
bad but it has been going for hundreds
of years so let's beware of um
romanticizing the individual and
demonizing the institution both have
their problems
although general motors i mean you could
say that you know it certainly embraces
the ideology of capitalism but it
doesn't
uh
and and you're right i mean you look
back certainly before the reformation
the the catholic church was a
totalitarian entity
which ruled as much through fear
and the threat of damnation
as anything else
that there was
a kind of power especially in
pre-literate
europe uh which the church certainly
abused but these were violent times and
you know compared to the power that
existed during in you know in in normal
government at that time i mean this was
a the violence ruled in families this
was an age when uh you know children
couldn't answer to their parents where
wives didn't exist as legal entities um
where the whole notion of being a
subject was not part of the common law
so i mean we're dealing with violence
right across the board and to say you
know the church in 1400 was a bastion of
intolerance you know that's to narrow i
mean i mean look i'm an atheist i don't
know i don't see why i should spend my
time defending the catholic church but
all i'm saying is let's set it i'm also
a historian and i know that you know
it's set in its context um
you know the average monastery was not
better or worse than the average uh
kingship so you know let's set that
these were violent days let me ask you
about you you quote spinoza you quote
nietzsche and at one point in the book
you
uh
talk about how difficult which of course
is true
uh radical intellectuals those
figures like spinoza or nietzsche who
challenge an entire system
superstructure the assumptions of an age
uh
both essentially cast out uh not only by
the institutions i mean espinoza was
tried and denounced as a heretic um
and you i wonder if those figures can
ever
be comfortable in any institution you
seem to propose that it's possible
well i you know reading about
nietzsche's life he longed for company
he looked back to ancient greece and
rome and the fellowship of philosophers
at that time epicurus and his garden
held a huge layer for him he wanted to
be he wanted to be part of a team
but he was living in 19th century europe
in the german university system which um
you know was even less tolerant than the
university system now but it's you know
along similar grounds they didn't
recognize that they had in their midst a
top quality thinker and didn't give him
a job would he have wanted a job he was
desperate for a job he didn't want to be
an outcast at the top of a mountain um
you know speaking his claims to an
audience of four
uh he wanted to be a professor at basel
university but he was kicked out so you
know we should be aware of interpreting
a romantic
view that um you know people like
nietzsche you know just wanted to be on
their own because it's it's nice to live
out of a suitcase roaming around europe
you know no um it's really great to be
the professor of x or y but you know so
long as you can say what you want to say
um and that's what nietzsche himself
dreamt of
oh that's true but i wonder whether
institutions
have ever embraced
thinkers who
have sort of dynamited
the entire superstructure on which
social political and economic
assumptions are based i mean marx would
be another example i i it again it gets
back to that sort of conflict between
individual morality as niebuhr rights no
institution can ever achieve the
morality of an individual because
finally institutions are always
concerned about their own perpetuation
and their own survival whereas an
individual is capable of making a choice
and sacrificing that sure but i think
you know there are institutions which
better or worse address the needs of the
individual and i think that's really
what interests me you know when i look
at we're talking about the humanities
and how they're not particularly
addressing the needs of their students
and that's why people don't want to
study there you know that's
people voting with their feet take
another institution like the world of
museums you know and you often hear it
said that nowadays
churches museums are our new churches
there are new cathedrals and what's
going on there what people are saying is
these are institutions where you will
find the same solemnity reverence and
enrichment for your soul as you might
have gone to religions for now when i
look at that i think well that's kind of
interesting good in theory and then i go
to the museum and i think
i'm not sure this is all going right
because i think again the museum has
fallen prey to a method of uh presenting
its art that is too cut off from the
lessons of religion religions use art in
a very simple way they use it as a way
of um
helping us to know how to live it's a
reminder religious art is a reminder of
how we should live an expression of
gratitude uh and a warning for you know
all sorts of ways in which we shouldn't
live
that sounds really odd when compared
with you know what might be going on at
the museum of modern art or whatever
we don't expect that art should
have much of an intention upon us that's
the modern curatorial system modern
curatorial system is put objects in a
white space um put a minimal caption and
you know get the crowds through but
really this is not revolutionary either
at the level of the individual or of
society general it exists in the world
of art and so writing my book i was
struck by the way in which
uh religions as institutions use art in
far more adventurous provocative ways
and it's just one example of how
i see
you know lessons that can be pulled out
of religion by a non-believer and
applied to try and get some of things in
the modern world to go a little bit
better and yet the renaissance was
a reaction to the restrictions placed
upon art i mean voted shelley chill it
on everyone else yes well i think what's
interesting about the renaissance is
that it it kept true to
the didactic ambition of religious art
and indeed roman and greek art because
roman greek art is exactly like
religious art it wants to guide you and
know how to live which has been an
anathema under
the church roman and greek art yes
absolutely but but that ambition that
art should be a guide to life is is
there both in christianity and in pagan
thought and it only disappears in the
19th century under that rather unhelpful
idea that art should be for art's sake
and the idea that the artist is alone
figure who creates works that are
ambiguous and so that the dominant
feeling you get leaving the museum is
what did that mean
you know or you know and the the
catalogue seems like it was translated
badly from the german in other words you
you're not quite sure what your response
should be that is the modernist elite
view of art art is an ambiguous
uh a medium and the more complex a work
of art the harder it will be to say what
that work of art is about but you know
religions you know take a rembrandt uh
painting like christ crossing the sea of
galilee it's a piece of propaganda it's
a very simple piece of propaganda it's a
propaganda on the part of on behalf of
courage basically you're supposed to
look at that and remember what courage
is
and it's very complex as a work of art
in terms of its technical formal
qualities but it's very simple at the
level of its moral
and
that's uh
that's a situation that we have a hard
time accepting in the modern world you
know how could something both be really
simple morally and get really
complicated and some noble
as a work of art we we expect that you
know that's not going to be the case
although secular artists did it picasso
with guernica goya yep
yes i mean absolutely you see some
artists and the greatest artists i think
absolutely have that i think the problem
weirdly is not the artists
it's the system in which they operate
you know mark rothko take mark rothko um
fascinating artists very didactic
impulses
i remember going to see rothko's
paintings at the tate gallery in london
as a teenager thinking i wonder what
this is about wonder what it's for i can
sense a mood and it's kind of powerful
but i looked at the caption and it just
said mark rothko american abstract
expressionist born in died in i didn't
really know what it was all about read
some books on him didn't really get a
sense and then years years later i read
an interview with him which the
interview said what are you trying to do
with your art and he said i want my art
to be a place where the sadness that is
common to all of us can find a refuge
and a focus i thought wow that's that's
pretty simple you could write that on a
postcard do i do i ever see that on the
museum caption no i mean anything but
and you find that with a lot of artists
you know you know if you said to picasso
what are you doing with gwennica he
would say i'm trying to stop war i'm
trying to get people to be nice to each
other but when you go to the picasso
museum is that ever stated no picasso
was influenced by this and the influence
so in other words that very simple
didactic ambition of the artist has been
drained out of it
by the curatorial system so i say that
the museum world does to the visible to
visible culture what the academic world
does to written culture which is namely
drain it of its revolutionary
therapeutic didactic possibilities
i would have to add that that's what
religious institutions
due to religion interesting interesting
um
perhaps because i'm an atheist
i don't notice that as much
i'm more impressed by the aspects of
religion which seem only to be possible
through
a collective action but you know i defer
to you in this area strikes me that what
and it's also
an admiration that i share
that what
moves you
is not always so much the institution
but the ritual yes
and and rituals are designed to create
sacred space
they are designed uh
to
uh
honor a reality that goes beyond
articulation
they are designed and i think as this is
also something you raise in the book
they are designed to put human beings in
their place within the cosmos
and
and that of course is the power there
there is uh
um
something brilliant about the eucharist
and the mass i mean the way i look at it
is the ritual is a communal event
it it a ritual is something that that a
number of people do
that has an impact on the inner self and
again in the modern world we imagine
that things that happen in your inner
self come spontaneously or with
communion with with
one book
or maybe one artwork in other words
there's the group doesn't touch your
soul
um and i think what's fascinating about
ritual is that it it it's precisely an
attempt to say
um left to your own devices solely
there are things that you're not going
to get to so we need you know you're not
gonna forgive people without yom kippur
uh you're not gonna look at the moon
without the zen buddhist festival of
tsukimi uh you're not gonna properly
forgive uh people without you know the
jewish ritual of plunging yourself in a
mcfare or whatever that there are these
communal rituals which are going to have
to take place
otherwise
your soul will be will be in trouble and
i'm deeply impressed by this um
chiefly because
subjectively i know there's so much that
i feel and want to do that i don't do
because there is no
communal structure and when people say
yeah but you know the world you know us
atheists we're brilliant at inventing
things and i've had that people say that
to me and i said oh really great what is
it and they go what we've got birthday
parties and i go come on the birthday
party go yeah you know i went to a 50th
it was great people read poems and
whatever and okay what's wrong with of
course there are secular rituals but
they tend not to be structured properly
they tend not to be psychologically rich
you know take something like um father's
day or mother's day which
is a secular ritual has obviously a
religious antecedent but it's a
typically modern secular rather stupid
ritual the reason it's stupid is that it
fails to recognize the number one thing
which is that we don't only love our
mothers or fathers we also hate them
they've let us down in all sorts of ways
that the relationship between parent and
child is conflicted and by having a
moment which only honors the positive
it actually makes
a true relationship impossible so a more
intelligent
relationship but more intentional ritual
would start by saying that relationship
is conflicted so we need the ritual to
accept that and that's what's clever
about things like well things like the
bar mitzvah the bar mitzvah if you
follow a bar mitzvah ceremony it's full
of acknowledging the fact that the
parents are sad that the kid is growing
up
it's basically saying
the kid is murdering the father right
this is a ritual murder of the father as
the next generation grows up so beneath
the festivities and the balloons and the
party and the presents what you've got
is an intergenerational you know murder
and but it's healed and it's held
together and it's done intelligently and
so that for me is the genius of
religious ritual well it expresses and i
you i think point this out at the
beginning of the book
a fundamental truth about existence
in the same way that the greek myths
understood psychological truths it's why
freud kept going back to greek myths and
shakespeare yeah
and uh
and i think that i think i'm certainly
in complete agreement with you that uh
to ask the question is this literally
true
is absurd from the beginning because
even biblical literalists are
selectively
you know uh they're selective
literalists they they pick and choose
what they want um the
innumerable contradictions even within
the four gospels uh you know on all
sorts of issues and i think it's also
it's leaving the individual with so much
pressure to assume that we as
individuals can
do all the stuff we need to do just by
ourselves you know um i was struck in
reading the history of religions is
there's always in all religions a
festival of chaos a moment when the
world is turned upside down when power
relations are reversed when sexual
relations are reversed and when in a
sense all the craziness all our
perverse impulses a given room
for exp for expression um and you know
whether it's carnival or you know the
feast of fools or in ancient greece the
festival of dionysus um or whatever it's
a moment in the calendar where the
darkness is allowed to come out into the
light and is regulating that's what
that's what fascinates nietzsche in in
the festival of dionysus that it's both
chaos and structure it's that wonderful
mixture and in the modern world what do
we do when we get drunk on a saturday
night and beat someone up or break a car
or something it's very
dis uncoordinated or we have an affair
and you know
it's it's it's left up to the individual
it's not coded it's not lent dignity
it's not seen as something that we all
labor with so the individual comes to
their own realization oh i've got
unfaithful impulses or oh i've got
violent impulses or oh i want to punch
my boss and and and this is seen as a
private realization against the backdrop
of a kind of sunny optimistic version
vision of man religions are much kinder
to us in saying of course this stuff's
going to be in you so we're going to try
and structure it we're going to give it
a bit of a place in in the world well it
acknowledges the dark impulses right
within humankind which of course in the
happy
cheerful positive psychology world of
modernity is completely denied right
which is what i mean what i love about
uh all the faiths is their pessimism you
know christian pessimism is wonderful
you know whether it's pascal or uh you
know in judaism you know the book of job
or uh buddhist texts that again speak of
the unarguable you know misery of
the grasping of human nature these
things are incredibly important to read
precisely because we live in this sunny
world where the assumption is that
children are normal creatures rather
than half crazy beasts and that all of
us are mature you know sensible people
just looking forward to the next
vacation rather than people who are
torn apart by serious darkness and i
love reading christian and other you
know jewish dark texts precisely because
um i think oh i'm not alone here you
know there's some you know this has been
it's also very dignified there's you
know the prose or the poetry is
beautiful the language is beautiful so
it expresses those most private
inarticulate sides of ourselves raises
them out of the darkness places them
before us and makes us feel less lonely
with some of the most unacceptable stuff
that you know resides in the human soul
well there was no division between art
and religion when it began that's right
and and i think there should be no
longer a division between art and what i
call psychology
the psyche that that division that that
art served the needs of the soul
directly with no it didn't exist in up
the art world it was just it was part of
ethics it was part of
living um whereas we've we've put it
seriously in a corner and we almost
don't recognize how much we put it in a
corner but it's not it's not in the
service of life
and yet
uh you know both of us love proust
proust certainly for me gave me a
language
gave me a vocabulary to describe aspects
of human reality that i had not had
before i read proof absolutely but you
know it's not the artist the artists are
doing a fine job it's the way they're
presented i mean i read a book a few
years ago on proust how proust can
change your life and that got me
excommunicated from the university i was
in
uh the the feeling was this is not a
serious man if he has written a book or
how bruce can change your life we don't
want him here he has written a self-help
book and i was happy to go because i
thought we're not seeing eye to eye here
but it's symptomatic it's not proof
that's the problem it's the structure
that we place around bruce everything
all works of culture should be how x can
change your life how picasso can change
your life how mondriyan can change your
life you know
that's a method um that we've lost at
our peril but more importantly it's why
they wrote it i mean the last book and a
half of proust is one depth charge after
another absolutely this is a man looking
for the meaning of life and defining
if you like a quasi-religious path to
redemption and and and he who knew a lot
about religion is precisely following
you know
absolutely
um
you have some sort of specific ideas
um i want to ask you about travel agents
and i mean i don't need to list them
agape restaurants but maybe you can sort
of spell some of them out well one of
the things i do in my book um
is provoke the reader into thinking look
what i'm telling you here is not merely
a set of ideas i'm trying to imagine how
we might tweak the world and change the
world with the help of
certain of these concepts that we've
been discussing why do i do that i think
there's sort of an assumption that
practice is in one area and books are in
another and the books shouldn't suggest
practices
and because i'm writing about religion
which are all about the union of
practice and theory
it seemed exciting and interesting to uh
look at that so for example i'm thinking
about perspective and or all the major
faiths are interested in the feeling of
awe
they realize that if you put somebody in
a space where they see how small a human
occupies
um someone being as how small a human
being occupies in the vastness of space
or time
there will be
a kind of quietening of their soul their
anxiety
their pressure to succeed and their ego
driven impulses that will abate under
the night sky
in a cathedral
in a grand canyon wherever it is you
will have a certain kind of feeling a
stilling of the ego the or
the feeling of all um so i try and think
okay religions are unparalleled at doing
this they do this all the time and
they're really great where do we do this
you know and people say okay we do go to
the grand canyon etc but i try and
imagine structuring it a bit more the
stars and astronomy is a vital source of
awe problem is when you go to a science
museum they'll they'll treat you like
you're a scientist they're not they
don't treat you like you're looking for
ore
they look treat you like you're you know
about to work for nasa and are seriously
interested in the details of the g102
galaxy you know three million light
years away you're not most of us are not
we're looking to use
science or scientific material as our
religious forebearers did in other words
as a source of ore but the modern museum
doesn't allow that so i try and imagine
a space where we might go that maybe
maybe a little bit like a planetarium or
a little bit like a science museum
where the point would not be to learn
learn about science it would be to look
at scientific phenomena for that feeling
of awe and its benefits that it can
bring i even playfully imagine that
these giant screens in times square that
are currently displaying the stock
market data would every now and then get
a live feed from the hubble telescope
that surrounds the earth and so that as
you're walking along uh you know mired
in the human ant hill you would look up
and you would see some of these galaxies
and nebulae um and suddenly everything
would uh would change rather as it
changes when you see the towers uh uh
and spires of sharks cathedral across an
open field in in northern france that
same kind of impact that same collision
of your daily self with something you
know public so yeah if anyone who's
owning those uh
those screens in times square is
watching let's let's plug them into the
hubble
and talk a little bit about the you you
have
you talk about travel you talk about
yeah communal restaurants
um
i'm interested in the travel business
because um travel is seen by religions
as an absolutely fundamental part of a
spiritual life
and that's interesting you know because
we travel a lot as well so you think
okay what what did they do and what do
we do you're talking about pilgrimages
yes pilgrimage exactly um
what is a pilgrimage a pilgrimage has
many things but it's it's really an
attempt to use a journey to help your
soul
uh and we kind of have an impulse in
that you say okay well i'm gonna go on a
journey to try and do something but
we're very unstructured about it we
don't really connect our destinations
with our inner needs the the real if you
look at the so-called travel pages of
newspapers
the dilemma is always how do i find the
hotel or how do i get a cheaper rate on
something the real question of travel is
how do i match
the outer world with some evolution in
the inner world that's what religion
that's how religion uses travel so i try
and imagine what a travel agency might
be like that have properly studied
religion and it's playful suggestion but
it's a real suggestion like many of my
suggestions and and really what you
would do is you would have
like you used to do in medieval
christianity before setting out on a
pilgrimage you would visit a priest and
you would discuss the state of your soul
and the priest would guide you to a
destination
he would literally have a map or a book
of destinations around europe and and
your inner life and your outer
destination would be matched plenty
there for the modern travel agent
and you might walk because again as
religions understand often the ease of
getting there undermines the capacity of
a journey to affect a change in us there
is in difficulty
a
metaphor for an inner difficulty and so
by removing all outer difficulties you
undermine our willingness to endure an
inner difficulty to change so
and the other problem is that people
leap having lived for 20 years in the
developing world
from uh
you know a cloistered
industrial invert to to a replication of
that yeah in a resort i mean in fact
they don't travel at all really yeah
orwell wrote an essay about this once
yeah they don't travel at all and um and
they're they're genuine rather touching
ambitions that they do you know people
want serious things from their travel
they they travel in order to find
themselves in order to improve a
relationship in order to discover their
children in order to
understand the world these are really
really serious ambitions and yet how
often travel goes wrong you know because
these serious ambitions are not taken
seriously by the travel industry well
and it's the cruelty of marketing
absolutely where we can be so easily
dissuaded where these noble impulses can
be you know taken taken from life
yeah you know that's going off to a club
med and it's gonna be commuters gonna
that's right that's right so that's
that's another area um
i also look at the area of community and
it strikes me that one of the things
religions are brilliant at doing is
bringing a group of strangers together
in an extraordinary accomplished
beautiful space and through certain
basic actions basically introduce
themselves they act as hosts and just
like a host at a party will break the
ice and allow people to release their
humanity and curiosity so a religious
host
does that with you know the group of
congregants
we've lost that ability a city a modern
city like new york or anywhere is full
of bars and restaurants but these are
corrupt visions these are not communal
spaces they are simulacra of of of
communities no one really talks to
anyone or only in slightly haphazard
ways
there is we lack any systematic
mechanisms for turning the stranger into
a friend which is so core to all
religions all religions have the table
at which the stranger can come and can
eat and break bread
these are wonderful traditions
we spend so much time worrying about
restaurants and the quality of the you
know tomatoes there and you know it's
nonsense compared to the real ambition
of the table and i suggest in my book
you know let's get some tables but you
know it doesn't really matter what
you're going to eat the point is
friendship and community and that
ancient religious originally religious
ideal of breaking bread with a stranger
you don't talk about theater in the book
classical theater and i'm wondering uh
especially having lived in new york
after 9 11
and the whole build up to the iraq war
the the one institution
that sought to remind us of the horror
of war was not in fact the church
which pretty much signed on for the war
as an institution but theater um and
there were
numerous productions uh suffolk women i
mean all sorts of great stuff that were
done and theater itself has a kind of
sacred quality it gives it
it
you know in some kind of way almost
brings back to life our the past our
ancestors
it has a communal quality it has a
ritual i just wondered what your
thoughts were um
i accept all of that if i were to
criticize theater and a lot and in
relation to religion um certain
religious communal rituals have elements
of theater you know a mass etc but it's
not simply what um uh that theorists i
think it was uh bourdieu called the
society of the spectacle um no it wasn't
but it was kind of uh it got guy dubois
it's dubois
wisely called the society of the
spectacle um he criticized modern
culture
for extraordinary things happening on
the stage and all of us there like this
and he critic he compared this with
religious and pre-modern societies where
there's extraordinary stuff going on
stage and that has an impact on the
audience and you leave transformed and
with an energy to transform and i've
been in so many plays
wonderful moving plays where
the audience is wrapped and the audience
is ready to go anywhere that the play
has taken them anywhere we are in
ecstasy we are in a state of ecstasy and
we are in the hands of those actors
and then the curtain comes down and we
go and buy an ice cream and head out for
a taxi and go home
and that's it the whole thing
the energy that was in that theater that
could have transformed the world
it dissipates
and so um
you know i i look back to a more radical
theatrical tradition you know of brecht
and you know there are others who've
thought about this that theater should
not just exist in the playhouse that it
should maybe start in the playhouse but
that it's for you know everyone and that
tradition looked very much to religion
as an integration of
spectacle and public engagement
and and yet in times of
repression
and i covered pinochet's chile
art
and theater uh i mean the two major
institutions that stood up to pinochet
were actually the church in the theater
i think i think you're right i mean
people do walk out and are sort of
anesthetized
but that's because of the sort of uh the
culture that's upon them once
everything's stripped down i mean susan
sontag
went to sarajevo while i was being
shelled and surrounded and did waiting
for godot and that has a power to speak
when when ev when all of those false
comforts are gone
i think often times the inability to
hear and see as you point out
is
uh
is the narcotic of well i think it comes
back to this idea of how seriously we
should take works of art and there's
this assumption that even though we pay
reverence to art and arts so important
etc we don't really want to allow it to
transform things
and whenever a very powerful work comes
along
just the way in which i don't know
there's just this um you don't wouldn't
one wouldn't want to call it a
conspiracy but it almost feels like a
conspiracy to to strip it of its truly
transformational uh power as i said you
know we all know films or plays you've
come out and you think i want to change
my life you know this piece of work has
urged upon me an agenda that is so
different from everything around but the
problem is that by lunchtime the next
day you've kind of forgotten it and you
know by the next weekend
it's it's gone and there's something new
at the at the theater and uh you know
and and that's it so we don't have
follow-through and again to look at
religions religions are all about
circling they're saying
you know there were these insights there
were these powerful insights so we're
going to go back to them because you
know you knew them on sunday but you'll
forget them by next saturday so we're
going to go back to them and um
modern culture
it's almost like can't take its own high
points seriously enough it undermines
itself and this constant search for the
new the new is great because you keep on
good things in the new but this this
sort of um
this neglect of repetition and rehearsal
seriously undermines the capacity of any
one work of art to really affect change
when you have
as you certainly do with judaism and
christianity
systems of thought that were written by
an oppressed class
to what extent
uh
is that theology aimed for the oppressed
um
i i was in a refugee camp in the war in
el salvador and they were decorating the
camp
for uh the day of the innocence which
and i knew the story i heard my father
reading the pulpit
and i asked one of the refugees why it
was such an important holiday and they
said because on this day
jesus became a refugee jesus had fled
with mary and joseph to egypt
and
before herod came and killed the
children
and i who had heard the story from a
position of privilege in some
fundamental level had although i could
recite it verbatim didn't understand it
and i'm wondering uh you know if you
look at the antebellum south
you had two strains of the christian
religion you had black the black church
and you had the white slave holding
church which used the bible of course to
defend slavery
uh and uh i think there's a theologian
james cohen has made a pretty strong
argument that uh in many ways he
actually calls the white church and not
just the antebellum church but the white
church
he calls it the antichrist
because and he talks a lot about
lynching as sort of our modern cross uh
and i just wanted to you know as we
close if you could address that issue
that issue of justice that issue of
oppression and to what extent finally
religion
you know or religious theological
systems in some ways pro may not have
been written for people like you and me
well look i think there's something
immensely important in a message which
is there in all the major faiths which
is a defense
of the vulnerable the weak
the child
the dispossessed
and more broadly the self that exists
outside of power money and status all
religions are
at their purest on the side of
that in a way on the side of the um the
status person
um
the secular world is a winner society
you know we live in capitalism
capitalism rewards productivity and
economic merit and demonstrable economic
success this is an immensely punishing
ideology
that leads to madness at its most
extreme because only a fraction of the
members of this planet and even the
members of the united states can ever
live up to that ideology
under that ideology
a huge portion of the world citizens and
american citizens are losers
and
that can't be right and where do the
losers go what what ideology is it that
has led half the population to be
defined as a loser this can't be the
right philosophy
and what religions have very cleverly
intelligently done is to say no that's
the wrong ideology that what matters is
not power and status and the possession
of vast castles but the inner self the
inner being the stuff that a parent
would love in a child
that
outside of power relationships when we
love outside of power relationships what
we love in people is the pure person and
that that's what matters and in
different forms that's what all the
religions say
love the powerless love the child love
the weak person love the mortal self
not vanity not power etc and we need
that voice desperately and what saddens
me is that um it's really only the
faiths that put forward that voice
articulately it used to be put forward
by marxism and by the left
unfortunately the left was discredited
by all sorts of economic positions and
it failed to capitalize on really what
was its richest area which was its
emotional analysis of what we need by
focusing itself as a scientific economic
cure to the ills of mankind it fatally
shot itself in the foot so we're now in
a world where there's capitalism on the
one hand and faith-based organizations
on the other and what gives the
faith-based organization such strength
is that capitalism labels so many people
losers
i think
as the absolute ruler of the world if
ever i were i would say what we need is
a non-faith-based ideology which
recognizes the dignity and humanity of
the vulnerable and the weak and the
child
all right well thank you very much thank
you so much
tails go to studentcam.org
up next a forum on the occupy movement
that began in 2011 from the
massachusetts institute of technology
this is an hour and a half
[Applause]
thanks very much for everyone for coming
and thanks to the boston review and to
the department of political science
so today uh we have four uh renowned
panelists i'm going to start off by
introducing them all and then they're
each going to speak for 10 minutes and
then we'll have a bit of discussion
between them and then we'll move to
audience discussion okay so first
deborah satz is the marta marta sutton
weeks professor of ethics and society at
stanford university
she's also the senior associate dean for
the humanities and arts
she is a
member of the philosophy department and
director of the mccoy family center for
ethics in society who and her research
focuses on the ethical limits of the
markets the place of equality and a just
society and theories of rational choice
debra also works on feminist philosophy
ethics and education and issues of
international justice she's co-editor of
the forthcoming collection occupy the
future
nadine mason is a graduate of mit and an
early participant in occupy boston he's
also a small business owner ceo of
nimblebot.com a boston-based interactive
marketing boutique specializing in web
apps and design and co-founder of danger
awesome a laser cutting workshop and
community arts storefront in cambridge
actually just in central square
mazing continues to be engaged in
outspoken protests against
government-sanctioned human rights
abuses malfeasance and finest finance
industry
mismanagement
next is phil thompson actually phil is
on the end
uh associate professor and i'm i'm
giving their introductions in the order
they will speak
uh phil thompson is associate professor
in mit's department of urban studies and
is an urban planner and political
scientist
phil worked as deputy general manager of
the new york housing authority
and as director of the mayor's office of
housing coordination he's a frequent
adviser to trade unions in their efforts
to work with immigrant and community
groups across the united states
he's the author of double trouble black
mayors black communities in the struggle
for deep democracy and is currently
writing a book on community building and
development since the
1960s
finally chris hedges was awarded a 2002
pulitzer prize as part of a new york
times team of reporters who covered
global terrorism he spent almost two
decades as a forest foreign
correspondent first in latin america and
later as the new york times bureau chief
in the middle east
he's the author of many books including
days of destruction days of revolt war
is a force that gives us meaning and the
best-selling american fascists he is
currently a columnist for truthdig and a
senior fellow at the nation institute
so welcome all of our panelists and
let's start with deborah
thanks
thanks to boston review for organizing
this event
and i'm happy to be here so i'm going to
talk a little bit about the occupy
movement
the role of the research that the
stanford faculty engaged in i'll talk a
little bit about that connected to
occupy and then i'll talk about
what i think occupy accomplished and the
future
i think that that as a guiding question
we can ask um what were the roots of the
occupy movement and how far did it go is
it and is it continuing to go in writing
the injustices that uh gave rise to it
so sorry yes you were right
let that be yes that's a theme
okay so um from its beginnings in
zuccotti park in 2011 the occupy
movement consistently raised awareness
of the glaring inequalities that now
characterize american society and
galvanized forms of public response
a series of largely uncoordinated
sit-ins teach-ins and protests were held
and citizens came together under a
capacious and inspired banner we are the
99
so what's important about that
many things but one thing was that it
was
the actions articulated a growing sense
that there had to be an alternative to
the status quo
and they therefore should be understood
in part
as protests against the poverty of
political imagination
in the face of the economic crisis that
swept the country and the globe starting
in two thousand eight
occupy opened up a wedge for changing a
conversation and ultimately
a direction of politics in the country
and it was this idea that there was a
beginning something began there was a
wedge sometimes it's just important that
something begins and that part of the
importance and i'll come back to this
about occupy is that it something began
um
uh
a group of faculty decided to add force
to the wedge
by turning their various expertise and
we were a group of political scientists
economists sociologists philosophers
artists and
literature professors
to add force to the web by developing a
narrative
that would undergird the
broad concerns raised by the occupiers
so it's one thing to say inequality
there's a lot of growing inequality then
there are questions about well what
makes the inequality bad why is it
happened what
can be done
to combat it so
about
13 of us
issued daily short articles
on different topics related
to a couple of issues i'll talk about
we wanted to explore the roots of the
crisis
and to explore the resources we have for
renewal of economic and political
democracy what raymond williams
helpfully called resources of hope
and these essays were published online
in the boston review and are soon to be
published like in the next month by mit
press
so our writing sought to explain and tie
together four main issues that the
occupy movement brought to national and
international attention that are central
i think to the roots the causes of the
occupy movement
so first is the deep and growing divides
between the have and have nots in
america
so across multiple areas of life health
education income housing political
influence we see the greatest
inequalities the united states is known
since the great depression
in this sense we are
the 99 percent is not just a clever
rhetorical device it's consistent with
data that shows that the only the top
one percent of wage earners have seen
their incomes rise over the last decade
the next two to five percent has
experienced flat wages and everyone else
has seen a drop in earnings
the adrenal trend towards increasing
inequality has been going on for 30
years but has reached unprecedented
levels
the top one percent has claimed nearly
all the growth in income over the past
20 years so our essays sought to clarify
these trends to explain them in prose
that would be available
and and helpful to people
and to analyze the causes of this
growing inequality so it's one source of
the occupy movement is this growing
inequality but second
issue that occupy responded to
is i think as important if not more
important than inequality in itself and
that's that the extreme inequality is
rooted in and itself fuels corruption
governmental
interventions that favor the rich a lack
of accountability regarding those who
recklessly led us into the economic
crisis and a shallow commitment to
redressing the disadvantages faced by
those unlucky enough to be born to
poverty
we claim to be a country committed to a
fair contest in which everyone no matter
how rich or poor has an equal
opportunity to get a job and get ahead
where if you work hard and play by the
rules you'll lead a decent life and not
be in poverty
but instead we find the government
bailing out rich wall street bankers and
ignoring the rest of the country
we now seem to take for granted vast
educational inequalities in which poor
children are badly educated are
unqualified for college and are
increasingly consigned to low earnings
and unemployment
and if the debt is rigged against the
poor it's quite the opposite for the
rich we simply look away as ceos cut
sweetheart deals that secure for them
extraordinary compensation even as their
firms fail
so the problem then isn't just extreme
inequality in itself it's
too often that that inequality is the
product of corruption and unequal
opportunity and that's a second source
for the occupy movement
and a second
point of
its roots a third
route concerns the crisis in our
government in democracy meaningful
democracy can't exist when moneyed
interests can buy elections and can
lobby in ways that buy legislation
so for an example two-thirds of
americans support increasing taxes on
the top one percent but an ideologically
extreme faction in congress supported by
moneyed interests is committed to
blocking reform in this area
add to this list concerted efforts to
restrict or eliminate collective
bargaining rights of unions to deprive
people the right to vote and you begin
to appreciate the full measure of the
democratic crisis we face
fourth and final issue
is
the challenge of finding a way to manage
the economy and provide a good life for
everyone that's environmentally
sustainable
no uh solution to the problems of
climate disruption can be found that
doesn't involve the developed world
reducing its level of carbon emissions
so these four issues inequality
corruption
uh
inequality corruption
democrat crisis of democracy
sustainability
fueled
the occupy movement and what we tried to
do
was to explore
and analyze the origins of
and to see what could be done to bring
our institutions into better alignment
with solutions and we also wanted to
bring these four issues together in a
narrative
and we chose in um
to to root our narrative in american
ideals of freedom and equality and to
say that the ideals of freedom and
equality the found some of the founding
ideals of this country were a lever
for which to
think about these four issues and then
to begin to identify where we fall short
and in our book we try to take up some
solutions
including a millionaires tax financial
regulatory reform
and reforms of the electoral college i
said that one of the things we wanted to
do was to take the wedge that was begun
by occupy and press on it
by developing a narrative in part
because we thought that having a
narrative
something beyond just a slogan but
actually a narrative that you could
begin to take out
to
deepen
and make accessible to a broad public is
a critical part of the story of
successful social
movements um and so that's what we tried
to do but there was something we
couldn't do that occupy did and i think
this is um and now i'll turn to
what i think was the uh value of occupy
and where i think it's going in my last
two minutes
so what occupy did was it began
and i can't underestimate the importance
of that action that beginning to
basically show us
that the search for
solutions and opposition isn't futile
now you might say well isn't futile
some people think well occupier is
occupied now a year after so i wanted to
say quickly
a couple of things about why i think it
is premature to write the obituary of
occupy i think occupy was a beginning
it's not an ending there's a lot more to
be done but i want to say why we
shouldn't write its obituary so first
there are still significant actions
being taken by people inspired by the
occupy movement i'll mention one
strike debt which is an organization
started by occupiers which has been
buying up
it has something called the rolling
jubilee where it buys up debt
and
cancels it
there was occupy sandy there's occupy
the sec so occupy still goes on
second and most important
significant social change in this
country is never come simply by
conventional politics and it never comes
in a straight line
it's never a simple story of movements
you know yielding success after success
every social movement has seen ebbs and
flows starting with the great
anti-slavery movements begun um in the
1700s
which nobody would have ever predicted
would have ended uh slavery a hundred
years later
the civil rights movement saw ups and
downs so i think that um it's just
important to always know that social
movements are not simple uh narrative
arcs of one success after another and
that brings me to the last thing i want
to say which is
um in the end the occupy movement isn't
about occupying park or public space
it's about confronting
um
enormous challenges that we face as in
america and in the globe and if we don't
confront these changes we won't have a
future so one way of thinking about
maybe the history of the ebbs and flows
of social movements is to say we can't
write there's no social science that
writes the demise of this movement what
there is is there's a always a gap
where you can have hope
and that's the importance of the
beginning of the occupy movement is it
actually is a source of hope that people
responded and
to the um
changes in this country that really show
that
there are cracks
that can be exploited and i'll stop
thank you
thank you deborah okay nadeem
she actually took my answer
that's what i was going to say
um actually there is some good overlap
so i guess i'll talk a bit about
my experience with occupy and probably
start off with the general occupy
disclaimer that um you know it's been a
long time since i was involved in occupy
and that in general when people from
occupy talk they speak on their own
behalf and not with any special
knowledge or authority over the
rest of the group but um my my early
days started in boston when when we all
came together on the band stand the
gazebo in um
in the park downtown in in boston
and tried to imagine when we would do
this and how he would put it together
and two groups kind of
um
vied for putting it off six to eight
weeks new york had taken months to kind
of come online there had been a lot of
planning or should we start on thursday
you know should we start two or three
days down the road and the group that
said we should start immediately ended
up winning out and i think someone had
said at that meeting well the only way
to get that much work done is to then
spend several all-nighters in a row
getting together all of our groups
whether those groups are dissemination
or communications or
direct action or food or whatever it is
and actually hit the ground running on
thursday so in my studio in central
square
you know 13 to 15 people
met for about 72 hours running and we
got a tremendous amount of work done in
those types of
of subgroups and
we were surprisingly effective i think
when we actually hit hit the ground
and then i i kind of took a
media team
role uh beginning to field our outreach
and our um
uh messaging uh along with several
others who put in a lot of hours so i
prepared myself for that we kind of had
a press release even though we weren't
sure if it was going to be useful and lo
and behold in our kind of fourth
all-nighter in a row it's 4 a.m we're
intense it's the first night there's
police cruising around in small numbers
and the film crews start showing up and
we thought this is great we've done a
great job it's everything we prepared
for we made this happen and we learned
in retrospect that they were all there
because they had heard erroneously they
would be demonstrating in such way as to
block morning traffic
and
it was a phenomenal realization for us
that that going forward making noise
would be much more effective than than
preparing
in many cases and and we we fielded then
straight interviews every morning 4 a.m
every afternoon every evening for a
recap something's happened in new york
something's happened in a new
outcropping of occupy something's
happened internationally and we want
your thoughts
the whole the whole system
grew very quickly
the rest of my time was spent mostly in
in in the kind of
messaging and marketing side and in the
comm side i think i realized very
quickly that as these types of
organizations
spring up spontaneously that there's
very little
stepping back everyone's very close to
the issue very close to the content very
close to the um
minute by minute and i think i spent a
lot of time stepping back and trying to
make sure that everyone was connected so
uh the the email address com boston
became the singular
central node for
everyone reporting what each group was
doing and then in turn became a subgroup
in its own right as i trained people to
handle the emails and put things on the
calendar and those people in turn
changed the system that we were using
improved the system beyond my capacity
to set workflows and and and began
connecting teams and and being very
effective and proactive in that way
so that's kind of my experience with
occupy i did that for several months and
probably about three months or so and
then um got a little burnt out i was i
was working all day and then i was going
back at occupy and i was going back to
uh to central square and working all
night to get the the work done as as
many at occupy were actually
i think the complaint was that these are
unemployed hippies and these are um
you know people without direction and
then they're not our traditional leaders
and and
while that statement has no merit
because any anyone i think in this
egalitarian
occupy premise or in our general
american egalitarian traditional premise
uh ought to be able to participate it
also had no merit because so many of the
people there eight nine hours a day also
had full-time jobs
so i want to speak to the idea that
occupy was leaderless
and
although i've never said it before today
because i i just detest the the phrase i
think it was leaderful
um and i think that's true uh we were
helping one another we were teaching one
another we were supporting one another
and
um in in a sense
uh i think everyone outside of occupy
had this feeling that if anyone were to
grab the reins if anyone were to take
initiative that that would make the
whole thing crumble or that crumbler
there would be some pushback and really
from within it was if you take the
initiative if you do it many will follow
you many will be inspired by that and
then in turn they will expect that you
teach them bring them up alongside you
and eliminate the hierarchical
construction in favor of a network-based
form of teaching and learning
which in my experience was a way for the
organizational behavior of the group
to really
to really prove the model
it showed everything that researchers
and uh
theorists have said about node-based and
network-based
anti-hierarchical models being better
for innovation being better for nimble
around
and in many cases
i would say being better for
public activism
so it was leaderful we did it we had
dissemination we had inclusion we had
training and i generally think that
there were missed opportunities pardoned
around the organizational behavior side
um
i'm now halfway through with two minutes
to go so
i'm also going to say briefly that we
were aimful
um there's the claim that we that that
occupy uh had no aim
uh
uh was patently ridiculous
there were so many aims
um and those ranged from you know
corporate uh and government malfeasance
on the on the financial side to
mismanagement to the frustration that
government seemed more interested in
appearing leaderful than acting
leaderful more interested in
unilateral discussions than in any kind
of inclusive atmosphere
the list of aims goes way way way on
and
the question for me was not about
establishing aims or announcing aim so
that the public could be satisfied
the occupy experience for me was about
finding the low-hanging fruit
the things that many of us agreed on the
things that fundamentally contradicted
systems systems of justice that we've
all set up um
inequity and and lack of egalitarianism
where we all assumed it should be all of
us all of us the rich and the poor if
you were to say out loud some of the
things that are being done in government
and in finance
no one would be able to say
that they were okay without sharp
reprisal
and the fact that we don't say these
things out loud and we don't say them
out loud regularly is really the only
reason that i can understand that they
don't get taken care of dismissed
changed evolved
and that was my my kind of core
participation in occupy to find these
things together to find this aim
together and then to find a way to make
change together and i'll then echo what
was said just prior to me that
nothing went horribly wrong
nothing died and that that all of these
types of movements take a long time and
if if you are particularly patient and
particularly grounded i think in
activism then you take a 20-year view
and then you take a 100-year view and if
you're really good you realize that your
lifetime doesn't really matter
particularly much and you take the
thousand-year view
and uh you know i think there's a number
of people who are still involved with
occupy who are willing to do that
okay thank you so much so
phil let's hear your perspective
well
in terms of
why occupy arose i mean i don't have
much to add but
i think that
something dramatic has happened uh in
the last 15 years or so
where six banks in the united states now
hold 64 percent or so of total wealth
in this country and i think 15 years ago
it was something like
those same banks out held 17
simon johnson at sloan has numbers on
this but i think that's about right
and
that uh is an unprecedented
concentration of power
um
in a very small number of hands and and
i think
you know
occupy really shined a shown a spotlight
on that
and i will just say that i think that
our current economic and political
theories
can't deal with this fact
because this wasn't supposed to happen
um
american political science is basically
pluralist in nature that says that
they're contending forces in society to
counter big corporations whether there's
a big labor unions or you know other
kinds of institutions that counter that
power of the corporation
but corporations were always imagined to
be governed by any trust laws they
weren't supposed to control
64 a handful
64 of all the wealth in the country that
kind of power just isn't imagined
and spending billions of dollars a year
lobbying congress
that wasn't imagined in american
political science so i don't really
think american political science has
even grappled
with
what we have now and also our economic
theories always presume basically a
market economy marx may have wanted to
overthrow
competitive capitalism but citigroup did
uh when you're too big to fail that
basically means you're not a market
anymore you know that's you're into
something else
and i don't think in economic theory
either there are any real
answers
or ideas for how do you deal with a
situation like this so i think that
we're in new territory and i don't even
think the banks have figured out the big
banks have figured out fully how to
utilize their power but
this is something we all should be
extremely concerned about and and i
think what occupy did was like since
something dramatic was happening
sees the moment
in terms of the future of occupy i would
say
or
movements right now dealing with this
intense corporate concentration of power
i think
as many said occupy was a beginning
i think there are
lots of different ways to
fight corporate power
and
that
our thinking of politics really has to
expand
more into things like consumer
organizing using the power you know
consumer power to
boycott
certain companies to target others for
you know the do good things to
we have to fight around
uh regulatory
uh changes that businesses need in order
to get things done whether it's a zoning
approval or
a tax abatement or a utility service
plan or any number of things that
businesses come to government for
seeking public approval we have to
organize shareholder power
in ways that we have never done before
and one of the interesting things about
these big banks and other big
corporations now they're public it's
they don't literally own
you know 64 of the wealth of americans
all of our wealth but we are not
organized and we tend to think of
politics as voting for politicians we
don't tend to think of politics as
voting
as shareholders at corporate board
meetings and i just think we need to
radically expand our notion of politics
the last thing i wanted to
say was that
i view occupy essentially as a movement
and awakening of young white
students and young white people and
that's a great thing
in my opinion uh a real activism and
political awakening
um
and
i don't i do think
in order to really deal with
change and to make change in america
we have to think about how
occupy or these
predominantly young white activists
connect to other movements
that have been fighting for or could be
fighting for in the same
trenches along for the same things and
i specifically just want to talk about
movements of people of color
and
potential linkages here
and
many folks
kind of have a mythology of what the
civil rights movement was about and tend
to forget you know like it was all about
desegregation and people wanting to you
know go to schools and ride on buses but
um the 1963
march on washington was a march for
jobs and freedom
jobs was number one
um before martin luther king gave the i
have a dream speech in washington he
gave it to the afl-cio
in 1961 and he said we really don't need
to have two movements if you all would
just agree to desegregate unions we
could have one movement we don't need to
have a separate civil rights movement
the afl-cio rejected him and rejected
that offer
and
andy young tells a story in the
introduction to a book called the
closing door
by gary orfield and carol ashkenazi and
he says
he said you know after king was
assassinated
the johnson administration came with
affirmative action
and
at the time if you
may have read if not remember
the civil rights movement martin luther
king had turned to full employment
and poor people's campaigns as a
principal demand and the johnson
administration rather than coming up
with full employment responded with
affirmative action you won't see go look
at eyes on the prize you won't see black
people marching on the streets demanding
affirmative action
they were demanding full employment and
trying to reach out to whites latinos
asians native americans that was the
vision
and andy young said when affirmative
action happened
we knew
it would only help
the upper middle class within the black
community a very small percentage of
african-americans kids were going to go
to these elite colleges you know that
affirmative action was targeted we would
benefit from it
but we were scared
of being red-baited we were scared of
being ostracized or attacked so we
backed down and just accepted that and
he said we knew that poverty would
remain and these basic issues of
economic injustice would remain i say
this to say that
movements
can be derailed they can be
intimidated they can be distracted and
generally in america we tend to just
follow the pattern of
decentralized government which is a form
of moderated anarchy
and we don't really work hard at
cooperating together period we all kind
of get excited with local empowerment
and having our voices heard and whatever
we're doing and we don't think build big
strong movements capable of taking on
concentrated power
that's what happened to the civil rights
movement
we have thousands of community
development organizations in communities
of color we have lots of local
environmental justice organizations we
have lots of this local empowerment we
do not have a movement anymore and i
think it's important
in terms of learning lessons that we not
just replicate that all the time not to
just say we don't need local empowerment
and local ingenuity and all of that but
that will not be enough to take on the
concentrated power that exists in this
country right now and last i just want
to say i think there are many
opportunities for linking the folks
who've been involved with occupy and the
kinds of initiatives that deborah was
talking about with very serious issues
going on in communities of color right
now that could really be synergistic
i'll mention nine thousand
african-american homeowners in detroit
are suing morgan stanley
people who lost their homes due to
foreclosure and this is not just going
after the originators of these mortgages
but
wall street the secondary mortgage
market the folks who manipulated this
stuff and that is a direct connection
between what occupy was fighting around
and african americans who were
disproportionately
seven times more lost their homes than
white americans for example
many predominantly african-american
cities and in cities predominant with
people of color are teetering on
bankruptcy many of them were sold bad
goods bad
financial products
just as we're homeowners birmingham
alabama is an example and so whole
cities are on the brink of bankruptcy
and that too can be part of a movement
connected to these issues
immigration the lack of immigration
reform means that there are 12 million
undocumented
immigrants in this country who do not
have access
to health insurance
and they get sick
and they die just like everybody and
where do they go they go into hospitals
in inner city communities largely
because to get treated and why are they
treated because if you don't treat
people with tb and other diseases
everybody gets sick they get treated but
these hospitals don't have funding
to pay for it they're not covered by
medicaid medicare these are hospitals
that people of color rely on generally
in inner city communities so this is a
crisis
and if if folks who are involved in
occupy can make the link
and see how it is affecting immediately
these same issues how it plays out
in communities of color i think there's
some very powerful synergies that can be
built to build a stronger movement
and
last i want to say that you know i'm
very hopeful
the dream
of a unified movement is a dream that's
been around i think since the
underground railroad um but i think we
have to be real honest we have never
done that
we have never done that
and you know perhaps the election of
obama really would i take from it that's
positive i think a lot of people aspire
to that right now so you know this is
the time i think it's a it's a historic
opportunity and as you know some
philosophers said danger and opportunity
tend to come together and we have both
right now
thanks so much
so
chris let's hear your words
well the occupy movement was the first
movement
in recent history to respond rationally
to the new configuration of power to the
corporate coup d'etat
that has been undertaken
what sheldon wolin calls our system of
inverted totalitarianism
uh it was an understanding that the
formal mechanisms of power no longer
work to carry out incremental or
piecemeal reform as they were designed
to do essentially we are
trapped in a system of political
paralysis
there is an inability on the part of
government to respond rationally that is
a constant theme in paul krugman's
columns to the problems that beset us
whether that is climate change or
whether that is the financial collapse
the mortgage crisis
um the chronic underemployment
unemployment the fact that a million
people a year go bankrupt because they
can't pay their medical bills 80 percent
of whom had health insurance
all of our legislation is written by
corporate lobbyists uh the power elite
uh understands perfectly well what's
coming
and is radically reconfiguring the legal
system to criminalize dissent obama's
assault on civil liberties has been far
worse than the assault carried out by
george w bush
whether that is the use of the 2001
authorization to use military force act
to justify the assassination of american
citizens the fisa reform act or
amendment act that retroactively makes
legal what under our constitution has
traditionally been illegal the
warrantless wiretapping monitoring and
eavesdroppings of tens of millions of
american citizens we know all of our
personal information is being stored in
supercomputers in utah the use of the
espionage act six times to shut down
whistleblowers this is was never
designed to silence whistleblowers uh it
was only used three times until obama
came to office the first time being
against daniel ellsberg
as a former investigative reporter i can
tell you that you cannot do anything at
this point to challenge the official
government narrative you cannot even get
background briefings because people are
frightened of going to jail and of
course the national defense
authorization act which obama signed
into law on december 31st section 1021
permits the u.s military to seize u.s
citizens
strip them of due process hold them in
military facilities indefinitely
i sued the president
over this in federal court i won
in september
and the obama administration
appealed
uh what was fascinating is that they uh
went to judge catherine forrest after
she gave her decision and her 112 page
opinion which is really a brilliant kind
of dissection on the destruction of the
separation of powers and is worth
reading
asked for an emergency stay meaning they
wanted the law put back into effect
until the appellate court would hear the
case she refused they demanded an
emergency hearing with the appellate
court
at 9 00 a.m in the morning the next
monday
for an emergency hearing and an
emergency stay which they got the only
reason that i and the lawyers bruce
afron and karl mayer can make out that
the obama administration reacted so
aggressively is because they're already
using it
probably on pakistani us dual nationals
in places like bagram
the inability to curb wall street
a close examination of
the obama health care bill which was
written by corporate lobbyists in
particular liz fowler uh who worked for
baucus and has now gone back into the
industry um the
uh inability to deal with the the most
important crisis that is confronting us
that's climate change the fact that the
obama administration has not only
approved the southern leg of the
keystone xl pipeline but appears to
uh
almost certainly be ready to approve the
northern leg
so that they can exploit the tar sands
all of these are indications that
essentially power has been rested from
the hands of the citizenry
there is no way within the american
political system anymore to vote against
the interests of corporations like exxon
mobil or goldman sachs and occupy
understood this and they understood
number one where power had been
transferred to and that was from the
legislative bodies and the judicial
bodies and of course the press let's not
forget the press has been completely
corporatized you talked about banks
roughly a half dozen corporations viacom
general electric rupert murdoch's news
corp disney clear channel control almost
everything most americans listen to or
watch
creating this kind of faux
narrative on the one hand it's court
gossip from fox or it's court gossip
from msnbc it's all the same junk
just spun differently
uh and the real substantial issues that
matter to the majority of american
citizens are never mentioned
it it reminds me of what
dorothy parker once said about katherine
hepburn's emotional range as an actress
it goes from a to b
step outside of that paradigm
and you instantly become a pariah
as anybody who
at mit knows gnomes chomsky's
great work will tell you
or ralph nader who's been fighting
corporations and understands corporate
power better than anyone else in this
country and occupy grasped that
they also grasped that the only
mechanism we have left by which we can
save ourselves is civil disobedience
and they courageously carried out those
acts of civil disobedience
um
uh repeatedly
and what was the response of the state
the response of the state was to move in
and physically eradicate the encampments
in a coordinated effort run by the obama
administration because this movement
terrified the power elite and in
particular the democratic party this
kind of faux liberalism that speaks in
that traditional feel european language
and yet has abandoned the very
constituency that they purport to
represent
and that's very dangerous i covered the
war in the former yugoslavia for the new
york times i watched what political
paralysis does and that is essentially
what's happened we have a system that is
incapable of responding to the
legitimate grievances and injustices
that are being visited on tens of
millions of americans half of this
country is now living in either poverty
or a category called near poverty and
what is the response of the corporate
state
it is to cut unemployment benefits for
hundreds
of thousands of americans which means
tens of thousands of these people are
going to lose their homes and they're
all about to push us over the so-called
physical cliff
corporations know only one word and
that's more
and because all of the restraints the
regulations and the impediment to
corporate power have been lifted
they have as marx understood and carl
polyani understood
commodified everything human beings have
become commodities and the natural world
has become a commodity you see it 40
of the summer arctic sea ice melts
and shell and exxon look at it as a
business opportunity
it's insanity
we are now all aboard the pequod
moby dick
melville's most prescient study of the
american character and ahab's in charge
and as ahab said my means and my methods
are saying
only my object is mad
and the inability to stand up whether
it's over the inevitable financial
dislocation
these people are harvesting the country
anytime hedge fund managers
and let's forget never forget that at
institutions like this
half of the trustee boards come from
this class most of whom should be in
jail
when they walk into inner city areas and
start talking about poor children's
education it's not because they want
kids to read and write it's because they
know the federal government spends 600
billion dollars a year on education and
they want it and they're going to get it
there is no mechanism left
except civil disobedience
and having covered movements all around
the world the revolutions in eastern
europe the two palestinian uprisings or
intifadas the street demonstrations that
brought down slobodan milosevic you know
that the tinder is there and i spent the
last two years in the poorest pockets of
this country from camden new jersey to
the produce fields in immokalee florida
the coal fields of southern west
virginia you know that tinder is there
but you never know what's going to set
it off it's usually something relatively
benign
an elderly woman gets foreclosed in her
home in utah or something but i know
it's coming will it look like occupy
will it be cold occupy you can never
know
i think it's better to think of occupy
not as a movement
but as a tactic
rosa parks
refuses to move on the bus it's five
years until we see the freedom rides
and because the state has not responded
rationally
because the state has proved paralyzed
because it not only cannot address the
grievances but essentially allows
corporations to extract
more and more and more in this
reconfiguration into a form of
neo-feudalism the only thing i can tell
you as a reporter is that something
is coming
thank you very much maybe we could thank
them and then we'll move on to
discussion
so thank you very much for your
incredibly powerful statements i think
one of the questions that comes to me is
what exactly is occupy um it's been
mentioned as a tactic for example it is
a way of organizing uh individuals uh to
respond rationally to what's happening
um i think that there's quite a bit of
agreement on the part of the panelists
about uh what the problems are but a
little less agreement on what occupy
exactly is and whether it can become
what it needs to be in order to uh
respond to the big problem so for
example
um do we need a big strong movement as
as phil was pointing to and can can
occupy become a big strong movement
without losing
sort of its essential character which
seemed to be much more local much more
spontaneous much more
uh
sort of democratic in in in ways that
seem sometimes to be fragmenting okay
this is i'm just trying to say these are
perceptions of occupy but can it become
this without ceasing to be occupied or
is occupied just a tactic that anybody
can use at any moment so
who would someone like to let me just
let me just add quickly that sure there
was a process
within occupy i'm talking about zuccotti
and they lost control of the park in
particular
or the particular moment was when the
individual tents went up because they
had been able to keep alcohol and drugs
out once the tents went up they came in
activists were staying up all night in
de-escalation teams and
and we were also seeing the nypd
um
dropping
homeless people off to essentially
overload the system uh and so
by the end at least within new york i
don't know what your experience in
boston was it the park didn't work
consensus worked very well kropotkin
makes this point when you have small
groups it worked very well at the
beginning it did not work well when you
had 4 000 people especially with the
capacity for a block um
i wouldn't get too caught up in
in
um
you know
movements
and i you know i speak as someone who
covered them movements have a kind of
mysterious life force of their own
and and it's always the ruling class
that determines the configuration of
rebellion or response the inability of
the ruling class or the ruling elite in
the united states to respond rationally
to the grievances that drove people into
these parks means that something will
spring up
inevitably
i tend to think that it is
probably eminently possible for occupy
to grow i was part of a number of
international and international occupy
kind of phone calls and virtual meetings
and that kinds of things and they all
went very well
bringing back knowledge and sharing
power and all that went well at scale i
tend to think that the main problem was
that our focus became the day-to-day
running of this camp and that we weren't
prepared for
we definitely saw bpd driving people and
at least heard of bpd uh driving people
to to the camp that uh that became
difficult to manage there's a lot of
mental health issues a lot of other
issues entailed by running a camp and i
think uh uh
kind of de-convolving or separating the
camp aspects from the the movement
aspect will certainly help in
scaling
the the the program um
so i kind of think it's possible
well
i i
i don't think civil disobedience is
enough
and
i i worked as a movement organizer for
many years i made fifty dollars a week
um
and when i had kids i just can't
couldn't live on fifty dollars a week
and i don't think you can build a
movement sustained over time
as as like student movements you know um
where you go out for a brief time
you know you take action
and then it's over and you go look for a
job right and then it's over i i think
we have to have a a much more
sophisticated
approach
and i also think we need an approach
that my mother can get involved in
and she's 80 82 years old in a
wheelchair but she voted for obama
thinking that that was fighting
the system
and there there have to be ways to get
my mother involved
when i was a kid
people
my father was a minister very active in
the civil rights movement
and what people don't see on the tv
shows about the civil rights movement
were
the years
of conversations every sunday with
people in church to tell
them they are people
they they are children of god that was
the
the storyline
and god doesn't make bad children or
junkie children and they
they are as good as anyone
and it took years of that
to build their confidence to get them to
the point of taking actions
and
it's not just something i don't think
that happens spontaneously
uh it may in some cases but i don't
think we're going to build a really
strong really powerful really broad
movement
just waiting for some spark
uh it's there's a lot of education that
has to happen there are a lot of tactics
my first political action was boycott
i'm from philadelphia was boycotting
tasty cake they make these crumpets and
little cupcakes
and coca-cola
and that's because leon sullivan and
other movement organizers found ways to
involve seven-year-olds
in the movement and that was boycotting
tasty cake and coca-cola i think we have
to have a lot of
of tactics a lot of strategies in order
to bring people together and we have to
have some difficult conversations about
race i
i don't think the story of health care
is as simple as corporate lobbyists
wrote it and that's the whole thing a
lot of institutions played in it uh
things are just more complicated than
that
there are a lot of unions that lobbied
and got stuff stuck in the bill for
example it's and
obama in my opinion is a transition
figure meaning that he embodies
everything that's been said at this
table both in terms of corporate
influence but also aspirations of huge
numbers of people who voted for him who
push for things that he included as well
that's why he's a transition figure and
i think he's a reflection of kind of
where we are as a country and where we
are as a movement
yeah i mean what happens when you have a
response like the chicago teachers
strike as obama turns his back on them
when you have the bailout of the auto
industry
they crush the uaw
and i think that obama like clinton is a
figure who
essentially serves corporate interests
but speaks in the traditional language
of liberalism uh there's hardly a
campaign promised from 2008 that barack
obama hasn't broken including
supporting unions and raising the
minimum wage and uh and i think that
that goes back to sheldon wollen's point
that it's it's the engines of corporate
power that drive the political process
and the economic process the personal
narrative barack obama is irrelevant
and
and that's why there's such continuity
whether it is imperial war assaults on
civil liberties failure to curb wall
street from bush to obama
because those who actually decide
and we just went through a 2.5 billion
dollar electoral charade
are not in the white house
uh in terms of
you know building a movement yes you're
right and all of those activities have
to be done and they are being done but
they're being done on a much smaller
scale and that was exactly what i saw in
eastern europe that you saw for instance
in leipzig
week after week the had vigils against
the uh
communist dictatorship and then suddenly
70 000 people showed up
um this is what vaslav havel points out
in his 1978 essay the power of the
powerless living in truth um so yes
you're exactly right that those
activities have to be carried out um but
you know
working with the occupy movement after
the destruction of zuccotti there's a
clear kind of despair and i think that
we have to understand that we have to
keep going this is what occupy sandy has
done
because as hovel points out we are
essentially speaking truth to power we
are exposing a decayed corrupt uh system
uh you know that that no longer responds
to the needs of the citizenry and that's
why they're so frightened of the occupy
movement itself okay so deborah why
don't you have the last word from the
panel and then we'll open the mic so um
start thinking about your questions so i
just want to is this on so i i i want to
agree with phil about the importance of
um
deepening the connection between the
rage and
response of occupy with existing
institutional structures so i don't
think we i mean we don't live in a
totalitarian world where the only thing
anybody can do is take to the streets
there are other forms of mobilization
of power that are out there whether it's
in the labor movement or in
shareholders
organizations or
uh
anyway there there are other forms of uh
opposition
and one of the things that i think is
very important you know social movements
there's no science i agree they have to
come outside change doesn't happen only
by the internal political process in
fact it almost never happens by that
alone there has to be points of pressure
but social movements don't succeed when
they don't tell a unified narrative that
every you know lots of people can sign
on and get on board that's you know
clear that um is hopeful that has some
solutions and they don't succeed when
they don't deepen their roots in
communities
who have the grievances that they're
taking up when you come in from outside
without and occupy wasn't just from
outside occupy did bring in some of
people who were absolutely on the front
lines of those grievances but there are
many many other people who are
suffering in the ways that you were
describing that weren't brought on and
unless you link out to those people and
tell a story that brings those people on
board you're not gonna in the end have a
successful social movement whether
occupy i think occupy is and you know as
i said it's very important because in
the absence of something like occupy you
could feel like there was no hope and
the fact that people responded is a sign
of hope but it has to deepen and it has
to connect to communities that are
hurting um in more systematic and more
unified ways if it's going to succeed
well i did say liver would be the last
but real quick real question real quick
i i want to say i want to
continue that thought a little bit and
also clarify what i think one of the
main issues here is you said that occupy
challenged the poverty of creativity
around governance around
society in general
we are not when we demonize i think and
i speak for myself but we in my tight
circle of friends and perhaps occupy at
large when we demonize romney or
demonize obama are not talking about a
person who haphazardly made his way into
the the presidential arena we're talking
about a system that only is controlled
by certain types of people and only
promotes certain types of people and the
system itself the structure the meta it
is it is all uh corrupt very
fundamentally and at very many levels
from top to bottom
so when we talk about
organizing around a singular principle
i don't think the the solution is
necessarily to consolidate around
existing labor movements i don't think
the solution is necessarily to formulate
a third party platform i think the
solution is to use these tools and use
these bodies in order to consolidate
power and to use that power to challenge
the way in which decisions are made
fundamentally
okay i'm going to cut you off now
because i'd like to take
time to have some questions from the
audience so recall if you are going to
ask a question you should
go to one of the mics so that we can be
sure to hear
you yes and i'll alternate between mics
um as long as we have people at them
so why don't we start with the left mic
or my left mike do you think
non-cooperation doesn't work in this
country because people don't know what
it means
do you think cooperation doesn't work in
this non-cooperation non-cooperation
civil
disobedience does civil disobedience
really work in this country why not
and if not why not
i didn't hear that there's civil
disobedience
so
so is the question
does civil disobedience work and if not
why not in this country i believe it
should work that's the only way
it can help in this country but does it
really work
and i want to
jump in it works if you get the numbers
i mean the the the important thing is
about about building numbers
uh
and and sustaining it um but it
certainly works i mean it worked in the
labor movement it the problem is that
all of the movements since world war one
in the name of anti-communism have been
destroyed all the radical movements and
i'm just going to have to disagree with
you on labor labor is a spent force
in this country and you look at the
chicago teachers strike they had to
break with the traditional democratic
establishment as embodied by rahm
emanuel and barack obama as well as
traditional labor
and step outside those mechanisms of
power to respond um
but you know labor's fighting a rear
guard action if you look at the auto
bailout which i mentioned earlier uh in
order for the bailout to go through
uh the uaw had to accept uh a decline in
salaries from uh older workers from
about 76 dollars an hour to 50 and it
had to agree that gm and other plants
could hire new workers at dollars an
hour and it had to agree that it
wouldn't strike if it it said if if it
struck all the bailout money would have
to be repaid so while the democratic
establishment holds up the saving of the
auto industry what is unspoken
is this continued assault against the
ability of organized labor what's left
of it to protect the working class
okay
microphone on the right
hi my name is bill lewis i'm a member of
occupy boston i have worked with that
gentleman a good deal making a lot of
noise in streets
i had a couple of comments and then one
fundamental question
the first comment is
a huge percentage of occupy is indeed
minority a great portion of our
effectiveness is that we are not
outsiders we are insiders with the
people on the streets we are the locals
that's why occupy sandy is so effective
it's not outsiders coming in it is the
people themselves
with doing mutual aid as we call it
we're helping each other so that's just
a comment
my main concern is
twofold
i have a virtual daughter she's 27
she has all the bad aspects of a girl
who lived her life wrong she has her
eldest daughter is 10 she's single she's
living on the barest minimum of section
8 etc
etc she doesn't have a thousand years or
ten years or even one year her children
need help now
and voting for obama allowed her to
maintain
her
support that she would have lost under
romney so these do make a difference
and finally
my main objective right now as a member
of occupy boston
is
that we spend all this time we're great
people we're talking to ourselves
we're not the ones we need to talk to we
need to be talking to the almost half of
america
who voted against their own best
interests repeatedly
and i personally was down in immaculate
for the same reason i assume that chris
was to talk to people to understand
what's going on and to talk to people
who are republicans who view the world
differently
and to get them to look at their own
best interest and answer the question
what do they want their own world to be
so my question is how can we get to
those people so how do we get to the
people we need to get to
yeah well
if you guys want to jump in i
i tend to think that as i said there's
there's this there's this low there's
this layer of low-hanging fruit that is
extremely appealing to people across all
um
constituencies and and across all
parties i i don't necessarily sounded to
me like you were saying how can people
to the left reach out to people to the
right but frankly our whole spectrum is
totally whacked
and i don't think we just need to reach
out to the 50 of people who i don't know
voted for romney voted for obama but to
both both sides and and appeal to people
on the very rational and reasonable set
of of points
and to show the the series of financial
bait and switches as a business owner
the the stimulus is a total joke right
the stimulus package for small
businesses never made it to small
businesses i mean that's one in a a host
of examples where
i don't think it's actually that
difficult to talk to people to engage
people to educate people to remind them
that the party dynamic is not positive
for any of us the two-party dynamic or
within your party the way in which
decisions are made and which leaders are
promoted
phil you look like you were about to
jump in i mean did you have something
you want yeah
i was just going to say that you know my
starting point is where people are and
it may be that
labor is a spent force it may be that
civil rights organizations are spent
forces it may be that community-based
organizations are narrow-minded and
too anxious to just get the
a foundation grant or a government
low-income tax credit to build five
units of housing and that's not going to
change the system
you know but that's where people are
and that's where i start for the last
four years i've been working with the
building trades
which is the widest most conservative
part of the labor movement
and i've been working with them to try
and get young
black and latino kids of color
into the building trade so they can
become the green workforce of the future
and the building trades spent as they
are
conservative as they are
operate 1200 job training centers in the
construction trades and it's the second
largest job training mechanism outside
of the u.s navy
and
guess what
they are actually in a coalition with
youthbuild with many other
organizations that train high school
dropouts inner city kids working
together for the last four years to say
how do we change how do we improve and
the national leadership of the building
trades has gone
across 350 cities in the u.s trying to
convince their locals that they need to
change and they need to have a new
vision about how to grow a labor
movement that's encouraging to me
and i think we have to do that kind of
work
reaching across not writing people off
if anybody is justified in writing off
white construction workers who spent 100
years keeping people of color out of the
trades i think i would be i think people
like me would be justified and writing
those people off i'm not writing those
people off because in order to change
america i need them
and i want them to understand
they need me too
and and i just think we have to proceed
like that we can't proceed from
somebody's theory
and somebody's wish for a spark to
ignite folks to go on the street i've
been on the street
in protests and demonstrations i
personally don't like riots because they
don't i saw what comes after riots if
you don't have a plan if you have no
capacity to run a city you get shot
people go to jail you know you win a
victory that lasts for a little period
of time and then you lose in the end
because the people who are fighting you
have much more staying power have much
more capacity and you haven't done real
deep work with people in your group to
actually
continue the fight and so i think this
is a real fight it's not one
i want to lose it's not what i want to
see our communities lose and i think the
stakes and the dangers are bigger than
they ever were
okay thank you i'm going to ask us
to not make comments but ask questions
and so and try to keep them short
because we have little time and many
people yes
hi uh given uh the technology that we
have
you know in the 21st century and given
the wealth that i see that we spend on
the entertainment industry my
understanding is that
the eradication of poverty is possible
and that it isn't you know some sort of
fantasy like the eradication of crime or
something i don't know and i wanted to
ask the panelists is the eradication of
poverty in america
uh a possibility and what is the method
uh to getting there if if we can't
depend on you know voting someone into
power that could
to help us get there thank you
so
you know poverty rates have been going
up in this country for the last two
decades but they went down and there are
got you know so here's a place where i
actually think government policies
matter
and
that whether people put pressure on the
government whether it's through
mass protests or through institutions
like the labor movement or through
election campaigns
policies matter as you say we have
enough wealth in this country that there
is no reason why anybody in this country
should be hungry right there's no reason
why anybody in this country should be
poor it's a actually an atrocity that so
many children in the united states grow
up in poverty it's totally you know
against the ideals that this country was
founded on that i think are powerful
ideals that resonate with many people
and i think the the what the occupy
movement correctly is picking up on is
um the government has not been
responsive in fact it's been part of the
problem it's been creating policies that
have made the situation for people worse
and that we actually need better
policies but it's not um we're not
technically limited we're politically
limited
all right next question thank you thanks
um in the interest of gender balance i i
in the out here i offered my spot to the
young woman behind me but she demured so
here i am
i wish this conversation
the entirety of it were focused on the
democratic party
whether it's an ally of our struggles
and interests or not
and what if anything might be an
alternative to that
politically
not
just in civil disobedience i'm
sympathetic to civil disobedience i'm
sympathetic to speaking truth to power
i'm sympathetic to challenging power i'd
like to get me some
ralph nader likes to quote cicero who
said freedom is participation
in power
so with that in mind
can we have a little bit of a further
elaboration on
political alternatives
acknowledging the difficulties and the
constraints
to the
established institutional democratic
party or if you don't think that's the
way to go
please say so a little bit more
explicitly thank you
question
well i supported nader i wrote most of
his policy speeches for him in 2008 and
i voted for jill stein
in this election
because
i believe the democratic party beginning
under clinton essentially sold out for
corporate money
clinton continued like obama to speak in
that feel-your-pain language while he
gave us nafta the greatest betrayal of
the working class in this country since
the 1948 taft-hartley act while he
deregulated the fcc allowing
corporations like murdoch by the way is
just about apparently to buy the los
angeles times in the chicago tribune uh
he deregulated the banking system he
destroyed welfare and under the
traditional welfare system 70 percent of
the recipients were children and for
doing the business of corporations he
got corporate money so that by the 1990s
the fund raising the democratic party
had fundraising parity with the
republicans when obama ran in 2008 he
got more
and i look at other countries like
germany the labor party in germany never
polls more than 5
but it is a counterweight it is a force
to protect labor and the reason i
supported nader and voted green
is not because anyone's going to win but
i think ralph is right that what we
needed to do was build five 10 15
million people who begin to put pressure
on the democratic party from the other
side who draw a line and say that's
enough we're willing to walk out but
this policy of voting for the least
worst voting in elections where the
primary emotion that is sold to the
electorate is fear fear of the other if
it's romney a supporter it's fear that
you know homosexual couples will teach
your children in kindergarten i don't
know
whacky idea they have and and if it's
obama it's fear of romney who was a
centrist
corporatist governor of this state you
know where did obamacare come from it
was written by the heritage foundation
it was first put into practice in 2006
by romney in massachusetts and then it
was adopted by obama it's a completely
faux debate and so uh for me supporting
third party movements is part of
resistance but of course not enough
uh and i actually agree with your point
and and the work that you're doing but i
think it's a and and when i talk about a
spark it's not i'm not sitting home
watching
uh c-span waiting for a spark i'm you
know i've been was arrested in front of
goldman sachs and the white house and
everywhere else but i think that
we can't get demoralized with numbers
and after the success of the occupy
movement i'm finding within the occupy
movement a demoralization and i keep
telling like when we go to zuccotti you
know and i was just out at occupy sandy
you know in that sense i come out of
seminary harvard divinity school well
okay it passes as a seminary and the and
and and and resistance is a kind of
moral imperative
and and that's what hovel gets that's
what the berrigans get
that's what king got that's what malcolm
got
that you you know we were where we
should be and faith is the belief that
the good draws the good to itself and as
some of you may know i have been in
fierce debate with the black bloc
anarchists over the issue of violence i
debated them
crime think in
september
because
i think that because we have this truth
we do have the capacity i think the
occupy movement is a mainstream movement
i think it actually articulates the
concerns of the mainstream and i think
what frightened the state
more than anything was seen on the
weekends mothers and fathers from new
jersey as they did show up in zuccotti
and push their strollers up and down the
park
and and they love the black blocks a few
bricks a few taunts um and so chris yeah
okay we need to okay so so um we're
actually i want to have one additional
comment from deborah in response to that
question and then um it will be six
o'clock and so those of you who need to
leave uh
please do so but i thought um to find to
finish up what we could do is just take
all the questions in sequence quickly
and then have some quick statements by
the um panelists
to sum things up okay so deborah you can
go ahead i wanted to say two things
because i thought
your very important question about how
to relate to the existing political
parties and i completely think there is
room for third parties for opposition
for
voting your conscience i do think there
are some political reforms that would do
a lot one of them is electoral you know
campaign finance we have been losing
over and over again on the campaign
finance issue the way that money now
influences elections is completely
undemocratic
and i think we need to get those laws
changed so that's one thing if i were
trying to you know think about how to
respond to the political process because
even if we have other parties in there
we need to change the rules of the game
to make sure that everybody no matter
how rich or poor has the chance to
influence the political process on an
equal basis
and the second thing is i think we need
to change the electoral college which is
very biased against uh cities
and places with big populations so great
okay so those of you who need to leave
at six o'clock here's your moment um but
i think what i would like to do is if we
could make the questions short it looks
to me as though there are four more uh
questioners we could ask those questions
and then come back to the panel so on
this side
well the occupy movement probably has
the right intentions but does it have
the right name uh occupy has very
pejorative connotations especially in
foreign policy especially in the middle
east and elsewhere
does occupy give occupation a good name
is it possible to occupy the occupiers
on this side
given that we're at mit i was wondering
if you had specific advice for both
students and professionals in
technologic or technical fields
who
people who see the same situation that
you've described agree that there's a
problem and want to help okay
yes next
go ahead okay
lawrence lessig is a really good book
republic lost
um and he gave a great talk he gives
great talk
and it seems to me he's he's
addressing
recovering the influ recovering from the
influence of money and politics how can
we do that
root strikers group and so forth
so it seems to me to be
as he says that's this should be the
second item on everybody's agenda
no matter what your issue is
so
what's your response
right yes
why are we
all of us so parochial and two examples
occupy sandy worked together with
350.org
but if you go to their web pages
they don't have live links to each other
something that simple and nobody here
has put occupy within the context of the
wave of worldwide revolution that
started in tunisia and in particular the
indignados of spain who are much closer
to us than tunisia or egypt or any other
place
okay yes our last question
hi um to the gentleman in the thai um
you mentioned that you had been to west
virginia and spoke spoken to the people
there and i've spent a lot of time in
west virginia and what i see is uh uh
poor white uh workers who um
who share a lot of the same values as
occupy and you know they have distrust
in the finance industry and in the
government and a lot of other things
like that and how can occupy appeal to
these voters who are
uh socially conservative but
you know we're traditionally democrat
and west virginia used to go democratic
like you know 20 years ago
consistently so
thanks
okay so why don't we start with phil and
chris and then move this way nadine and
okay could you just make a quick
statement
i just uh wanted to say that uh
end with
a lesson i learned from my grandfather
and uh
my grandfather was a
raised me my grandparents raised me and
he was from a farm in north carolina
and in 1968 he voted for george wallace
and i i truly even as a young person in
1968 i could not understand
why he was voting for george wallace and
i hope folks know who george wallace was
he was
leading a segregationist movement
and my grandfather said
both nixon and hubert humphrey
are corporate guys in suits
and they'll just say whatever they think
they need to say in order to get elected
but i've spent my whole life with poor
white folks
and they're lined up behind george
wallace because they really believe
in what george wallace is saying
and he said but i i think
if i really talk to them if i really
work with them i can change them
and if you change a poor white
and he was talking about in the south
you've got a friend forever
i'll never change these people in suits
because they don't believe what they're
saying themselves
so i say that to say that's how i think
about this question of movement building
and
i don't care democratic party frankly
i've been on the left for 30 years i
don't see a big difference between
whites on the left and whites on the
right
when it comes to a lot of issues i care
about i don't see it it's it's really
about
do you believe
in what you say are you open
to real conversation for real engagement
for real humanity
or are you not
and i don't think any party or any left
right really has a monopoly or a
particular high ground on that issue and
i think that's the fundamental issue
uh when it comes to to to change and
movement building
okay thank you so much phil has to leave
so let's thank him as he leaves
chris
i just got i just got back from alabama
where 34 percent of african-american men
have disenfranchised because of criminal
records
i was in montgomery uh and there's just
one confederate memorial after another
when you ride into montgomery the sons
of the confederacy have put this
gargantuan confederate flag outside the
city
reminded me of the breakdown of
yugoslavia where in
periods of economic dislocation people
retreat into mythic narratives about
where they come from and who they are so
that the war between the states is no
longer about
slavery it's about states rights
and we have huge sections of this
country embodied like that nativist
element like the christian right in
mythical narratives whether it's
creationism
uh or
you know the fact that muslims are a
satanic religion or relishing and you
cannot
rationally argue with people who think
the earth was created six thousand years
ago and adam and eve used to ride on the
backs of dinosaurs
um the only thing you can do is
reintegrate them into the economy
and that's what frightens me uh that
when you fall to that level of
desperation and this is exactly what
tore yugoslavia apart with these ethnic
nationalist identities
um there becomes an inability to
communicate we had a year ago several
hundred white guys dressed in
confederate uniforms marching through
montgomery half of that city is black to
carry out a reenactment of the
inauguration of jefferson davis
and you can't
you can't carry out a dialogue and
that's what frightens me we have
powerful proto-fascist movements that
celebrate the gun culture the language
of violence demonize uh the marginal uh
and the weak whether it's homosexuals
african-americans feminists uh liberals
undocumented workers have a very long
list of people they hate and i see that
breakdown occurring because of the
economic disintegration and having lived
through it in places like yugoslavia you
the rational argument just doesn't work
thank you chris nadine
uh i'm not sure if i heard the full
occupy in a revolutionary context
question but it's something that that i
think about a great deal
i'll just say very briefly that i think
i think there's great
future hope for occupy-like
movements and and that i can probably
cover the occupy as a pejorative term
question as well and saying that it
probably won't be called occupy when
there's a broader based uh longer term
initiative and the hope is that it's a
way of talking in a way of thinking that
is uh considerate deliberate and uh and
and long term and and and in in that um
in that vein i think we're very likely
to see as uh
as there continue to be uh
a regular practice of public outrage all
over the middle east and all over the
world that ameri burned that americans
hone that practice as well that we
remember
something we forgot it seems in the 70s
80s
90s
up until occupy for a great long time in
a lot of our major cities that uh
showing up for one day and marching
against uh iraq war one or iraq war two
is not going to to cut it and that a
longer term
uh sacrifice a longer term initiative a
longer term participation in
speaking to power however you call it
is an absolutely essential american
value and absolutely essential personal
skill one that you develop along with
your trade skill
your social skill your
your other skills so i think as we begin
to find individuals cultivating that
dimension we will also see america
join the world's uh many of the world's
struggles against uh corporatism and
government malfeasance
thank you let's go debra
take us home so i thought the point
about the global nature of this is
really important there were
occupied movements throughout the world
in addition to the impetus of the
revolutions that you were talking about
that sparked
a lot of this
one of the co-editors of the boston
review josh cohn once wrote a piece
about
how
a lot of people are always late to the
party so he's thinking about the
libertarians who years after
civil rights and women's rights came you
know to say well we're all for liberty
but never participated so i think
there's a critical um you know
importance for
not being late to the party you know so
when you see opposition
to um
grievances that are just that you not
stay on the sideline
so
and they may not be the the opposition
may not be exactly what you wanted but
then you enter into the dialogue that's
the importance of having a beginning but
i i have to put on my academic hat for a
second and say you know opposition is
great is important we need to start we
need hope but we also need analysis we
need economics you know for democracy we
need visions and you know of how things
could be done better and we don't
actually know the answers to lots of
questions about
just how to organize a just economy that
are critically important so that
the more we can
develop
programs not you know from on high but
that enter into the conversation about
here's what the possibilities are here
are you know different ways of doing
this here is the reason why the you want
to change these laws here's what would
happen the more that we do that the
better so for those of you who are
engaged in practices of you know
studying and thinking about things
there's a lot of work to be done
in addition to
joining the party
thanks
thank you very much let's thank our
panel
so there's a reception there's a
reception um in the back and all of your
warmly invited to participate
and they look like they have the same
problems
no i thought it might be